ALL RIGHT GO TO GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME EVERYBODY TO
TODAY'S JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING HOSTED BY THE COMMITTEE
ON PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND THE COMMITTEE
ON ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA
THAT IS A MOUTHFUL LET ME
START BY THANKING ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS FOR YOUR ATTENDANCE
AND PARTICIPATION I KNOW MANY
OF YOU HAVE A TESTED YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULES AND TRAVELED FROM
FAR AND IN SOME CASES FROM
VERY FAR DISTANCES TO BE WITH
US AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
IT I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
INCREDIBLE COMMITTEE STAFF FROM
BOTH COMMITTEES FOR ORGANIZING
THIS HEARING THE SERGEANTS
THE INCREDIBLE FOLKS AT THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND THE OTHER
CAPITAL SUPPORT OFFICERS WHO
HAVE WORKED BEHIND THE SCENES TO
CHORE THIS HEARING RUN SMOOTHLY
AND FINALLY WANT TO THANK MY
FELLOW MEMBERS AND EVERYONE
HERE IN ATTENDANCE FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN THIS BIPARTISAN
ISSUE OF STATE NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL SIGNIFICANCE WHICH
IS PROTECTING CHILDREN ONLINE
IN RECENT MONTHS WE HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC DISCOURSE
ON THIS CRITICAL TOPIC IN
HIS RECENT STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS PRESIDENT BIDEN URGED
ACTION TO PROTECT KIDS ONLINE
NOTING WE MUST HOLD SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
NATIONAL EXPERIMENT THEY'RE
CONDUCTING ON OUR CHILDREN FOR
PROFIT IT'S TIME TO STRENGTHEN
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS BAN TARGETED
ADVERTISING TO CHILDREN DEMAND
THAT TECH COMPANIES STOP
COLLECTING PERSONAL DATA ON OUR
CHILDREN JUST LAST MONTH THE
UNITED STATES SURGEON GENERAL
FOR BACK MURPHY TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES SENATE
REGARDING OUR NATION'S YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS WHICH HE
DUBBED A CRISIS OF LONELINESS
AND HELPLESSNESS DR MURPHY
STATED THE RECENT UBIQUITY OF
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS ESPECIALLY
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS HAS
HAD HARMFUL EFFECTS ON MANY
CHILDREN THAT WENT OUT OF
THE A BENEFIT TO OUR LIVES IN
IMPORTANT WAYS THESE PLATFORMS
HAVE ALSO EXACERBATED FEELINGS
OF ISOLATION AND FOR FUTILITY
FOR SOME YOUTH THEY REDUCE
TIME FOR POSITIVE IN PERSON
ACTIVITIES PITTED KIDS AGAINST
EACH OTHER REINFORCE NEGATIVE
BEHAVIORS LIKE PULLING AN
EXCLUSION IMPEDED HEALTHY
HABITS IN UNDERMINE THE SAFE
AND SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT KIDS
NEED TO THRIVE THE PRESIDENT'S
A DOCTOR MURPHY STATEMENTS
COME INTO THE AFTERMATH OF
EVIDENCE PROVIDED BY THE
FACEBOOK WHISTLEBLOWER FRANCIS
HOW CAN WHO TESTIFIED THAT
FACEBOOK WAS ACTIVELY TRYING TO
RECRUIT KIDS TO THEIR PLATFORMS
DESPITE HAVING KNOWLEDGE OF
THEIR PRODUCTS DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF CHILDREN THE TESTIMONY
REVEALED THAT THESE HARMFUL
IMPACTS OFTEN ARE FACILITATED
BY INTENTIONAL DESIGN CHOICES
SEEKING TO MAXIMIZE ENGAGEMENT
IN PURSUIT OF CORPORATE PROFITS
HER TESTIMONY ALSO REINFORCED
WELL FOUNDED CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW TECHNOLOGY AND SOCIAL MEDIA
IN PARTICULAR IMPACTS YOUNG
PEOPLE ON A WIDE VARIETY OF
ISSUES INCLUDING BODY IMAGE
ANOREXIA ADDICTION ANXIETY
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDAL IDEATION
FRANKLY I'M CONCERNED I'M
CONCERNED BOTH AS A LEGISLATOR
AND AS A PARENT OVER
THE PAST TWO DECADES WE'VE
PASSED NUMEROUS LAWS BOTH
STATE AND NATIONAL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN ONLINE BUT LISTENING
TO THE TESTIMONY OF DOCTOR
MERCY OF FRANCIS HOW CAN OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND EXPERIENCING
THIS FIRST HAND AS A PARENT
I'M NOT SURE THOSE LAWS ARE
PROTECTING YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
WAYS WE INTENDED AS A PARENT
I BELIEVE THAT MY CONCERN
REFLECTS THOSE OF PARENTS IN
THE STATE I WANT MY CHILDREN
TO BE SAFE ONLINE THIS IS A
COMPLICATED IN A SCARY TIME
TO BE A PARENT AT THE VERY
LEAST I WANT TO EXERCISE SOME
CONTROL OVER THE CONTENT TO
WHICH MY CHILDREN ARE EXPOSED
AND I WANT THEM TO HAVE ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE MATERIALS
AND TOOLS AS THEY LEARN HOW
TO RESPONSIBLY NAVIGATE THE
DIGITAL WORLD THEMSELVES
A FEW FINAL OBSERVATIONS WE
HAVE INTENTIONALLY ENTITLED
THIS HEARING CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH REFLECTS
BOTH THE TREMENDOUS BENEFITS
OF INNOVATION IN THE STATE
THE BENEFITS TO YOUNG PEOPLE
IN FAMILY OF TECHNOLOGY BUT
ALSO THE POTENTIAL RISKS AND
HARMS AND I BELIEVE THAT ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE CALIFORNIA
HAS BOTH AN OPPORTUNITY AND AN
OBLIGATION TO LEAD AS A WORLD
LEADER IN TECHNOLOGY MANY OF
THESE ARE HOME GROWN CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES THAT ARE CREATING
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THAT
CAN ENRICH PEOPLE'S LIVES BUT
WE ALSO HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE DOING WHAT
IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WE ALSO HAVE A
POTENTIOMETER OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO ACT IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION
THIS MAY BE ONE OF THE ONLY
ISSUES ON WHICH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTON
DC AND SACRAMENTO HAVE FOUND
COMMON CAUSE I ALSO WANT TO
SET OUT THE SCOPE OF THIS
HEARING THERE OBVIOUSLY
A LOT OF ISSUES INVOLVING
PROTECTING CHILDREN ONLINE --
CRIMINAL ACTS INCLUDING CHILD
EXPLOITATION HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THE SALE OF DRUGS FRAUD AND
SO ON THOSE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES
BUT MANY OF THOSE ISSUES ARE IN
THE JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND WHILE THEY
OVERLAP WITH A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO FOCUS OUR CONVERSATION
ON EXPERIENCES WHILE NOT ILLEGAL
THAT CAN IMPACT CHILDREN ONLINE
IMPACT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH IN
THEIR PHYSICAL WELL BEING AT THE
CONCLUSION OF EACH PANEL WE WILL
OPEN THE DISCUSSION TO MEMBERS
SO MEMBERS PLEASE RESERVE YOUR
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANELISTS
INTEL THEN AND WE WILL ALSO SET
ASIDE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE END OF THIS HEARING I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THE DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY WILL BE INFORMATIVE
FOR US AS A COMMITTEE AND FOR
THE LEGISLATURE MORE BROADLY AS
WE WORK TO COLLECTIVELY CREATE
A SAFER DIGITAL WORLD FOR OUR
CHILDREN WITHOUT IT LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH THE
CHAIR OF THE ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM AN INTERNET
COMEDIAN FOR HER OPENING REMARKS
I AM THAT I ECHO MY CO CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL'S
REMARKS WHEN WE MAKE WHICH
MAKES CLEAR THAT ALL WITNESSES
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY SWIM AND THE
PUBLIC WATERS CHANGED BY
THE REVELATIONS OF FACEBOOK
WHISTLEBLOWER FRANCIS HELGHAN
QUOTING FROM -- THE BACK
PAPER HOW CAN SUCCULENTS AND
TESTIMONY PORTRAYS THE EXTENT
OF FACEBOOK'S KNOWLEDGE AS TO
THE EFFECTS OF MENTAL HEALTH
ON CHILDREN AS WELL AS THE
COMPANY'S EFFORTS TO RECRUIT
CHILDREN ON TO THE PLATFORM
NONE THE LESS THE COMMITTEE
BACKGROUND REMINDS US THAT
CHILDREN CAN BE ADDICTED TO
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THE DICTION
CAMBIUM IN A PARADE BY SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS THE HEARING
BACKGROUND INFORMS US THAT
WHILE MOST SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS OFFICIALLY PROHIBIT
CHILDREN UNDER THIRTEEN FROM
REGISTERING AS USER USERS MANY
MANY CHILDREN UNDER THIRTEEN
DO MANAGE TO REGISTER ON THE
PLATFORMS AND ARE WELL AWARE
OF THIS AND CATER TO THIS AGE
GROUP DESPITE THIS PROHIBITION
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE WE TALK
ABOUT OPPORTUNISM CHALLENGES
AND WE LOOK BACK IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS YOU KNOW I THINK THE
WON'T OTHERS THERE'S A FLIP SIDE
OF ALL THIS WHERE WE WANT TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN BUT WE KNOW
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS HAVE
SERVED OUR CHILDREN I PERSONALLY
DON'T ALLOW MY KIDS ON INSTAGRAM
FACEBOOK TECH TOP SNAPCHAT I
DON'T ALLOW THAT AS A PARENT
MY KIDS ARE FOURTEEN ELEVEN AND
I THINK I'VE AS A LEGISLATOR
I THINK I KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT
THE HUMAN TRAFFIC INSIDE AND
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MY KIDS AND SO THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE ON THOSE PLATFORMS
THE PLATFORMS LIKE DISCORD
OR YOU TO MY DAUGHTER TAUTER
CROCHET LAST WEEK WHILE I WAS UP
HERE TELL US ALL HOW TO CROCHET
A BECAUSE YOU WATCH A TWO MINUTE
VIDEO ON YOUTUBE SO THERE ARE
BENEFITS OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS SO HOW DO WE KEEP THE
BENEFITS AND THAT INNOVATION BUT
HOW DO WE THEN REALLY PROTECT
OUR KIDS FROM THE KIND OF SHADOW
SIDE OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND THAT'S
THE BALANCE I THINK WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S CONSUMPTION WE KNOW
THIS DEPENDENCE ON IT SO HOW
DO WE TAKE THESE FORMING BRAINS
AND AND ENSURE THAT ALL PARTIES
WHETHER THAT'S PARENTS SCHOOLS
GOVERNMENT BY THE PLATFORMS
THEMSELVES ALL ARE ROWING IN
THE SAME DIRECTION TO PROTECT
OUR KIDS AND I THINK THERE'S
MORE WE COULD DO AND THAT'S THE
QUESTION HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET
OUT OF TODAY'S HEARING IS HOW
DO WE BALANCE THAT ALL OUT AND
SPECIFICALLY I HAVE THAT I HAVE
TO WHAT SHOULD WE AT THE STATE
LEVEL TWO I KNOW I'VE DONE ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING -- WEBINARS
FOR PARENTS AND MY DISTRICT WITH
OUR LOCAL DA ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO EDUCATE PARENTS AND
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT HAPPENS
IS INCREDIBLY DISTURBING SO
WHAT ARE THE PROTECTIONS THAT
WE CAN HAVE ESPECIALLY AT WHEN
I LOOK AT MIKE LONG COMMITTEE
NAME WE JOKE THAT THEY GAVE ME
A COMMITTEE NAME LONGER THAN
MY ACTUAL NAME -- AND
SO BUT ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT INTERNET MEDIA INTERNET MEDIA
IS REALLY THE CONTENT SIDE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE INTERNET
AND THAT INCLUDES A LOT OF OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS SO I'M
LOOKING AT FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE
AS A CHAIR AND REALLY WELCOME
THE MEMBERS OF MY COMMITTEE
HERE WHO -- FOR JOINING US AND
REALLY PARTICIPATING IN THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- CHAIR
FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON SO MANY
ISSUES AND ALSO WANT TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CRISTINA GARCIA
WHO I KNOW HAS AN INTEREST IN
A LOT OF THESE ISSUES AS WELL
-- NOW GOING TO ASK OUR FIRST
PANEL TO -- COME UP AND JOIN
US AND -- THEY ARE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING HOW DIGITAL MEDIA
AFFECTS THE EXPERIENCES AND
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND
WE'RE ALSO GONNA HAVE A SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO INCORPORATE THE
VOICES OF YOUNG PEOPLE INTO OUR
HEARING WE'LL BEGIN WITH VICKY
HARRISON WHO IS THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT THE STANFORD CENTER
FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING SHE HOLDS A MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK IN MANAGES OVER A
DOZEN PROJECTS PROMOTING EARLY
INTERVENTION STIGMA REDUCTION
AND INCREASED ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AGES TWELVE TO TWENTY FIVE MS
HARRISON WELCOME YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
M. CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT IS
OF GREAT IMPORTANCE TO ME AS A
CITIZEN A PARENT AND AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH SOCIAL WORKER WHOSE WORK
FOCUSES ON SUPPORTING THE WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS
AND FAMILIES RECENTLY THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DEBATE ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF SOCIAL MEDIA USE
ON YOUTH AND RISING CONCERN
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR
CHILDREN IN THE PAST SIX MONTHS
WE'VE RECEIVED AN ADVISORY FROM
THE U. S. SURGEON GENERAL AN
EMERGENCY DECLARATION FROM THREE
NATIONAL LEADING CHILDREN'S
HEALTH ASSOCIATIONS AND A CALL
TO ACTION FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN
IN HIS STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS FROM MY VANTAGE POINT
WORKING AS A PROGRAM DIRECTOR
WITHIN THE FIELD OF YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH I CAN CONFIRM THAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IS REAL
AND HAS BEEN BUILDING FOR YEARS
THE DEGREE TO WHICH SOCIAL
MEDIA IS CONTRIBUTING TO THIS
CRISIS IS STILL UNCLEAR AND
MUCH MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THE
HEAVIEST USERS OF SOCIAL MEDIA
OUR CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
WHOSE DEVELOPING BRAINS AND
LIMITED LIFE EXPERIENCE LEAVE
THEM SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RISKS OF MEDIA USE ON
PLATFORMS NOT DESIGNED WITH
THEIR BEST INTEREST IN MIND
THERE'S NO TURNING BACK TO
AN ERA WHEN THESE INNOVATIONS
WERE NOT EMBEDDED IN THE DAILY
EXPERIENCES OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
OR IN OUR SOCIAL FABRIC FROM
COMMERCE TO EDUCATION TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS ITSELF BUT
WE DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE COURSE AND RENEW OUR
APPROACH IN ORDER TO BUILD SAFER
AND HEALTHIER ONLINE COMMUNITIES
LET'S FIRST TAKE A MOMENT TO
CONSIDER WHAT A TYPICAL ONLINE
EXPERIENCE LOOKS LIKE FOR A TEAM
TODAY THE TECH THEIR FRIENDS
ON AND OFF THROUGHOUT THE DAY
BOTH ONE ON ONE OR IN MULTIPLE
GROUP CHATS THEY'LL DECOMPRESS
IN BETWEEN CLASSES WORKSHOPS
OR EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
BY SCROLLING THROUGH THEIR
FEEDS USUALLY ACROSS FORTY
FIVE DIFFERENT SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS PER DAY THE LIKE
COMMENT AND SHARE INSPIRING
STORIES OR FUNNY MEMES AND
POSTS PHOTOS THAT THEY RE TAKEN
EDITED AND DELETED SEVERAL TIMES
BEFORE THEY LOOK JUST RIGHT
THEY'LL SPEND HOURS GAMING WITH
FRIENDS CHATTING WITH FAMILY
GETTING LOST IN FUNNY VIDEOS
OR STREAMING EPISODES OF THEIR
FAVORITE SHOWS THOSE THE THE
LATEST NEWS STORIES THROUGH
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA FEEDS THEY
ACCESS SCHOOL ITSELF THROUGH
AN EDUCATIONAL PORTAL PORTAL
SUCH AS GOOGLE CLASSROOM AND
REGULARLY USE SEARCH ENGINES
OR YOUTUBE FOR HOMEWORK RESEARCH
OR HOW TO VIDEOS THE IMAGES
THEY SEE WILL BE HEAVILY CURATED
MANY WILL MAKE THEM SMILE AND
LAUGH BUT JUST AS MANY WILL MAKE
THEM FEEL ENVIOUS AND INSECURE
DON'T WONDER WHY THEY DON'T
LOOK LIKE THAT OR WHAT FILTERS
WERE USED AS THEY SCROLL THE
CONTENT ALL STARTS TO LOOK THE
SAME BUT THEY CAN'T PULL AWAY
MISINFORMATION IS EVERYWHERE
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT CONTENT AND
HATE SPEECH IS COMMON THEY'LL
SEE DISTURBING IMAGES ON A
REGULAR BASIS BUT NOT REPORT
THEM TO THE PLATFORM SINCE THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IT WILL DO MUCH
GOOD THEY WON'T TALK TO THEIR
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS ABOUT THE
DISTURBING THINGS THEY SAW MAYBE
OUT OF EMBARRASSMENT OR FEAR
THAT THEIR PARENTS WILL IMPOSE
RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR ACCESS
AND THEY WILL BE BOMBARDED WITH
TARGETED ADS THAT SEEM TO FOLLOW
THEM WHEREVER THEY GO HE'S
YOUNG PEOPLE TURNED TO SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR CONNECTION CREATIVITY
INFORMATION CURIOSITY AND FUN
BUT THEY'RE HAVING TO WORK
HARDER AND HARDER TO FILTER OUT
THE BAD IN SEARCH OF THE GOOD
AND THEY'RE MOSTLY HAVING TO
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE ONLINE WORLD ON THEIR OWN
IN MY CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE I'VE BEEN TROUBLED BY THE
DEGREE TO WHICH THEIR PERCEIVED
VALUE ON SOCIAL MEDIA SEEMS TO
BE HUSING THAT THEIR EMERGING
IDENTITY NUMBERS OF LIKES
FOLLOWS COMMENTS AND SHARES
HAVE BECOME A SKEWED CURRENCY
OF ADOLESCENTS LIVING UP TO
SOCIAL MEDIA'S EXPECTATIONS HAS
CREATED A POWERLESSNESS THAT
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE COME TO
ACCEPT SEEING OF SOCIALLY VIABLE
ALTERNATIVES IN OTHER WORDS THE
STEEP COST OF BEING A TEENAGER
TODAY WHY DO WE ALLOW THIS TO
BE THE NORM FOR OUR YOUNGEST AND
MOST IMPRESSIONABLE IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE THIS WAY INSTEAD WHY
AREN'T PLATFORMS COMPETING TO
BUILD PRODUCTS THAT MOST EMPOWER
SUPPORT AND INSPIRE OUR YOUTH
STILL ALLOWING FOR INNOVATION
BUT MOVING AWAY FROM THE CURRENT
AD BASED REVENUE MODEL TO ONE
WHERE REWARDS FOLLOW QUALITY
AND AUTHENTICITY OF CONTENT
PROMOTING CONNECTION AND PURE
SELF EXPRESSION RATHER THAN
CURATED FEEDS LIKES CLICKS AND
VIEWS IMAGINE THE EFFECT SUCH
A VIBRANT SPACES COULD HAVE ON
OUR COLLECTIVE MENTAL HEALTH
IN ORDER TO TRULY CONSIDER THE
BEST INTERESTS OF YOUTH ONLINE
THEY NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
DESIGN OF THE PRODUCTS INTENDED
TO SERVE THEM MANY WILL TELL
YOU THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE SOCIAL AND MEDIA ENVIRONMENT
CHANGE FOR THE BETTER AND THEY
WANT MORE SUPPORT FROM PARENTS
MENTORS AND POLICY MAKERS TO
PROTECT THEIR WELL BEING SO
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO HEAR FROM
A FEW OF THEM TODAY AND VIA
VIDEO I'VE BROUGHT WITH ME THE
VOICES OF SEVERAL YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT I WORK WITH ON OUR GOOD
FOR MEDIA PROJECT IT'S A PEER
MENTORING PROGRAM WHERE YOUTH
SHARE THEIR HARD EARNED WISDOM
WITH YOUNGER TEENS AND TWEENS
TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE A MORE
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA THE PROJECT CHALLENGES
THEM TO REFLECT ON QUESTIONS
SUCH AS WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU
GIVE YOUR YOUNGER SELF BEFORE
GETTING YOUR FIRST PHONE WHAT
STRATEGIES DO YOU USE ONLINE
TO PROTECT YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
AND RELEVANT TODAY IF YOU COULD
ADVISE POLICY MAKERS WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SEE CHANGE HERE'S
WHAT SOME OF THEM HAD TO SAY
BUYS LAWMAKERS AND SOCIAL MEDIA
APPS TO CHANGE ONE THING I'D ASK
THEM TO EVOLVE THEIR TECHNOLOGY
TO BEING MORE WELL ROUNDED FOR
EXAMPLE SERVING MORE POINTS OF
VIEWS -- BECAUSE I THINK THAT
A LOT OF THE TIME PEOPLE FALL
UNDER RABBIT HOLES OF SEEING
THE SAME PERSPECTIVES AND SAME
POSTS AND THINGS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND THAT MICROTARGETING
OF CONTENT REALLY AFFECTS YOUR
SELF PERCEPTIONS AND PERSONAL
PERCEPTIONS TOWARDS OTHER
PEOPLE AND I THINK THAT A LOT
OF TIME THIS LEADS TO FORCED
IDEAS AND THOUGHTS AND I THINK
THAT THE LACK OF THE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES CAUSES PEOPLE
TO COMPARE THEMSELVES TO WHAT
THEY SEE ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
THESE IDEALIZED VERSIONS OF
WHAT THEY SEE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND I THINK THAT WHEN PEOPLE
BECOME CAUGHT UP IN THIS FALSE
NARRATIVE THEY GET OVERWHELMED
AND THIS CAUSES MENTAL ANXIETY
AND CAN LEAD TO POOR MENTAL
HEALTH COVERAGE TO ADVISE LAW
OR POLICY MAKERS ABOUT SOCIAL
MEDIA I THINK I WOULD DEFINITELY
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE FACT
THAT A LOT OF USERS ARE TWEENS
-- WHO OR TEENS WHO ARE JUST
UNDER OR AT THE AGE OF THIRTEEN
WHICH IS THE LIMIT OF WHEN YOU
CAN START DRAWING SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND WHILE THIS IS
KIND OF STATE IT AS THE NORM
IT'S NOT REALLY ENFORCED AND
SO -- I FEEL LIKE A LOT OF
CONTENT -- CAN EASILY BE TO
MATURE I'M JUST FOR THAT AGE
-- SO I WOULD REALLY RECOMMEND
AWAY FOR USED TO BE ABLE TO
TURN OFF AND BLOCK AND REPORT
CONTENT THAT'S NOT AS QUITE
AGE APPROPRIATE FOR THEM OR --
JUST A BETTER WAY TO REGULATE
YOU KNOW ON THE AGES OF THESE
USED FOR MYSELF SOMETIMES MAKE
PEOPLE MAKE ME FEEL INSPIRED OR
CREATIVE BUT AT OTHER TIMES IT
CAN MAKE ME FEEL REALLY JEALOUS
OR INSECURE ABOUT MYSELF AND
WHEN I'M EXPERIENCING THOSE SORT
OF NEGATIVE EMOTIONS BECAUSE
OF SOCIAL MEDIA THAT'S WHEN I
KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
ADJUST MY FEET SO THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING ANYTHING IF I WERE TO
GIVE STATE POLICYMAKERS AND
ADULT ALISON VICE BUT HOW TO
MAKE SOCIAL MEDIA A BETTER SAFER
AND HEALTHIER PLEASE PLEASE I
THINK I WOULD SUM IT UP WITH
THE PHRASE STOP CENTERING
PROFIT INSERTS ENTERING YOU TO
CONSUMERS AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS THAT THE COMPANIES WHO
MAKE THESE ALGORITHMS TO CREATE
THESE APPS THEY DO SO WITH THE
PURPOSE OF MAKING MONEY AND
TURNING A PROFIT -- AND AS
A RESULT WHEN THEY RECOMMEND US
CONTENT NEWS INFORMATION AND
SO ON IT'S OFTEN WHAT GETS THE
MOST ENGAGEMENT -- WHAT'S GOOD
IF SOMEONE CLICKS WILL GETS THE
MOST LIKES WILL GET THE MOST
ABSENCE -- BUT THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN THAT INFORMATION
WERE GIVEN OR RECOMMENDED IS
CREDIBLE INFORMED WELL SOURCED
OR NEEDS ANY STANDARD TO BE
CONSIDERED AS ADVISING CALL C.
MAKERS ON WHAT TO DO IN REGARDS
TO SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM TO ENSURE
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
ARE TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE
DATA THEY'RE COLLECTING FROM
YOU AS WELL AS HOW IT'S USED
FOR EXAMPLE THEY SHOULD HAVE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS THAT ARE
MUCH MORE USER FRIENDLY AND
UNDERSTANDABLE ADDITIONALLY
THEY SHOULD HAVE OBVIOUS
WAYS THAT YOU CAN PREVENT OR
LIMIT DATA COLLECTION IDEALLY
THESE DATA COLLECTION LIMITING
OPTIONS WOULD BE LOCKED OUT SO
THE DATA IS NOT AUTOMATICALLY
COLLECTED AT ALL IF I COULD
TALK TO POLICYMAKERS ABOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA I WOULD ADVISE
THEM TO CHANGE RULES REGARDING
HOW SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS CAN
IMPLEMENT ALGORITHMS ON KIDS
ACCOUNTS OTHER THAN THIS MAKE
IT SO THAT SOCIAL MEDIA CAN
BECOME A HUGE TIME SUCK FOR
KIDS WHO MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THE TOOLS OR GUIDANCE TO
HELP THEM NAVIGATE SOCIAL
MEDIA AND SAFE AND HEALTHY WAY
I'LL MAKE IT EASY FOR KIDS TO
BECOME CONSUMED BY SOCIAL MEDIA
I THINK I COULD HAVE THE OPTION
TO TURN OFF THE ALGORITHM THAT
PROVIDES THEM WITH PERSONALIZED
CONTENT SO THEY CAN SET
BOUNDARIES AND TAKE BACK CONTROL
WHEN IT COMES TO SOCIAL MEDIA
THANK YOU YOU'LL NOTICE NONE
OF THESE REMARKABLE YOUNG
LEADERS SAID THAT THEY WANT
TO ELIMINATE SOCIAL MEDIA FROM
THEIR LIVES THEY JUST WANT
TO MAKE IT BETTER AND THEY
HAVE GREAT IDEAS LISTENING TO
THEIR STATEMENTS WE HEAR THESE
CONSISTENT TEAMS MORE CONTROL
PERSONAL CHOICE AGENCY TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
THEY READ SEE AND INTERACT
WITH ONLINE NOT HAVING THEIR
EXPERIENCE MANIPULATED BASED
ON SOMEONE ELSE'S IDEA OF WHAT
THEY THINK THEY SHOULD OR WANT
TO SEE HELPING THEM TO BE MORE
CRITICAL AND THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
WHAT CONTENT THEY'RE INGESTING
AND WHAT IMPACT IT HAS ON THEIR
MOOD OR THEIR FEELINGS HELP
UNDERSTANDING HOW THEIR PERSONAL
DATA IS BEING USED AND GIVING
THEM THE ABILITY TO OPT OUT OF
SUCH USE A DISS I DESIRE
FOR DIVERSITY OF PERSPECTIVES
AND CONTENT PEOPLE BEING REAL
AUTHENTIC NOT PERFORMATIVE
PERFECTED VERSIONS OF THEMSELVES
THAT ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO RELATE
TO OR LIVE UP TO CONSIDERATION
FOR THE ENORMOUS AGE SPAN OF
PEOPLE MIXING WITH AN ONLINE
SPACES AND DOING A BETTER JOB OF
PROTECTING THOSE WHO ARE YOUNGER
AND DON'T YET HAVE THE SKILLS OR
LIFE EXPERIENCE TO MAKE HEALTHY
CHOICES OR MINIMIZE HARMS WE
SIT AT AN INFLECTION POINT
WHERE THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF THE NEXT GENERATION RELIES
ON ADOPTION OF A NEW DESIGN
PARADIGM THAT PLACES A PREMIUM
ON A WELLBEING SAFETY AND
PRIVACY ABOVE OTHER INTERESTS
YET STILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
DRIVE INNOVATION AND COMPETITION
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
BEYOND THE QUESTION OF HOW IS
SOCIAL MEDIA HARMING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO INSTEAD ASK HOW ARE WE
DEFINING AND SUSTAINING A SOCIAL
MEDIA ENVIRONMENT THAT SUPPORTS
THE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS AND CREATIVITY OF
OUR NEXT GENERATION TO ESTABLISH
A NEW SET OF EXPECTATIONS AND
STANDARDS THE PRIORITIZE THE
WELL BEING OF YOUNG PEOPLE
TO CREATE A SAFE HEALTHY
SPACES THEY ARE ASKING FOR AND
DESERVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS HARRIS
AND APPRECIATE THAT -- WE'RE NOW
GOING TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM DR JENNY RADESKY WHO
HAS A DEVELOPMENTAL BEHAVIORAL
PEDIATRICIAN AND ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF MICHIGAN MEDICAL SCHOOL --
HER RESEARCH FOCUSES ON THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN MOBILE
TECHNOLOGY PARENTING PARENT
CHILD INTERACTION AND THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT OF PROCESSES SUCH
AS SELF REGULATION AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING DOCTOR
TESKE WELCOME IF I CAN INVITE
YOU TO MOVE YOUR MICROPHONE
CLOSE YOURSELF WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE CAN HEAR YOU
INCLUDING OUR GOOD FRIEND CHRIS
AND KELLY WHO'S SITTING IN
THE BACK SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO SPEAK
TODAY BUT THE CHAIRS AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU FOR THAT INTRODUCTION
YES I AM A DEVELOPMENTAL
BEHAVIORAL PEDIATRICIAN -- I MY
N. H. FUNDED RESEARCH FOCUSES
ON ALL OF THIS -- MODERN DIGITAL
MEDIA PARENTING AND CHILDREN'S
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT
MY TESTIMONY TODAY -- REPRESENTS
MY EXPERTISE IS A PEDIATRICIAN
AND RESEARCHER -- NOT THE VIEWS
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN
SO WITH TODAY'S TESTIMONY I
HOPE TO ILLUSTRATE HOW THE
DEVELOPMENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
NEEDS OF YOUNG CHILDREN SO BIRTH
TO FIVE YEARS HAVE NOT BEEN
SUFFICIENTLY CONSIDERED IN THE
DESIGN OF THE CURRENT DIGITAL
ECOSYSTEM BUT AT THE SAME TIME
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE GREAT
OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA HAS FOR
IMPROVING EARLY CHILDHOOD AND
ALL CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH ON A
POPULATION SCALE BY MAKING CHILD
CENTERED DIGITAL DESIGN THE NORM
SO I KNOW THAT THE TOPIC OF
YOUNG CHILDREN AND DIGITAL
MEDIA CAN BE CONTENTIOUS I WAS
THE LEAD AUTHOR OF THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS MEDIA GUIDELINES
OFTEN KNOWN AS THE SCREEN TIME
GUIDELINES FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
SO I EXPERIENCED HOW THE PUBLIC
OFTEN RESPONSE TO THIS TOPIC
WITH PANICKED AND POLARIZED
DEBATES HOWEVER CARING ABOUT
CHILDREN'S RELATIONSHIPS WITH
DIGITAL MEDIA SHOULDN'T BE A
SENTIMENTAL OR EMOTIONAL ISSUE
IT'S HIGHLY PRACTICAL AND IT'S
GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH IN MEDICINE
WE'VE REALIZED THE IMMENSE POWER
OF SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
THE STRUCTURAL ENVIRONMENTAL AND
CONTEXTUAL FACTORS THAT SHAPE
PATIENTS OPPORTUNITIES AND RISKS
TOM FRIEDEN THE FORMER DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND ESTABLISH THE IDEA
THAT YOU CAN MAKE MUCH MORE OF
A HEALTH IMPACT BY ADDRESSING
THE ENVIRONMENT MAKING PEOPLE'S
DEFAULT DECISIONS HEALTHY
RATHER THAN TRYING TO INTERVENE
PATIENT BY INDIVIDUAL PATIENT
SO WE OFTEN THINK OF CHILDREN'S
HOUSING ENVIRONMENTS IN THEIR
FOOD ENVIRONMENTS BUT WE SHOULD
ALSO BE THINKING UP THEIR
DIGITAL ENVIRONMENTS NOT JUST
EVERYTHING ON AN INDIVIDUAL
SCALE BECAUSE DIGITAL MEDIA
ARE SOME OF THE MOST UNIVERSAL
AND UBIQUITOUS EXPOSURES THAT
CHILDREN EXPERIENCE ON A DAILY
BASIS AND ARE OFTEN DESIGNED
BY ADULTS UNTRAINED IN THE
CURIOUS AND EXPANSIVE WAYS THAT
CHILDREN EXPERIENCE THE WORLD
SO CONSEQUENTLY DIGITAL DESIGN
OFTEN FOCUSES ON MONETIZATION OR
ENGAGEMENT METRICS AND MAY NOT
CONSIDER THE UNINTENDED NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES ON CHILD USERS
HOWEVER THIS ALSO MEANS THAT
UPDATING THIS RELATIVELY NASCENT
DIGITAL ECOSYSTEM TO BE MORE
CHILD CENTERED MAY HAVE MORE OF
AN IMPACT ON CHILD WELL BEING
THAN ASKING EACH INDIVIDUAL
FAMILY TO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIORS SO THEREFORE I BUILT
MY RESEARCH PROGRAM AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN AROUND
FOCUSING ON MISMATCHES BETWEEN
HOW THE DIGITAL ENVIRONMENT IS
DESIGNED AND CHILDREN'S UNIQUE
DEVELOPMENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
NEEDS SOMETHING TO REVIEW A
FEW OF THOSE EXAMPLES TODAY
SO FIRST EARLY CHARACTER BROOCH
CAREGIVER CHILD RELATIONSHIPS
ARE THE BEDROCK OF LIFELONG
MENTAL HEALTH IT ARE FREQUENTLY
INTERRUPTED AND DISPLACED BY
TECHNOLOGIES AND PLATFORMS
THAT ENCOURAGE PARENTS TO
POST AND REACT AND CONSUME AND
LESS AMOUNTS OF CONTENT OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WHEN PARENTS
ATTENTION AS HEAVILY ABSORBED
IN THEIR MOBILE DEVICES THERE'S
LESS VERBAL AND NONVERBAL
INTERACTION WITH YOUNG CHILDREN
LESS INSIGHT INTO THE MEANING
OF CHILD BEHAVIOR AND OVER TIME
A WORSENING OF CHILD BEHAVIOR
OTHER RESEARCHERS HAVE SHOWN
THAT THESE INTERRUPTIONS REDUCE
CHILDREN'S LEARNING FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND MAKE IT HARDER FOR
PARENTS TO KNOW HOW TO REPAIR
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AFTER A
TOUGH MOMENT SO THIS POINT IS
IMPORTANT WE DON'T NEED TO BE
PERFECT PARENTS ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT RESPONSIVE TO ALL
OUR CHILDREN ALL DAY LONG BUT
DEVELOPMENTAL SCIENCE SHOWS THAT
WHEN CHILDREN AND PARENTS CAN
REPAIR AFTER DIFFICULT MOMENTS
THIS LEADS TO SECURE ATTACHMENT
AND THIS MEANS A STRONGER SENSE
OF SELF AND EMOTION REGULATION
FOR THE CHILD AND THE MISMATCH
HERE IS THAT SILICON VALLEY'S
DESIGN ASSUMPTIONS EMPHASIZE
PERSONALIZATION FOR A SINGLE
USER BUT THIS IS AT ODDS WITH
HOW CHILDREN EXPERIENCE THE
WORLD THROUGH THEIR FIRST
RELATIONSHIPS IT ALSO IGNORES
HOW HARD PARENTS ARE WORKING
RIGHT NOW TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
CHILD CUES AND BEHAVIORS AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING IN THERE
TO ON IN THEIR CHILDREN'S MINDS
WHILE THEIR ATTENTION IS PULLED
IN MULTIPLE DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
SO INSTEAD OF BLAMING PARENTS
ABOUT USING THEIR DEVICES IN
FRONT OF THEIR CHILDREN MY
RESEARCH HAS ASKED WHY THEY DO
THIS AND PARENTS TELL US THAT
DEVICES HAVE A HAWK THEY ARE
COGNITIVELY AND EMOTIONALLY
OVERLOADED FROM THE DEVICES
IN THEIR LAPS OR THEIR POCKETS
AND THEY SAY THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
AS A SOURCE OF SOCIAL SUPPORT
BUT ALSO A LOT OF TOXIC CONTENT
THAT THEY NEED TO WADE THROUGH
SO VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
ADOLESCENTS HAVE SAID IN THOSE
VIDEOS THEY WANT THE SAME SORT
OF CONTROL AN AGENCY OVER THEIR
FEEDS AND I KNOW WE'RE NOT HERE
TO DISCUSS PARENTS MEDIA USE BUT
I THINK THIS POINT ILLUSTRATES
HOW DIGITAL DESIGN HAS
LARGELY IGNORED HER CHILDREN'S
EXPERIENCES ARE INSEPARABLE
FROM THEIR RELATIONAL CONTEXTS
SO SECOND IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
LEARNING HOW TO IDENTIFY AND
MANAGE EMOTIONS IS ANOTHER
FOUNDATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
BUT YOU BAKER JUST DESIGN AND
FRICTIONLESS ACCESS TO MYRIAD
CONTENT MEANS THAT CHILDREN CAN
POTENTIALLY USE GAMES AND VIDEOS
AT ANY TIME OF DAY OR ANY MOMENT
OF BOREDOM THE DIFFICULT THING
ABOUT RAISING YOUNG CHILDREN IS
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY FULL OF A LOT
OF FRICTION A LOT OF NEGATIVE
BEHAVIORS AND PARENT SELF DOUBT
AS CHILDREN LEARN HOW TO INHIBIT
THEIR IMPULSES IDENTIFY HOW
THEIR BRAIN AND BODY YOU'RE
FEELING AND HOW TO MANAGE THAT
FRUSTRATION THIS IS ONE CRITICAL
EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONING SKILLS
ARE DEVELOPING WHICH HAPPENED TO
PLAY AND SENSITIVE INTERACTIONS
WITH CAREGIVERS AND CHILDREN
BEING GIVEN THE FREEDOM TO
EXPLORE AND FAIL AND REPAIR
WITHOUT TECHNOLOGIES DEMANDING
THEIR TIME AND ATTENTION OUR
RESEARCH STUDYING THE TOP APPS
LABELED AS EDUCATIONAL SHOWS
THAT THE MAJORITY ACTUALLY
PROVIDE LOW QUALITY SIMPLISTIC
AND REPETITIVE GAMEPLAY AND
ARE FULL OF DISTRACTIONS SUCH
AS ADS OR VIRTUAL REWARDS
WHAT ALSO CONCERNS EARLY
CHILDHOOD SPECIALISES HOW
DEPENDENT SOME CHILDREN HAVE
BECOME ON USING MEDIA AS A
COMMON TOOL PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL DELAYS
MY RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
EXCESSIVE USE OF MEDIA FOR
CALMING IS LINKED WITH MORE
EMOTIONAL REACTIVITY OVER
TIME A SIGN THAT CHILDREN
ARE NOT LEARNING THEIR OWN
INTERNAL MECHANISMS OF MANAGING
STRONG EMOTIONS AND RECENT
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THIS MAY
ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO PROBLEMATIC
MEDIA USE HABITS IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD SUCH AS RELYING
ON MEDIA FOR COPING THAT WE
THINK MAY CARRY FORWARD INTO
THE TWEEN AND TEEN YEARS
AND THIS WOULD NOT BE IS
CONCERNING OF CHILDREN WERE
REGULARLY ACCESSING POSITIVE
PROGRAMS LIKE DANIEL TIGER'S
NEIGHBORHOOD OR SESAME STREET
EVERY TIME THEY PICKED UP THEIR
MOBILE DEVICE BUT OUR RESEARCH
TRACKING CHILDREN'S TABLETS
AND SMARTPHONES SHOWS THAT
THE FRICTIONLESS APP STORES
HAVE PROVIDED ACCESS TO A WIDE
RANGE OF AGE INAPPROPRIATE
CONTENT WHEN REVIEWING THE APPS
THAT THREE TO FOUR YEAR OLD
CHILDREN IN OUR STUDIES HAVE
USED WE HAVE FOUND APPS WITH
NAMES LIKE TERRORIST SHOOTER
THREE D. FLIPPY KNIFE KICK THE
BUDDY HEAD AND HORROR APPS LIKE
GRANNY SO EVEN WHEN CHILDREN
ARE PLAYING AGE AN APPROACH
AGE APPROPRIATE GAMES ADDS THAT
COME THROUGH AD NETWORKS CAN
HAVE VIOLENT OR INAPPROPRIATE
CONTENT APPLE MARKET PLACES AN
AD NETWORKS CONTINUE TO BE A
PART OF THE DIGITAL ECOSYSTEM
THAT HAVE NOT FULLY GRASP
CHILDREN'S NEEDS DESPITE BEING
A FREQUENT ENTRY POINT FOR
CHILDREN'S ONLINE EXPERIENCES
SO THIS LEADS ME TO MY THIRD
MISMATCH WHICH IS HOW HEAVILY
MONETIZED CHILDREN'S DIGITAL
SPACES ARE DESPITE CHILDREN NOT
FULLY UNDERSTANDING CONCEPTS
LIKE ADVERTISING OR THE VALUE
OF CURRENCY OR PERSUASIVE NUDGES
SO BY TRACKING YOUNG CHILDREN'S
MOBILE DEVICES MY RESEARCH TEAM
REALIZE HOW MUCH TIME CHILDREN
ARE SPENDING ON PLATFORMS
NOT INITIALLY DESIGNED WITH
CHILDREN IN MIND SUCH AS YOU TO
-- NERD WITH COMMON SENSE MEDIA
TO ANALYZE CHILDREN'S YOUTUBE
VIEWING HISTORIES FINDING THEM
THAT THE MAJORITY OF VIDEOS
YOUNG CHILDREN ARE WATCHING
ARE NOT EDUCATIONAL ARE HIGHLY
COMMERCIALIZED AND MANY CONTAIN
VIOLENT OR STEREO TYPES CONTENT
ON SOME CHANNELS WE EXAMINED
DURATION OF ADS EXCEEDED THE
DURATION OF THE VIDEOS SO
ALTHOUGH POSITIVE CONTENT
EXISTS ON LIKE ON YOUTUBE LIKE
CROCHETING CHILDREN APPEAR TO
BE WATCHING WHAT TRENDS AND
ALGORITHMS THAT ELEVATE THE JUNK
UNFORTUNATELY LEAD TO CONTENT
CREATORS TRYING TO PRODUCE
MORE OUTRAGEOUS CONTENT TO
GET MORE CLICKS AND ENGAGEMENT
IN MOBILE APPS MY RESEARCH IS
FOCUSED ON WHERE DIGITAL DESIGN
IS CROSSING THE LINE IN TERMS
OF MANIPULATING CHILDREN ALSO
KNOWN AS DARK PATTERNS INTO
WATCHING MORE ADS PLAYING FOR
LONGER MAKING MORE PURCHASES
IN OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
APPS THAT WE DOWNLOADED PLAYED
EIGHTY PERCENT CONTAINED AT
LEAST ONE TYPE OF MANIPULATIVE
DARK PATTERN THIS COMES IN
THE FORM OF PRESSURE FROM
TRUSTED CHARACTERS NAVIGATION
CONSTRAINTS THAT MAKE KIDS
KEEP PLAYING FABRICATED TIME
PRESSURE PROMISES OF VIRTUAL
CURRENCIES ARE GAME PLAY
OBJECTS OR REWARDS FOR WATCHING
ADS WE'RE FINDING THAT ADULTS
DESIGN NORMS ARE JUST COPIED
AND PASTED SLOPPILY INTO
CHILDREN'S DIGITAL PRODUCTS AND
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY GOOD DESIGN
IN ADDITION WE FOUND
THAT CHILDREN FROM LOWER
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO PLAY APPS WITH
MANIPULATIVE DARK PATTERNS
THEY'RE ALSO MORE LIKELY TO
WATCH YOUTUBE AND MUCH OF
FOR LONGER WHICH SUGGESTS THE
CHILDREN'S DIGITAL OPPORTUNITIES
ARE BEING SHAPED BY WHAT IS
EASILY AVAILABLE AND WHAT IS
FREE THE DEFAULT CONDITIONS
THE DOCTOR FRIEDMAN HAS TALKED
ABOUT ALTHOUGH MY LAB IS
DOCUMENTED THE PREDOMINANCE OF
INAPPROPRIATE DESIGN FEATURES
AND DIGITAL PRODUCTS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE
FOUND MANY CHILD CENTERED --
INDUSTRIES THAT STAND OUT AND
IT'S A RELIEF ON MY RESEARCH
ASSISTANTS PLAY SOMETHING LIKE
PBS KIDS OR KHAN ACADEMY --
TOCA BOCA OR LET GO BECAUSE
THEY DON'T COLLECT DATA THAT
THEY DON'T SERVE ADS THEY
HAVE MEANINGFUL CONTENT THEY
HAVE STOPPAGE CUES TO LET KIDS
DISENGAGE AND GO NUDGED THEM TO
PLAY IN THE THREE D. PHYSICAL
OR SOCIAL WORLDS THEY GIVE
KIDS THE AGENCY AND AUTONOMY
TO CHOOSE WHAT TO DO NEXT AND
THEY REGULARLY EVALUATE THEIR
PRODUCTS TO EACH QUESTION
ALL THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT THEY
MADE AT THE DESIGN OUTSET
WE NEED MORE COMPANIES THAT
SHOW A DUTY OF CARE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE RESPONSIBILITY
INHERENT IN CREATING THE IMAGES
AND STORIES THAT CHILDREN
CONSUME I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT REGULATION THROUGH THE
AGE APPROPRIATE DESIGN CODE
IN THE U. K. DID NOT KILL
THE TECH INDUSTRY BUT ACTUALLY
ALLOWED A LOT OF CHILD CENTERED
IDEAS THAT WERE ALREADY IN THE
PLANNING STAGES WITH CHILD TEAMS
AT GOOGLE OR MATTER OR OTHER
LARGE COMPANIES TO ACTUALLY
COME TO FRUITION AND FINALLY
BE PRIORITIZED IN THE MONTHS
LEADING UP TO THE SEPTEMBER
DEADLINE WHEN THE ADC WENT
INTO EFFECT INSTAGRAM FINALLY
MADE TEENS ACCOUNTS PRIVATE BY
DEFAULT YOUTUBE FINALLY MADE
NIGHT TIME NOTIFICATIONS OFF
BY DEFAULT THESE ARE BASIC
IMPROVEMENTS THAT SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED YEARS AGO BUT
THERE CLEAR SIGNS THAT THESE
CHANGES ARE FEASIBLE AND
THERE'S STILL SO MANY OTHER
INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT INDUSTRY
CAN DESIGN FOR KIDS AND STILL
MAKE PROFITS AND SUMMARY I
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
THIS IS A RELATIVELY NASCENT
INDUSTRY CREATING A RAPIDLY
CHANGING DIGITAL ENVIRONMENT
AND THIS IS THE PERFECT TIME
TO DEBUG WHAT HAS BEEN HASTILY
CREATED AND REDESIGN IT IN A
MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
CHILDREN'S BEST INTERESTS THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY FROM BOTH YOUR
NOW WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND OPEN IT UP TO
-- ANY QUESTIONS OR STATEMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
GARCIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SO WANTED TO GO
BACK TO THE CHILD CENTERED
-- IDEA YOU TALK TO ABOUT
SITES LIKE PBS KIDS THE KHAN
ACADEMY AND I'VE I HAVE
VISITED THOSE SITES AND A FEW
OF THE THINGS THAT THEY DO
THAT ARE CHILD CENTERED --
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
PEPPERMINT DIRECTIONAL LIKE
OUR KIDS ARE IN TECH TALKS
BASED FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM --
DISCORD I JUST RECENTLY
DISCOVERED THAT WE ARE IN
SO WHAT WOULD BE FROM CHILD
CENTERED -- IDEAS THAT THESE
OTHER PLATFORMS CAN BE USING
SO I THINK FIRST OF
ALL THERE'S NOT A SOCIAL
COMPONENT TO A LOT OF THOSE
APPS THEY'RE REALLY MEANT TO
JUST ENGAGE THE USER AND MAYBE
THAT THE CHILD'S PARENTS --
IF YOU WERE ADDING A SOCIAL
COMPONENT I THINK THERE NEED
TO BE DESIGNED FROM THE GROUND
UP ENGAGING FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN NOT JUST RETROFITTING
EXISTING APPS LIKE TICK TOCK
OR DOING OTHER THINGS THAT
JUST CREATE YOU KNOW FILTERS
OR NEW PRIVACY SETTINGS I THINK
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
CHILD CENTERED DESIGN IS YOU'RE
REALLY WORKING WITH FAMILIES
SEEING HOW CHILDREN EXPERIENCE
THESE PRODUCTS TESTING THEM
OUT AND THEN CONTINUING TO DO
ONGOING AUDITS ARE TESTING TO
MAKE SURE THE KIDS ARE USING
THEM IN THE WAYS YOU ANTICIPATED
THERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES SAY
LIKE LEGO HAS LIKE A LIFE WHICH
IS A SOCIAL PLATFORM FOR KIDS
WHERE THEY JUST DON'T SHOW THEIR
FACES THEY DON'T USE THEIR REAL
NAMES BUT THEY CAN SHARE WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IN TERMS OF LIKE
-- BUILDS AND THEY CAN YOU KNOW
COMMENTS -- YOU KNOW AND THERE'S
CERTAIN PROTECTIONS JUST SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT REALLY COMMENTING IN
NEGATIVE WAYS BUT IT'S MORE AGE
APPROPRIATE IN THAT KIDS DON'T
NEED THEIR IMAGE -- TO
BE THE CENTER OF THE ATTENTION
HERE THEIR CREATIVITY SHOULD BE
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION AND I
THINK THAT EACH PRODUCT WOULD
PROBABLY NEED TO THINK THAT WAY
OF HOW DO WE UP LEFT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR CHILDREN
RIGHT HERE RATHER THAN IT BEING
ABOUT WHAT A LOT OF THE SOCIAL
PLATFORMS ARE ABOUT WITCHES
APPEARANCE OR PERFORMANCE OR
YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF METRICS
OF HOW MANY PEOPLE APPROVED OF
WHAT YOU JUST DID YOU KNOW MANY
OF THESE THESE SATIN PLATFORMS
MAY NOT HAVE LAKES OR OTHER
METRICS OF ENGAGEMENT AT ALL
SO SHOULD WE BE RAISING THE AGE
LIMIT FOR THE SOCIAL PLATFORMS
RIGHT NOW SOME OF THEM HAVE AT
THIRTEEN -- I APPRECIATE THIS
OR VETS -- COMMENT
ABOUT HER KIDS NOT BEING ON THE
PLATFORM -- AND AND VISUALLY
BE RAISING THAT AGE LIMIT THEN
THE SORT OF RECOMMENDATION
YEAH I MEAN I WOULD ANSWER THAT
BY LIKE CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
IT'S SORT OF ALL OR NOTHING
LIKE IT'S EITHER YOUR HONOR
YOUR OFF AND THERE'S ONLY ONE
ONLINE WORLD THAT THAT'S FOR
ADULTS FOR KIDS FOR EVERYBODY
SO I THINK CREATING SPACES THAT
ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SO THAT IT CAN BE A SAFE AREA
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO PLAY AND
SOCIALIZE AN EXPERIMENT I THINK
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD RECOMMEND
BECAUSE -- THAT'S WHAT WE DO
IN THE OFFLINE WORLD RIGHT
WE HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE
ENGAGING IN SAFER ENVIRONMENTS
AND WE DON'T JUST THROW THEM
IN WITH EVERYBODY -- SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
RECOMMEND IS DOING SOME MORE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SPACES SO THEY HAVE MORE CHOICES
YEAH I THINK IT'S A MATTER OF
A COMBINATION OF ADJUSTING THE
EXISTING SPACES THAT TEENAGERS
ARE USING THERE'S A STUDY
THAT JUST CAME OUT YESTERDAY
IN NATURE COMMUNICATIONS
TELLING THAT THERE ARE THESE
DEVELOPMENTALLY SENSITIVE
WINDOWS IN THE ADOLESCENT
YEARS WHEN GIRLS MIGHT STRUGGLE
MORE WITH IT DURING THAT KIND
OF ELEVEN TO FOURTEEN AGE
RANGE AND BOYS MORE LATER IN
ADOLESCENCE SO -- THERE MAY
NEED TO BE BOTH -- IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE DESIGN OF THE EXISTING
PLATFORMS I KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE CHILD TEAMS WORKING ON
WAYS TO TRY TO MAKE IT A GRADED
-- AMOUNT OF DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE CONTENT RATHER
THAN AN ALL OR NOTHING ENTRY
INTO YOU KNOW THE ADULT
SOCIAL MEDIA WORLD RIGHT AT
THE AGE OF THIRTEEN WHICH
IS -- RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
RESEARCH HAS SUGGESTED
THAT'S MORE THAN CHILDREN
ONCE AT THAT AGE AND IT'S
MORE THAN IS DEVELOPMENTALLY
SAFE OR APPROPRIATE FOR THEM
I APPRECIATE -- FRAMING IT IN
TERMS OF ADJUSTING WHAT EXISTS
THE CREATING OF A PLATFORM
THAT IS CHILD CENTRED FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING INSIDE I WILL
SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT A NEW
MINDSET THAT YOU PUT IN MY HEAD
MY APPROACH HAS BEEN FOCUSING
ON THE ADJUSTMENT OF EXISTING
PLATFORMS -- VERSUS HAVING
THE DUAL TANDEM FACT THAT YOU
JUST SPOKE TO US ABOUT IT
IN IN THAT ADJUSTMENT OF OF THIS
PART FOR MY HAVE BEEN WORRIED
ABOUT THE ADOLESCENTS AND THE
IMAGES ARE GETTING -- AND HOW
IT IS FEEDING THEIR EATING
DISORDERS -- ALONG THE WAY IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH ALONG THE WAY
-- AND TRYING TO ACTIONS PARENTS
YOU TO THOSE IMAGES OF IT S.
AS THE STARTING POINT OF FLOOR
FOR ADJUSTING THOSE PREFERENCE
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S YOUR
APPROPRIATE POLICY AND I DON'T
KNOW BUT TRYING TO FIND WAYS --
AND SO WHAT ARE SOME AMERICAN
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU HAVE
INSURANCE OF THE ADJUSTMENT SIDE
OF EXISTING SOCIAL PLATFORMS
-- WELL I THINK I MEAN YOU MIGHT
HEAR FROM A TECHNOLOGIST LATER
THAT WOULD HAVE MORE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I THINK
PART OF WHAT WHAT IT SPEAKS TO
IS JUST THE ALGORITHMS THAT ARE
DRIVING CONTENT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IF A YOUNG PERSON WHO'S
CURIOUS AND YOU KNOW EXPLORING
STUMBLES UPON TROUBLING
CONTENT AND INTERVIEWS THAT THE
ALGORITHMS GONNA THINK THEY WANT
TO SEE MORE OF THAT -- SO THAT
SOMETIMES HOW THEY GET TRAPPED
INTO THESE LOOPS OF CONTENT
THAT IS NOT HEALTHY -- AND SO
IF THERE'S MORE CONTROL OVER
YOU KNOW GOING WHERE YOU WANT
TO GO AND SEEING THINGS YOU
WANT TO SEE NOT WHAT'S BEING
FOR STATUTES THAT THAT IS
GOING TO ELIMINATE SOME OF
THE TROUBLING CONTENT THAT'S
THAT THEY'RE BEING EXPOSED TO
AND I CAN GIVE AN EXAMPLE FROM
-- YOUNGER IN CHILDHOOD WE'RE
EXAMINING THAT -- THE THUMBNAILS
THAT ARE OFFERED TO CHILDREN
AT THE END OF YOUTUBE VIDEOS
TO LOOK AT WHAT IS RECOMMENDED
TO THE NEXT AND A LOT OF THOSE
IMAGES CONTAIN A LOT OF EITHER
VIOLENCE OR MANUFACTURED
DRAMA OR A LOT OF JUST VISUAL
OUTRAGEOUS NOUS -- SOME OF IT
SEXUALIZED SOME OF IT MORE --
IT JUST LAVISH AND FULL OF MONEY
AND AND LOTS OF OTHER THINGS
JUST REALLY TRYING TO LURE
CHILDREN TO CLICK THROUGH AND
SO CONTENT CREATORS ARE DOING
THAT BECAUSE THE ALGORITHM HAS
INCENTIVIZE THE MORE CLICKS
IN THE MORE ENGAGEMENT YOU
GET THE MORE AD REVENUE YOU'RE
GOING TO GET SO IF THEY COULD
CHANGE SOME OF THE INCENTIVES
AROUND PROFITS ON THESE SITES
IF THEY COULD CHANGE THE WAY
SOME OF THE -- SUGGESTIONS
FOR WHAT TO CLICK THROUGH NEXT
BECAUSE WHEN I'VE OPENED UP
SNAPCHAT OR OTHER THINGS I
SEE PLENTY OF FEMALE AND MALE
AND OTHER BODIES IN KERR IT AS
PART OF THAT ENCOURAGEMENT TO
TO CLICK THROUGH AND SO IT'S
BECOME PART OF THE ENGAGEMENT
JURISTIC SAYS THAT THAT --
CONTENT CREATORS ARE USING TO
GET MORE ENGAGEMENT AND THAT
MAY BE WHY IT'S JUST BECOME SO
COMMON OUT FOR TEENS TO BE
GOING DOWN THOSE RABBIT HOLES
AND THEN FINALLY -- IF THERE'S
A WAY TO CHANGE THE ALGORITHM TO
ACTUALLY -- GET IT TO ELEVATE
MORE POSITIVE CONTENT CONTENT
THAT PERHAPS HAS BEEN REVIEWED
BY HUMANS AND KIND OF THAT
THERE ARE IS SOME AGREEMENT AND
DEVELOPMENTAL CONSENSUS LIKE
YES THIS IS THE GOOD STUFF THAT
WE WOULD WANT KIDS OF CERTAIN
AGES TO BE SEEING IT WOULD
BE FANTASTIC OF THAT SORT OF
ELEVATION COULD BE HAPPENING
RATHER THAN THE ELEVATION
OF WHAT'S REALLY CLICK BAITY
THANK YOU DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS IT'S A SAYS HE RISK
GIVING YOUR LAST COMMENTS I
COULDN'T HELP BUT THINK ABOUT
THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY AND AND
HOW THEY HAVE AT TIMES USE
HAPTICS TO GET -- FOLKS
HOOKED AT AN EARLY AGE AND
CREATE A LIFETIME YOU SIR OF BAD
HABITS AND SO SOUNDS A LOT LIKE
PRESCRIBING THE VERY SIMILAR
TYPE OF TACTICS WITH OUR CURRENT
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS OUT THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN I KNOW THAT -- CHAIRMAN
FOR HER THAT HAD SOME QUESTIONS
S. THANK YOU AS SOMEBODY
WHO WORKED IN MARKETING
COMMUNICATIONS FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS -- YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THESE PLATFORMS ARE
DOING RIGHT THERE THEY'RE NOT
NONPROFITS THEY'RE NOT THEIR
JOB IS NOT TO LOOK OUT FOR A CUP
PUBLIC GOOD THEY'RE OFFERED A
JOB IS TO OFFER A PLATFORM AND
OUR THINK OUR JOB IS GOVERNMENT
IS HOW DO WE PROPERLY REGULATE
THAT FOR KIDS YOU KNOW I'M USED
TO WORK REGULATE SORRY GUYS --
BUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT THAT YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THE U. S. IS
SAID YOU KNOW THEY WANT THE
OPTION TO TURN OFF THE ALGORITHM
AND THEN YOU ARE TALKING DR IT'S
WEIRD IT'S K. ABOUT YOU KNOW
ARE THEY EVEN ABLE TO DISCIPLINE
THEMSELVES HOW MANY KIDS ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO DISCIPLINE
THEMSELVES TO DO SO AND SO I
DON'T KNOW FROM YOUR RESEARCH IF
YOU HAVE A RECOMMENDATION FOR US
FOR US ABOUT WHAT AT WHAT
AGE YOU CAN ACTUALLY DEAL
WITH THE CURRENT RULES OF THE
PLATFORM I GIVE YOU LOOK AT THE
CURRENT ROLE AS A PLATFORM WITH
THE ALGORITHMS HOW IT DOES --
CONTENT AND THESE MICROTARGETING
I MEAN THAT'S LIKE A MARKETING
THING RIGHT LIKE MOST PEOPLE
WHO DIE MARKEN COMMUNICATIONS
AND SAY THEY DO THIS THEY THEY
CLICKED ON THIS THREE TIMES
DAILY SEARCH FOR THIS PAGE ALL
THAT STUFF AT WHAT AGE CAN YOU
SELF REGULATE TO MAKE THOSE WELL
INFORMED DECISIONS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND I THINK ADULTS STILL
STRUGGLE WITH THAT SORT OF SELF
REGULATION AND AND A LOT OF MY
RESEARCH FOCUSES ON PARENTS OWN
MEDIA USE AND SO IN OUR LATEST
STUDY WE'VE BEEN ASKING PARENTS
ARE WHAT ARE THE DIGITAL DESIGN
-- TECHNIQUES THAT ARE MOST
HELPFUL TO YOU IN SUPPORT OF
AND THEY MENTIONED THINGS LIKE
YOU KNOW WALMART AND TARGET
APPS THERE SO CONVENIENCE THEY
HELPED ME GET THROUGH SHOPPING
AND I CAN THEN GO ON AND LIVE
THE REST OF MY LIFE AS A PARENT
AND THEN WHEN WE ASKED ABOUT
WHAT SORT OF DESIGN FEATURES
ARE UNHELPFUL THEY THEY'VE
UNIFORMLY TALKED ABOUT SOCIAL
MEDIA SITES OFTEN FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM ABOUT HOW THEY GO
INTO THOSE PLATFORMS HOPING
FOR SOME TYPE OF SOCIAL SUPPORT
SEEING THEIR FAMILY HAVING
A LAUGH OR AN ESCAPE FINDING
NEWS ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITY BUT
THAT THEY'RE WAITING THROUGH
LOTS OF OTHER EITHER TARGETED
ADS THAT THEY FIND CREEPY AND
SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE PARENTS
THAT WE INTERVIEWED SAID THEY
DID NOT THINK THAT IT WAS
ETHICAL TO HAVE REALLY TARGETED
ADVERTISING OUT THEM -- AND THEN
THEY WANTED MORE CONTROL ONE
PARENT SAID I JUST WANT FACEBOOK
LITE I WANT THAT VERSION OF
IT WHERE I CAN JUST YOU KNOW
DO YOU SEE THE FAMILY THAT I
WANT TO SEE AND NOT HAVE TO
DEAL WITH ALL THE OTHER EITHER
POLITICAL STUFF OR MARKETING
STAFF OR OR OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE GETTING XCELERATED
BY THE DESIGN FEATURES SO --
THAT IS NOT A SPECIFIC AGE
BUT IT IS AN INDICATION THAT
I THINK ADULTS WOULD BENEFIT
FROM MORE CONTROL AND MORE
TRANSPARENCY FROM A LOT OF
THESE AD TECH PLATFORMS AS WELL
AND THE OTHER THING WHAT WHEN WE
ARE HAVING THIS PANEL THAT I WAS
THINKING ABOUT I WAS BORN IN THE
SEVENTIES AND A LOT OF THINGS
WE'RE DEALING WITH IS JUST ARE
JUST AMPLIFIED TO THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM RIGHT WHERE MARIE
CLAIRE AND COSMETOLOGISTS HOW
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AS WOMEN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MAN HAD THAT
THAT'S WHAT I HAD AND YOU KNOW
SO A LOT OF THAT BODY DYSMORPHIA
THAT WE HAVE THE WIND PHOTOSHOP
PHOTOS WE THOUGHT WE ALL HAD
TO LOOK LIKE KATE MOSS AND I
CAN TELL YOU I WAS NEVER GONNA
LOOK LIKE KATE MOSS YOU KNOW AND
SO HOW HOW THE AND THAT'S BEEN
AMPLIFIED THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
AND THE FILTERS NOW AND AND HOW
PEOPLE REALLY RELATE TO THAT
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED BECAUSE
AT THE TIME WHEN WE HAD PRINT
MEDIA WHICH IS OUR PRIMARY FOR
MEDIA OR TV WHERE HE WE HAD ADS
TARGETING KIDS FOR CIGARETTES
FOR EXAMPLE SMOKING --
YOU KNOW WE NOW HAVE IT MUCH
QUICKER AND MUCH MORE DIFFUSE
DECENTRALISED WAY AND YOU KNOW
I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT --
YOU KNOW AT SOME POINT THE FCC
REQUIRED FOR EVERY ANTI OVER
EVERY TOBACCO ADD EQUAL AIR
TIME FOR ANTI SMOKING ADS
RIGHT SO THERE THERE WE HAVE
A SYSTEM FROM BACK IN THE DAY
BEFORE SOCIAL MEDIA OF WHERE
WE THOUGHT WE SAID OKAY THERE'S
A PRIVATE MARKET RIGHT THEY
HAVE A FOR PROFIT COMPANIES
BUT WE HAVE AS A GOVERNMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR REGULATING
THE PUBLIC GOOD SIDE OF THESE
PLATFORMS -- SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU KNOW WE CAN THINK
ABOUT -- AND THE OTHER THING
THAT I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THE EATING DISORDERS AMONG
GIRLS DURING THE PANDEMIC IN
OUT THE PANDEMIC REALLY FORCED
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON I KNOW
FIRST ALL OF OUR YOUTH ONLINE
WHICH WAS GREAT MY SON GOT TO
THE PANDEMIC HAS HIM AS FIVE
BODIES COULD GAME AND THEY
COULD CHAT AS IF THEY WERE IN
PERSON SO HE WAS PERFECTLY FINE
RIGHT -- BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND I KNOW OF MANY CASES EVEN
IN MY OWN FAMILY WHERE WHERE
CROSS OF BECOME ANOREXIC AND
PART OF THAT IS THE SOCIAL
MEDIA REALLY TARGETING THAT
AND I KNOW THE PLOT FROM SAY
WE DON'T DO THIS BUT YOU NO
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ESPECIALLY
ON THE EATING DISORDER SIDE
OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING TO
PROTECT OUR YOUTH -- AND NO
NOT IT'S NOT ONLY GIRLS WHO
ARE AFFECTED BY INTERAKSYON BUT
LARGELY IT'S IT'S OUR OUR YOUNG
GIRLS DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
AROUND EATING DISORDERS HOW
SOCIAL MEDIA EXACERBATES IT AND
WHAT MAYBE WE SHOULD BE DOING
YEAH HI THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS I THINK ONE THING THAT
COMES TO MIND IS JUST THAT THE
DESIRE AND YOU HEARD IT FROM
SOME OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
JUST MORE DIVERSE CONTENT AND
IT'S BECAUSE I THINK SOME OF
WHAT DOCTOR TESKE SAID JUST
ELEVATING A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF QUALITY OF CONTENT BECAUSE
SINCE SO MUCH OF WHAT IS BEING
REWARDED ONLINE IS YOU KNOW
LIKE -- ADS RELATED
TO DIETING OR INNOVATING
SUITS IT A LOT OF IT IS IT'S
VERY VERY MUCH DRIVEN BY
THE CERTAIN STANDARDS OF BEAUTY
THEY JUST KEEP THE JUST YOU KNOW
AS YOU SCROLL YOU'RE JUST SEEING
MORE AND MORE MORE OF THAT SO
I THINK AND YOUNG PEOPLE THEY
JUST THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
AND THEY LIKE THEY'RE FRUSTRATED
BY IT THEY WANTED TO SEE THEIR
FRIENDS AND AND THEY WANT TO
GO ON THERE FOR YOU KNOW TO UP
LIFT THEIR MOOD SO I THINK IF
IF THERE WAS THE ABILITY FOR
MORE DIVERSE AND MORE AUTHENTIC
CONTENT TO BE ELEVATED TO HAVE
THAT GET MORE WEIGHT -- OTHER
THAN JUST THE KIND OF THE CHEAP
ADS AND CHEAP -- CLICKBAIT
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
AND THEN THEY WOULD ENGAGE WITH
THAT AND THEN THAT WOULD GET
REWARDED SO I THINK THAT WOULD
BE PART OF IT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE SEEING JUST THE CITY OF
MONOLITHIC -- WORLD WHEN YOU
GO ON A SCROLL AND THAT'S
NOT HELPING SOMEONE THAT'S
VULNERABLE TO AN EATING DISORDER
I THINK THAT THE MAIN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOU KNOW GROWING UP IN
THE EIGHTIES AND GOING INTO A
DRUG STORE AND GETTING UP MARIE
CLAIRE COSMOPOLITAN THAT YOU
WENT AND YOU HAD THE AUTONOMY
TO KIND OF CHOOSE FROM WHAT WAS
OFFERED TO YOU ON THE AISLES
IT WASN'T FED TO YOU DIRECTLY
BASED ON WHAT PRIOR THINGS YOU
HAD READ OR EVEN HOVERED OVER
AND SO I THE WAY I THINK ABOUT
THAT YOU KNOW A COMPARISON
SAY TO FOODS THAT WE YOU
KNOW WE CAN'T GET RID OF FOOD
ENTIRELY AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
HEALTHIER FOODS AND OTHER
FOODS THAT ARE YOU KNOW JUNK
HERE AND WE WANT TO LIMIT YOU
DON'T GO INTO A GROCERY STORE
AND HAVE AN ALGORITHMICALLY
PREDICTIVE YOU KNOW AS
A SORT OF DESIGN FEATURE JUST
PUTTING THINGS IN YOUR BASKET
AND THEN NOT LETTING YOU SEE
ALL THE OTHER HEALTHIER FOODS
OR THE OTHER MAGAZINE IANS THAT
MIGHT ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE OTHER
PARTS OF YOU AS A TEENAGER AND
SO I THINK THAT -- ALGORITHMIC
TARGETING AND NARROWING IT
WHETHER IT HAPPENS BECAUSE
-- YOU KNOW IN THAT LAST JULY
THERE WERE REPORTS FROM RESET
AUSTRALIA THAT FACEBOOK WAS
ALLOWING TARGETING FROM OUTSIDE
MARKETERS TWO TEENAGERS BASED ON
A TOPIC LIKE EXTREME DIETING OR
INTEREST IN DIETING OR FITNESS
BUT FACEBOOK ALSO KNOWS ENOUGH
ABOUT ITS USERS THAT IT COULDN'T
IT CAN ELEVATE CONTENT OR IT
CAN AT ITSELF TARGET ADVERTISING
BASED ON WHAT IT KNOWS IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO OFFER
THAT TO A THIRD PARTY ADVERTISER
IT CAN DO IT THROUGH ITS OWN
MECHANISM SO THE MORE WE CAN
LET THERE'D JUST BE MORE OF
A BLANK SLATE AND AND LESS OF
THIS NARROWING IN TARGETING
WHICH CERTAINLY CAN IDENTIFY
CHILDREN'S VULNERABILITIES
THAT THEY MAY NOT EVEN REALIZE
THEY HAVE THEMSELVES IT COULD
BE DIETING AND ADDS LOW BODY
IMAGE IT COULD BE IMPULSE
CONTROL ISSUES THAT COULD BE
ANXIETY OR SELF HARM OR YOU
KNOW OTHER ISSUES THAT WE WE
GEN SEE QUITE A LOT OF RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS REMEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA
JUMP IN THANK YOU SO I JUST I'M
MR ISN'T SOMETHING YOU SENSE
-- STUCK OUT TO ME -- AND THAT
WAS THAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
YOU WORK WITH HAVE REPORTED
THAT THEY -- ARE HESITANT TO
REPORT TOXIC CONTENT AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING I HEAR A
LOT FROM FOLKS IN THE INDUSTRIES
THAT WE HAVE MECHANISMS TO DEAL
WITH THAT SINCE I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHY THAT IS WHY DO THE YOUNG
PEOPLE FEEL HESITANT TO DO THAT
YEAH THAT WOULD AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING WE HEARD FROM THEM
AND WE -- ASKED WHAT THEY DO
WHEN THEY SEE THINGS THAT THEY
DON'T LIKE AND THEY JUST SAY
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S GONNA DO
ANY GOOD AND SOME OF THEM HAVE
REPORTED AND THEY JUST LIKE
IT'S SORT OF TOO LATE AT THAT
POINT BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY
SEEN THE DISTURBING IMAGE OR
WHATEVER IT WAS IT'S NOT GOING
TO REALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM --
AND SO THEY JUST DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF FAITH THAT IT'S GOING
TO DO ANYTHING OR IT'S IT'S
SORT OF TOO LITTLE TOO LATE
THANK YOU THE OTHER -- SORT
OF BIGGER QUESTION I HAVE FOR
YOU AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GET A
MOVE ON IT'S A LITTLE BIT OUT
OF LEFT FIELD BUT I'M CURIOUS
TO GET YOUR REACTIONS TO IT
IS TWO PEOPLE THAT SPEND A LOT
OF TIME THINKING ABOUT THESE
ISSUES ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
IMPACTS ON YOUNG PEOPLE -- AND
THEN PARTICULAR ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS WHAT
WHAT THE LONG TERM IMPACTS MIGHT
BE RIGHT I THINK WE HAVE SOME
RESEARCH ON WHAT THE IMPACTS
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE SHORT
TERM -- BUT THINK ABOUT WHAT
THEY MIGHT BE IN THE LONG TERM
AND I WAS READING IN THE -- THE
ACTUAL BACKGROUND PAPER HERE
THAT THAT SCREEN TIME ON RELATED
TO SCHOOL MORE THAN DOUBLED FOR
AMERICAN TEENAGERS UP TO SEVEN
POINT SEVEN HOURS PER DAY SO
MAKES ME THANK YOU KNOW WE HAVE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE SPENDING
A THIRD OF THEIR OF THEIR DAY
YOU KNOW PROBABLY HALF OF THEIR
WAKING TIME IMMERSED ON THESE
PLATFORMS AND SO YOU KNOW WE'VE
HEARD AND AND AND MISS GARCIA
BROUGHT THIS UP AND AND THAT
CHAIR BROUGHT IT UP AND I'VE
HEARD FROM OTHER COLLEAGUES ONE
ANALOGY WHICH IS THE ANALOGY TO
TOBACCO AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
A VERY POWERFUL ANALOGY IN SOME
WAYS RIGHT YOU'VE GOT A PRODUCT
THAT IS POTENTIALLY ADDICTIVE
THERE'S INTERNAL RESEARCH FROM
THE COMPANY THAT SHOWS THAT IT'S
POTENTIALLY ADDICTIVE THAT IT
YOU KNOW HIS BAD OUTCOMES FOR
FOR FOLKS -- AND AND POTENTIALLY
HELP LONG TERM HEALTH IMPACTS
YOU KNOW HURTFUL IMPACTS TO
PEOPLE'S HEALTH AND SO OBVIOUSLY
-- AT BOTH THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE'VE TAKEN AN
APPROACH TO REGULATING TOBACCO
THE OTHER ANALOGY THAT I'VE
HEARD WHICH I WHICH I HEARD FROM
A CONVERSATION WITH SOMEONE IN
THE INDUSTRY WHO WORKS FOR ONE
OF THESE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
WAS THE ANALOGY OF THE SEAT
BELT WHICH IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
INVENTED THE CAR THE CAR WAS A
GREAT INVENTION AND IT PROVIDED
A LOT OF GREAT -- ALTERNATIVES
AND BENEFITS TO PEOPLE -- AT
THE SAME TIME WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE WERE SOME REST ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT AND SO WE MANDATED
PEOPLE TO WEAR SEAT BELTS --
AND SENATE WONDERING JUST WHICH
OF THOSE ANALOGIES SPEAKS TO
YOU UNDERSTANDING SORT OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE ISSUES AT STAKE
ARE WE IN THE WORLD OF OF OF
TOBACCO SHOULD WE BE SHOULD WE
BE USING THAT AS THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK ARE WE IN THE WORLD
OF SEAT BELTS WERE WERE WERE
WORKING GREEN I'M JUST CURIOUS
OUT PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES
BECAUSE THE FOCUS OF THIS
HEARING IS ON KIDS ON YOUNG
PEOPLE -- WOULD YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS MORRIS TOBACCO OR DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THIS MORE SEAT BELTS
-- I'VE OFTEN USED THE ANALOGY
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE
AROUND AUTOMOBILES AND DRIVING
-- SO THAT RESONATES WITH ME
-- BECAUSE IF YOU THINK ABOUT
ALL OF THE STEPS THAT ARE PUT
INTO PLACE FOR DRIVING TO TAKE
PLACE THERE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH STOP SIGNS STOPLIGHTS
THERE'S SAFE ROADS THERE'S YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LICENSING
PROCESS TO LEARN HOW TO DRIVE A
CARD BE APPROVED TO DRIVE A CAR
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF STEPS
AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S IN
THERE TO SUPPORT YOU AS PARENTS
WE TEACH OUR KIDS HOW TO LOOK
BOTH WAYS AND CROSS THE STREET
BUT WE'RE ALSO RELYING ON ALL OF
THAT AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BE MAKING IT A STATE STREET FOR
THEM TO CROSS SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR WHEN IT
COMES TO THEIR EXPERIENCE ONLINE
WE HAVEN'T REALLY BUILT THAT
SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
THEM AND SO THAT'S THE ONE
THAT I WOULD I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT WE KIND OF GO WITH IT AS A
PARALLEL YEAH I TEND TO
THINK OF THIS MORE AS A PRODUCT
SAFETY ISSUE OF OF PRODUCTS THAT
WE USE AND WE HAVE TO USE ALL
THE TIME RATHER THAN IT BEING
SOMETHING ABOUT AND -- YOU KNOW
A SUBSTANCE THAT WE MAY NOT EVER
NEED TO USE WITH LIKE TOBACCO
-- YOU KNOW I TEND WHEN I THINK
OF YOUNG CHILDREN I THINK OF
THE THE TESTING THAT THE FDA
DOES OF BABY FOODS I THINK OF
THE YOU KNOW TOY TESTING THAT
WE DO TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NOT
LEAD AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
LOW GRADE EXPOSURES IN THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT MAY NOT HAVE
A HUGE EXTREME IMPACTS BUT DO
MATTER CUMULATIVE CUMULATIVELY
OVER TIME AND SO THAT
SORT OF STATE PRODUCTS SAFETY
PARADIGM MAKES MORE SENSE TO ME
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE
WITH US TODAY -- SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND WE ARE GOING TO
TRANSITION NOW -- TO OUR SECOND
PANEL -- IN WERE VERY FORTUNATE
TO HAVE SOME EXCELLENT SPEAKERS
WITH US -- AND THE SECOND PANEL
IS GOING TO FOCUS ON DIGITAL
LITERACY AND ENCOURAGING
HEALTHY TECHNOLOGY PRACTICES
AMONG FAMILIES AND YOUTH SO
WE HAVE FIRST WITH US IS THAT
MERVE LAPUS THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF EDUCATION OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH COMMON SENSE
MEDIA COMMONSENSE HAS LONG
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
PROMOTING DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP
AND LITERACY FOR KIDS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WELCOME
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS -- I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR A REALLY PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT AND PRESSING
ISSUE -- YOU KNOW AS I JUST
KINDA LIKE THINK BACK OF KIND
OF WHEN I WAS A KID AND WHAT
MEDIAN TECHNOLOGY MEANT TO ME IN
SCHOOL AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
NO GONE ARE THE DAYS WHERE IT
WAS THERE'S TWO COMPUTERS IN
THE BACK RIGHT AND I HAD TO
GET EVERYTHING DONE THAT WEEK
SO I CAN GO PLAY ORGAN TRAIL
AND IF I CAN JUST HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO FORGE THE KANSAS RIVER
EVEN JUST GONNA QUIT HUNT YOU
KNOW GET THAT BEAR AND THEN BE
ABLE TO FEED ALL MY PIONEERING
FAMILY BEFORE EVENTUALLY GETTING
SICK OF DYSENTERY WHICH IS LIKE
THE NORM RIGHT YOU ALL KNOW
THE PART THAT WAS THE PROBLEM
RIGHT BUT THAT WAS THE EXTENT
OF DIGITAL MEDIA KIND OF IN MY
LIFE YOU KNOW IT IN SCHOOL AND
AS I THINK ABOUT THESE DAYS OF
THESE DIGITAL MEDIA TECHNOLOGY
PLAYS REALLY A SIGNIFICANT
ROLE AND HOW OUR CHILDREN LEARN
COMMUNICATE SHARE AND CREATE ON
A DAILY BASIS AND IN SOME WAYS
WE'VE HEARD ALMOST EVERY MINUTE
OF THE DAY JUST WITH SOME OF
THE DATA WHICH ARE TODAY AND
YES YOU KNOW ACCESS TO RELIABLE
TECH AND MEDIA IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR KIDS LEARNING BUT WE ALSO
KNOW FROM OUR RESEARCH THAT OUR
KIDS ARE BEING EXPOSED TO MORE
HURTFUL INSENSITIVE SITUATIONS
-- THAT WE MUST ADDRESS AND
THIS EXPOSURE HAS SIGNIFICANT
IMPLICATIONS ON OUR KIDS MENTAL
HEALTH ON A RECENT STUDY WE
DID AROUND MENTAL HEALTH -- AND
DIGITAL MEDIA WITHOUT SIXTY NINE
PERCENT OF BLACK YOUTH OFTEN
OR SOMETIMES ENCOUNTER REESE'S
CONTENT ONLINE WHEN THEY'RE
ONLINE SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
HISPANIC OR LATIN EXCUSE ARE
OFTEN OR SOMETIMES ENCOUNTERED
RACIST CONTENT ONLINE SEVENTY
FOUR PERCENT OF OUR L. G. B.
T. Q. PLUS YOU'VE OFTEN OR
SOMETIMES ENCOUNTER HOMOPHOBIC
CONTENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
SEVEN IN TEN FEMALE YOUTH
OFTEN OR SOMETIMES ENCOUNTER
SEXIST OR BODY SHAMING CONTENT
WHEN THEY'RE ONLINE RIGHT SO
HELPING KIDS COPE WITH WHAT
THE EXPERIENCE ONLINE IS
JUST ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
TEACHING DIGITAL LITERACY IN
SCHOOLS IS SO CRITICAL AND ALSO
WHY IT HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ACCORDING TO A FUTURE
OF TECH COMMISSION POLL EIGHTY
TWO PERCENT OF REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS SURVEYED THAT
THEY SUPPORT TEACHING DIGITAL
CITIZENSHIP SKILLS IN SCHOOL
SCHOOLS NOW MORE THAN EVER ARE
LEVERAGING TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES ASSESS
STUDENT LEARNING AND PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION TO THE WIDELY
DIVERSE NEEDS OF THEIR VARIOUS
KIDS AND SCHOOL COMMUNITIES
BUT WHAT THIS IS OFTEN LOOK
LIKE SO IF YOU'RE CELLS IF YOU
HAVE ANY CHILDREN OF YOUR OWN
I MEAN THE STRUGGLE ITSELF JUST
GETTING THEM TO PUT ON THEIR
DEVICE TO MAKE EYE CONTACT WITH
YOU IS ALREADY A BIG YOU KNOW
STRUGGLE LET ALONE ARE THEY
EVEN PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT AND I'M SURE
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF TIMES
WERE YOU MAYBE SAT BACK AND
SAW SOMETHING ONLINE AND JUST
LET YOURSELF WHY WOULD ANYONE
POST THIS RIGHT NOW IMAGINE IF
YOU'RE AN EDUCATOR COMING INTO
A CLASSROOM FULL OF THE STUDENTS
OR COMING INTO A SCHOOL FULL
OF PARENTS COMMUNITY MEMBERS
CARE GIVERS YOUR STUDENTS
AND THEY'RE ALL USING DEVICES IN
VERY SIMILAR WAYS SO HOW CAN
WE EXPECT TO EFFECTIVELY TEACH
CORE CONTENT IN OUR SCHOOLS
IF WE ARE TOO BUSY TRYING TO
DEFUSE THE DRAMA THAT LIKELY
START ONLINE LAST NIGHT RIGHT
HOW CAN WE EXPECT OUR EDUCATORS
TO EMBRACE TECHNOLOGY AND FEEL
CONFIDENT REALLY LEVERAGING ALL
OF ITS OPPORTUNITIES IF WE DON'T
BUILD THEIR SKILL AND PROVIDE
ACCESS TO RELIABLE TRAINING
FOR THEM IN MY WORLD TEACHING
DIGITAL MEDIA LITERACY AND
DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP ESCORT TO
TEACHING COURSE SUBJECT MATTER
CHILDREN ARE GROWING UP WITH
THE POWER OF DIGITAL MEDIA AND
TECHNOLOGY TO EXPLORE CONNECT
TO CREATE AND LEARN IN WAYS THAT
WE'VE ONLY DREAMED OF GROWING
UP AND WITH THIS POWER YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
BUT THEY ALSO FACE CHALLENGES
AND DILEMMAS SCHOOLS ARE
DEALING WITH RAMIFICATIONS
OF ISSUES LIKE ONLINE SAFETY
CYBERBULLYING PRIVACY HATE
SPEECH MISINFORMATION TECH
ADDITION TECH ADDICTION DIGITAL
DISTRACTION RIGHT THAT'S JUST
SOME OF WHAT THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH I HAVE A NINE AND ELEVEN
YEAR OLD I HEAR ABOUT THESE
THINGS ALL THE TIME EITHER WHAT
THERE'S EXPERIENCING OR WHAT
THEY'RE SEEING ON THE SCHOOL
YEAR TO WHAT THEIR FRIENDS
ARE TELLING THEM RIGHT SO IF
WE ARE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
TO BROADBAND AND DIGITAL
RESOURCES THEN WE SHOULD BE
JUST AS COMMITTED TO EMPOWERING
OUR KIDS TO THINK CRITICALLY
BEHAVE SAFELY UP PARTICIPATE
RESPONSIBLY WITH THE DIGITAL
WORLD RIGHT TO BECOME MORE
MINDFUL OF EVERYDAY HABITS
THAT ARE OTHERWISE AUTOMATIC
AND MINDLESS AND IN MANY WAYS
THESE MEDIA TOOLS WERE BUILT TO
OPERATE THAT WAY AS EDUCATORS
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP OUR
KIDS UNDERSTAND THEIR LONG TERM
ETHICAL CONSEQUENCES OF THE
DECISIONS THAT THEY MAKE USING
DIGITAL MEDIA AND OFTENTIMES THE
MEDIA AGAIN WAS BUILT FOR THEM
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS REALLY
QUICKLY BUT ESPECIALLY IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND SO THAT LOOKS LIKE
AS ONE EXAMPLE HOW DO WE HELP
DEVELOP THINKING ROUTINES FOR
KIDS WHEN YOU RUN IT I REMEMBER
GROWING UP I WENT RIGHT BY --
-- RAILROAD TRACKS STOP LOOK
AND LISTEN THINKING ROUTINE
RIGHT EASY THERE THERE BUT
WHAT ARE THE THINKING ROUTINES
WHEN OUR KIDS ARE RUNNING INTO
SOMETHING THAT MAKES THEM FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE WHAT IS THAT RED
FLAG FEELING THAT THEY FEEL WHAT
DO I DO SO THINGS LIKE PAUSING
AND THINKING BEFORE THEY LIKE
REPLY OR POST OR DEVELOPING
A HABIT OF CONSIDERING AND
RECONSIDERING THEIR OWN AND
OTHERS PERSPECTIVES WHEN THEY
EVALUATE AND SHARE RIGHT THESE
ARE THINKING ROUTINES THAT WE
CAN REINFORCE IN THE CLASSROOM
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING DIGITAL MEDIA LITERACY
TRAINING FOR SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS
THESE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CHILDREN IN OUR FAST CHANGING
WORLD MEDIA TECHNOLOGY SO
COMMONSENSE ASSURED A MULTITUDE
OF RESOURCES AND AND RESEARCH
THAT AIDED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT WILL BE HANDING OUT --
THIS CAN BE RELATED TO SOCIAL
MEDIA HARMS THE METAVERSE AND
TEEN IN MEDIA USE YOUNG
PEOPLE OFTEN STRUGGLE TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS OF THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH ONLINE CONTENT
AND AS A RESULT CHILDREN ARE
BEING EXPOSED TO INAPPROPRIATE
AND HARMFUL CONTENT THAT MISS
INFORMS THEM THAT FINANCIALLY
EXPLOITS THEM -- AND CONTRIBUTES
TO SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DIGITAL LITERACY INSTRUCTION
HELPS EQUIP STUDENTS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
STAFF WITH THE KNOWLEDGE TO
THOUGHTFULLY NAVIGATE AND
SAFELY ENGAGE WITH THE DIGITAL
CONTENT AND OFTENTIMES MOST FOR
INSTRUCTION IS PROVIDED ON THE
SPACES RIGHT SO IT ALSO EMPOWERS
YOUNG PEOPLE TO ANALYZE AND
ASSESS THE INFLUENCE OF CONTENT
ON THEIR THOUGHTS FEELINGS
AND BEHAVIORS THE CURRICULUM
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SCHOOLS WITH HAS SEEN GREAT
SUCCESS ACROSS THE NATION AND
EMPOWERING YOUNG PEOPLE TO
CONSCIOUSLY CONSCIENTIOUSLY
INTERACT WITH THE DIGITAL WORLD
IDEALLY I SEE I FORESEE A FUTURE
WHERE STUDENTS LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE THEY THINK BEFORE THEY
POST SOMETHING PROBLEMATIC
ONLINE A WORLD WHERE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS KNOW HOW TO
TALK TO THEIR STUDENTS ABOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA CHALLENGES AND
CAN FEEL COMFORTABLE DOING THAT
ORDER PARENTS FEEL COMFORTABLE
FLAGGING DISTRESSING INSTANCES
ONLINE AND ROLE MODEL HOW WE
SHOULD BE NAVIGATING THE SPACE
TOGETHER -- IN CLOSING I JUST
WANT TO SAY CALIFORNIA HAS A
GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL MEDIA AND TECH ISSUES
THAT IMPACT US ALL AND CREATE
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT EMPOWERS
EDUCATORS STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
TO NAVIGATE THE VASTUS OF
THE INTERNET IN A SAFE AND
PRODUCTIVE WAY WE ARE NOT JUST
RAISING LEADERS OF TOMORROW
HER KIDS ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW
RIGHT SO IT IS OUR DUTY TO
ACT ON THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
PROVIDE THE NEEDED RESOURCES
FOR OUR SCHOOLS IN THIS GROWING
CONNECTED WORLD THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DID NEXT LIKE TO
WELCOME AMELIA VANCE SHE IS THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
INTEREST PRIVACY CONSULTING
INFORMALLY THE DIRECTOR OF
YOUTH AND EDUCATION PRIVACY
AT THE FUTURE OF PRIVACY FORUM
WHO IS GOING TO BE
JOINING US AFTERNOON
WE WE CAN HEAR HER NOW THANK YOU
EXCELLENT HI GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TO TESTIFY TODAY AND ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY REMOTELY I
AS MENTIONED MY NAME IS A
MILLION VANCE -- IN ADDITION
TO MY WORK AT PUBLIC INTEREST
PRIVACY CONSULTING I AM ALSO
AN ADJUNCT PROFESSOR OF LAW
AT PENN STATE AND WILLIAM AND
MARY LAW SCHOOL AND CO CHAIR OF
THE FEDERAL EDUCATION PRIVACY
COALITION THE FOCUS OF MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS THE PRIVACY
RISKS THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
WHEN CONSIDERING NEW PER CHILD
PRIVACY LAWS THE IMPORTANCE
OF EMBEDDING PRIVACY IN K.
TWELVE EDUCATION HOW PRIVACY
IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT
OF CHILDREN'S WELL BEING AND
HOW POLICYMAKERS CAN CREATE
EVIDENCE BASED PRIVACY LAWS
THAT STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
TECHNOLOGY CAN SUPPORT WITHOUT
HIM AND I GO AHEAD AND TRY TO
SHARE MY SCREEN AND HOPE THAT I
SUCCEED ALL
RIGHT IT'S SO
PRIVACY IS A MUCH BROADER
CONCEPT THAN MANY PEOPLE REALIZE
BY CARNEGIE MELLON UNIVERSITY
HAS A PROJECT ASKING PEOPLE
TO DRAW WHAT PRIVACY MEANS TO
THEM MANY PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN SEE PRIVACY THROUGH
THEIR RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PEOPLE IN THEIR LIVES SO THE
PRIVACY THAT COMES FROM BEING
ALONE HAVING A PRIVATE
SPACE SEPARATE FROM OTHER
PEOPLE PRIVACY FROM PHYSICAL
EXPOSURE THE PRIVACY
OF THOUGHTS AND IDEAS
AND US KIDS GROW UP THEY START
TO UNDERSTAND PRIVACY MORE
BROADLY HAVING PASSWORDS ON
ACCOUNTS COMPANIES POTENTIALLY
WATCHING WHAT THE ACCESS CAMERAS
IN SCHOOL HALLWAYS AND GROCERY
STORES WITH SO
MANY INTERPRETATIONS HOW CAN WE
DEFINE PRIVACY CERTAINLY PRIVACY
IS RECOGNIZED AS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT IN OUR CONSTITUTION AND
IN MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S LAWS
WE KNOW THAT PRIVACY CAN INCLUDE
A PERSON'S CONTROL ABOUT HOW
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION IS
SHARED BUT MORE AND MORE
FREQUENTLY THE WORD PRIVACY IS
USED AS A PROXY FOR FAIRNESS
WE OFTEN DON'T GET A REAL CHOICE
ABOUT HOW INFORMATION IS USED
BY GOVERNMENT AND SCHOOLS AND
COMPANIES THE MORE INFORMATION
THAT ONE PERSON OR ORGANISATION
HAS ABOUT ANOTHER THE MORE THAT
PARTY MAY INFLUENCE OR EXERT
POWER OVER THE OTHER RIVA C.
PROTECTIONS GIVE US RIGHTS
THAT CAN EMPOWER AND WORKS TO
CORRECT THOSE POWER IMBALANCES
AS PREVIOUS PANELISTS TESTIFIED
PRIVACY HARMS CAN BE MUCH
MORE POTENT FOR CHILDREN
AS I'VE TALKED TO THOUSANDS
OF STAKEHOLDERS I FOUND THAT
CONCERNS OVER CHILD PRIVACY
CAN BE BOILED DOWN TO THESE
RISKS PARENTS WORRY ABOUT
SAFETY ABOUT OVER COLLECTION
AND OVER SURVEILLANCE HOW MUCH
INFORMATION IS BEING COLLECTED
ABOUT MY CHILD THEY WORRY
ABOUT COMMERCIALIZATION OUR
COMPANY SELLING MY CHILD'S
DAUGHTER TARGETING ADVERTISING
TO THEM THEY WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER THEIR CHILD'S MISTAKES
WILL BE RECORDED FOREVER
PARENTS WORRY THAT THEIR CHILD
WILL MISS OUT ON OPPORTUNITIES
PERHAPS BECAUSE OF BIASED
INFORMATION OR INFORMATION THAT
IS USED IN AN INEQUITABLE WAY
THEY ALSO WORRY THAT CHILDREN
WILL ACCESS INAPPROPRIATE
CONTENTS AND PARENTS WORRY
ABOUT HOW TECHNOLOGY COULD
BE USED TO BULLY THEIR CHILD
OR HOW INFORMATION COLLECTED
LIKE MENTAL HEALTH DATA
COULD STIGMATIZE THEIR CHILD
THESE RISKS CAN BE EXACERBATED
WHEN WE ONLY THINK ABOUT A
STEREO TYPICAL STUDENT ONE
CREATE M. PROGRAMS OR POLICIES
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
WHO MAY BE LGBT Q. AND HAVE
A FAMILY THAT WOULD KICK THEM
OUT IF THEY KNEW CHILDREN
FACING ABUSE UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN CHILDREN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THOSE WHO DON'T
HAVE INTERNET AT HOME THESE
CHILDREN MUST BE PART OF OUR
POLICY MAKING WE CAN'T ASSUME
THAT PARENTS UNIVERSALLY
HAVE TIME TO RESEARCH PRIVACY
PROTECTIVE APPS THAT ALL
PARENTS HAVE THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THEIR CHILD AT HEART OR
THAT FAMILIES WILL TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE PRIVACY
DECISIONS ON THEIR BEHALF
POLICYMAKERS ALL OVER THE
WORLD ARE RIGHT NOW WRESTLING
WITH HOW WE CAN EQUIP TODAY'S
CHILDREN TO ACCESS TECHNOLOGIES
BENEFITS AND AVOID OR MINIMIZE
RISKS THIS IS IN A SMALL
QUESTION IT IS INCLINED WITH
CHILDREN'S WELLBEING TODAY AND
THEIR OPPORTUNITIES TOMORROW
DIGITAL LITERACY CANNOT BE
AN AFTERTHOUGHT WE'RE JUST
ONE WEEK OF CURRICULUM IN THE
SCHOOL YEAR IN THE SAME WAY WE
TELL AND TRAIN AND EMPHASIZED
AS OTHERS HAVE SAID THAT
OUR KIDS MUST LOOK BOTH WAYS
BEFORE CROSSING THE STREET WE
MUST ACQUIT KIDS TO MAKE GOOD
PRIVACY DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
WE MUST TEACH STUDENTS THAT
THE MOST BASIC WAY TECHNOLOGY
WILL CHANGE SOCIETY IS THROUGH
THE CHOICES PEOPLE MAKE THE
CHOICES THEY MAKE ABOUT WHICH
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ADOPTED OR
REJECTED AND HOW TO WISELY
USE THE ONES THAT ARE SELECTED
SCHOOL SHOULD PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH TOOLS FOR HAVING THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATIONS AND MAKING
THOUGHTFUL DECISIONS ABOUT
PRIVACY BOTH ONLINE AND OFFLINE
WITH THEIR PARENTS TEACHERS AND
PEERS FOR EXAMPLE THE MIT
MEDIA LAB CREATED A MIDDLE
SCHOOL CURRICULUM ON A AYE
ETHICS AND PRIVACY IT FOCUSES
ON RELATABLE EXAMPLES SUCH AS
THE MODEL ON REDESIGNING YOU
TWO WERE STUDENTS IDENTIFY
THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS THAT
YOU TIP AND TAX AND HIGHLIGHTS
WHERE THOSE STAKEHOLDERS
VALUES OVERLAP AND CONFLICT
THE BERKMAN KLEIN CENTER AT
HARVARD AS SEVERAL LESSONS ON
PRIVACY INCLUDED IN ITS DATABASE
OF DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP LESSON
PLANS THESE RESOURCES AND
MANY MORE INCLUDING THE GREAT
RESOURCES FROM COMMONSENSE ARE
WONDERFUL IT RESOURCES ARE NOT
ENOUGH WE NEED
GOVERNMENT TO CREATE A COHESIVE
POLICY THAT ACKNOWLEDGES
THE PRIVACY EDUCATION AND
PROTECTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
AND ESSENTIAL TO CHILDREN'S
DEVELOPMENT AND WELL BEING
UNFORTUNATELY THE U. S. IS FAR
BEHIND OTHER COUNTRIES WHEN IT
COMES TO CHILD PRIVACY RESEARCH
AND AUTHORITATIVE RESOURCES
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS THE
UK'S INFORMATION COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE FUNDED RESEARCH INCLUDING
INTERVIEWS WITH PARENTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN TO INFORM
POLICY MAKING AND CREATE
ONLINE EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
THAT WERE BUILT AROUND THE
QUESTIONS CHILDREN KEPT ASKING
SUCH AS WHO IS MY DATA AND
WHAT ARE MY RIGHTS THE
IRISH DATA PROTECTION COMMISSION
GATHERED INPUT FROM STUDENTS
WHILE ALSO EDUCATING THEM ON
PRIVACY BY SENDING A PACKAGE
OF MATERIALS TO EVERY SCHOOL
THAT TEACHERS COULD USE TO
EDUCATE THEIR STUDENTS AND
ALSO TO SEND FEEDBACK BACK TO
PRIVACY REGULATORS SIMILAR
EFFORTS ARE UNDERWAY IN MULTIPLE
COUNTRIES ACROSS THE WORLD
IN ORDER TO PASSED EVIDENCE
BASED LOS WE NEED EVIDENCE BASED
RESEARCH EVEN WELL INTENTIONED
LAWS CAN RESULT IN HAVE RESULTED
IN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WE CAN MITIGATE THOSE
CONSEQUENCES BY CONSULTING WITH
KEY CALIFORNIA STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL AS EXPERTS WORKING ON THESE
ISSUES OCCUR AROUND THE WORLD
THIS MUST INCLUDE CONSULTING
CHILDREN THEMSELVES ABOUT
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF PRIVACY
AND THEIR PREFERENCES ONLINE
KIDS ALSO SPEND A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME AT SCHOOL AND
WHAT MAY WORK WHEN REGULATING
CHILD PRIVACY OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
MAY BE VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
IS IDEAL FOR THE SCHOOL CONTEXT
AFTER ALL KIDS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO CALL UP THE COMPANY TO
CHANGE THEIR GRADES CALIFORNIA
LED THE COUNTRY IN RECOGNIZING
THAT NUANCE AS THE FIRST STATE
TO PASS A STUDENT PRIVACY LAW
SPECIFICALLY GOVERNING AD TECH
COMPANIES IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TEACHERS ARE A CRUCIAL PART OF
THIS IS WHILE WE NEED ADULTS
WHO HAVE THE TOOLS AND TRAINING
THEY NEED TO IMPLEMENT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS AND TO MODEL GOOD
PRIVACY BEHAVIORS COLLEGES
OF TEACHER EDUCATION RARELY
INCLUDE TEACHING PRIVACY TO
EDUCATORS MEANING THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF TEACHERS ARE NEVER
TRAINED ON PRIVACY STRONG
PRIVACY LAWS ARE NOT EFFECTIVE
IF PEOPLE ON THE GROUND DO
NOT KNOW HOW TO PROTECT DATA
IT IS ALSO ESSENTIAL TO EXAMINE
WHICH PROTECTION SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO PARENTAL CONSENT TO
OFTEN KIDS GET AROUND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS BY LYING BECAUSE
IT'S EASIER THAN ASKING THEIR
PARENTS OR BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO ACCESS CONTENT THAT THEY
DON'T WANT THEIR PARENTS TO
SEE SUCH AS LGBTQ SUPPORT
RESOURCES -- ABUSE HOTLINES
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
FUNDAMENTAL UNDERLYING UNDERWAY
THE BILL PROTECTIONS SUCH AS A
BAN ON TARGETED ADVERTISING IN
HIGH PRIVACY SETTINGS BY DEFAULT
TO KEEP KIDS SAFE NO MATTER WHAT
HOWEVER GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT
OVERRIDE A PARENT'S JUDGMENT
ABOUT WHAT IS APPROPRIATE OR
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THEIR CHILD
TO ACCESS OR SHARE THIS IS
WHERE DEFAULT PROTECTIONS ARE
PARTICULARLY USEFUL CHILDREN
WHOSE PARENTS DON'T HAVE THE
TIME OR KNOWLEDGE TO OVERSEE
ALL OF THEIR CHILD'S DIGITAL
CHOICES WILL STILL HAVE A
BASELINE LEVEL OF PROTECTION
THOSE WHOSE PARENTS HAVE MADE
AN INFORMED DECISION TO LET
THEM USE PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGIES
OR ACCESS CERTAIN MATERIALS
STILL HAVE THE FREEDOM TO DO SO
EVERYONE WANTS CHILDREN TO BE
ABLE TO HARNESS THE BENEFITS
OF TECHNOLOGY WHILE MINIMIZING
RISKS EVERYONE AGREES THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS CALIFORNIA
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THE
COUNTRY AND EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE
BASED CHILD PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AND IN CREATING PRIVACY
LITERATE CITIZENS WE MUST NOT
ONLY PROTECT OUR CHILDREN'S
PRIVACY YOU MUST ALSO INFORM AND
EDUCATE THEM SO THEY CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT MRS VANCE I'M NOT GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DIRECTED
AT ANY OF OUR TWO WITNESSES
ALL RIGHT THEN I WILL I WILL
JUMP IN AND -- SO I GUESS MY
M. JUST INTEREST ONLY FOR YOU TO
REACT TO MISTER ABBAS
AND M. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK THAT WE HEARD
FROM THAT FROM THE FIRST PANEL
THE WORDS THAT KEPT COMING OVER
UP FOR ME WERE CONTROL AGENCY
AUTONOMY POWER -- IT SEEM LIKE A
BIG PART OF THIS IS THAT
THE FACT THAT YOUNG PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
CONTROL RIGHT AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE FOR PARENTS
AS WELL I CERTAINLY I CERTAINLY
FEEL THAT WAY WHEN MY FOUR
YEAR OLD IS SCROLLING THROUGH
YOUTUBE AND AND ENCOUNTERING
CONTENT THAT I WORRY ABOUT M.
IN AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
INTRIGUED ME ABOUT DIGITAL
LITERACY IS IT SEEMS LIKE A WAY
TO ACTUALLY PUT CONTROL BACK
INTO THE HANDS OF THOSE WHO ARE
ON THE OTHER AND -- YOU KNOW THE
CONSUMERS THE KIDS THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE USING THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES -- AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO GET YOUR YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT -- MAY THINK WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THINGS
THAT ARE PUTTING CONTROL ON THE
OTHER END QUITE YET IN TERMS OF
THE DEVELOPERS AND THE DIFFERENT
PLATFORMS THE ACCOUNTABILITY IS
LIMITED AND SO WE ARE FORCED TO
ALMOST ENSURE THAT OUR KIDS AND
THAT EVEN OURSELVES UNDERSTAND
HOW THINGS WORK SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE MORE THOUGHTFUL DECISIONS I
THINK IT'S VERY EASY BECAUSE WE
LIVE IN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE'RE
ABLE TO GET THINGS AS WE NEED IT
RAPIDLY AND FAST AND WE START
TO ASSOCIATE AND THE WAY THAT WE
JUST NORMALIZE HOW WE USE THINGS
AND I'M USE THE TERM EARLIER
LIKE WE JUST KIND OF GO THROUGH
THINGS ALMOST IN A MINDLESS
WAY BECAUSE IT'S MEANT FOR THAT
I MEAN REALLY THE THE VALUE
OF YOUR ATTENTION IS INCREDIBLY
HIGH AND SO AS YOU PAY ATTENTION
TO SOMETHING AS AS RACY AS
IT MIGHT BE OR UNCOMFORTABLE
AS IT MIGHT BE THAT TELLS THE
ALGORITHM TO SPEND WITH THIS
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
ALGORITHM WORKS YOU'LL EASILY
GET TIED INTO IT SO HOW DO WE
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS
UNDERSTAND HOW IS IT USING THEM
SO THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING USED
BUT MORE POORLY HOW CAN YOU
USE IT FOR WHAT YOU NEED AND
WHAT YOU INTEND I THINK WITH
MY NINE ELEVEN YEAR OLD ONE OF
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH THEM ON IS GIVING
THEM THE LANGUAGE SO WHEN THEY
SEE SOMETHING THAT MAKES THEM
FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE THEY KNOW
THAT WHEN THEY COME TO ME IT'S
NOT -- YOU KNOW WHAT REMOVE
THE DEVICE OR YOU'RE OFF THAT
PLATFORM WHICH IS A BIG FEAR
FOR A LOT OF KIDS ESPECIALLY
KIDS THAT ARE JUST KIND OF
EXPLORING IT NOW GAINING ACCESS
TO THESE PLATFORMS SO PROVIDING
THEM REALLY THE LANGUAGE AND
WROTE RECOGNITION THAT WHEN
YOU SEE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
THAT IS NOT OKAY HERE'S HOW WE
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS AND WORK
THROUGH IT AND THE SAME WAY IN
THE CLASSROOM WHERE SOMETIMES
AND AM I ACTUALLY OFTENTIMES
EDUCATORS WILL FEEL LIKE I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES SO I'M NOT GOING
TO EVEN PUT MYSELF IN IT EVEN
THOUGH THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIND
REALLY HIGH QUALITY CONTENT ON A
PLATFORM LIKE YOU TOO CAN THEN
BE MET WITH SEVEN CLICKS AWAY
LIKE I'M LOOKING UP THOMAS THE
TRAIN AND SEVEN CLICKS AWAY ALL
OF US IN THERE TRAINS HITTING
AUTOMOBILES RIGHT VERY EASILY
SO RECOGNIZING HOW THESE THINGS
WORK SO THAT AS EDUCATORS WE CAN
BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW WE'RE
PREPARING KIDS TO REALLY THROUGH
CRITICALLY ABOUT WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING FOR LET'S GIVE YOU THE
SKILLS THAT YOU CAN USE TARGETED
WORD SEARCH AND EFFECTIVE WAY
YOU SIGN IMAGE TO MAKE YOU FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE THANK LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN TALK THROUGH
THAT WHO CAN YOU GO TO WHERE
THE TRUSTED ADULTS I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A CULTURE IN A SCHOOL
THAT RECOGNIZED TECHNOLOGY
HAS INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
SOME HARMS IF WE DON'T PREPARE
OURSELVES TO ADDRESS SO MANY OF
OUR KIDS DON'T TRUST THAT WE CAN
GO TO AN EDUCATOR OR A PARENT
OR ANYONE LIKE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE TO WHOM IS
FEELS CONFIDENT THAT THEY KNOW
ALL THESE THINGS AND IT'S GOING
TO BE ANOTHER KID IN CLASS
OR ANOTHER KID MAYBE YOU KNOW
THAT MIGHT BE SLIGHTLY OLDER
WHO'S ALSO STILL NAVIGATING
HE'S YOU KNOW CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT THE RUNNING TO ONLINE
RIGHT SO WHEN YOUR POSITION
YOUR QUESTION ARE WE MORE LIKE
-- ONE INDUSTRY VERSUS THE
OTHER I THINK WE'RE OPERATING
AROUND WHAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO
AT THIS POINT AND SO EMPOWERING
OUR KIDS TO THINK CRITICALLY
BECAUSE REALITY IS THERE WILL
BE NEW TECHNOLOGY TOMORROW THERE
WILL BE A NEW ISSUE TOM YEAH
ACT THREE THREE YEARS FROM NOW
THEY'LL BE IN A NEW PIECE OF
TECH SO HOW MUCH ARE WE GETTING
OUR KIDS USE THE FILTERS THAT
ARE BETWEEN THIRTY YEARS --
AND REALLY EMPOWERING THEM TO
THINK THROUGH THOSE EXPERIENCES
I'M IS GONNA BE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AS WE WORK TO REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW THEN DOES THAT
CREATE THESE PLATFORMS ARE BEING
THOUGHTFUL AND AND CENTERING
THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR KIDS AND
THAT'S SOMETIME FROM NOW WHAT I
CAN DO RIGHT NOW WHAT EDUCATORS
ARE DOING RIGHT NOW WE KNOW
THERE'S GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
WITH TECH WHICH IS WHY THERE'S
SO MUCH TAKE A CLASSROOMS SO
WE NEED TO REALLY BUILD THE
SKILLS FOR KIDS TO USE IN REALLY
MEANINGFUL WAYS AND REALLY
THINK CRITICALLY HOW THEY USE IT
YEAH I I APPRECIATE THAT AND
IT'S YOU KNOW I WAS STRUCK BOTH
BY WHAT YOU SAID BY WHAT'S IN
THE BACKGROUND PAPER BY WHAT WE
HEARD FROM SOME OF OUR WITNESSES
ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE REALLY NOT
FEELING LIKE THEY HAVE ANYWHERE
TO GO RIGHT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT THEY CAN TALK TO
THAT THEY ENCOUNTER SOMETHING
PROBLEMATIC THEY'RE NOT SURE
TO THINK ABOUT IT AND YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT THE STATISTICS ABOUT
YOU KNOW AMERICAN TEENAGER
SPENDING SEVEN POINT SEVEN HOURS
ONLINE I MEAN WHAT SORT OF A
I DON'T IS THERE ANYTHING I
MEAN THEY'RE GETTING MORE HOURS
OF INSTRUCTION FROM YOU KNOW
SNAPCHAT AND GOOGLE AND YOUTUBE
THAN THEY MIGHT BE GETTING FROM
PARENTS AND TEACHERS SO THIS IS
THAT YOU KNOW I I WORRY ABOUT
YOU WE WE WE OBVIOUSLY CAN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AS AS AS EDUCATORS
AS POLICY MAKERS AS PARENTS
ABOUT WHAT IS THE MATERIAL
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR KIDS AND
WHAT ARE THEY RECEIVING AND HOW
IS THAT HELPING TO SHAPE THEM
THE QUESTION IS ARE WE ALSO
HAVING THAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
WITH THE SEVEN POINT SEVEN HOURS
OF TIME THEY'RE SPENDING ONLINE
YEAH YOU KNOW I COMPLETELY AGREE
AND I THINK IT'S ANOTHER REALITY
HAVE TO ADDRESS IS THE FACT
THAT WE'RE LIVING IN A DIFFERENT
WORLD RIGHT NOW RIGHT WHEN
I GREW UP IF THE LIGHTS WENT
ON OUTSIDE I WAS STILL WELL
WITHIN MY MEANS TO BE RUNNING
AROUND OF MY FRIENDS YOU KNOW
OUTSIDE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THESE DAYS
SO DEVELOPMENTALLY KIDS ARE
WHAT GOING TO BE WHERE THEIR
FRIENDS ARE AND THOSE THEIR
FRIENDS ARE IN ONLINE SPACES
WHETHER IT BE THROUGH GAMING
WITH THEIR FRIENDS OR ON DISCORD
OR OTHER PLATFORMS SO IF THAT
IS BECOMING KIND OF A NEW NORM
THAT OUR KIDS AREN'T OUTSIDE
AS MUCH REACTIVE ME INTERACTING
WITH EACH OTHER OR JUST KIND OF
NAVIGATING YOU KNOW THE OUTSIDE
WORLD THEY'RE GONNA BE WHERE
THEIR FRIENDS ARE AND IF THEY'RE
GOING TO BE IN ONLINE SPACES
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE THINKING THOUGHTFULLY
ABOUT HOW WE PROVIDE THEM -- YOU
KNOW REALLY THAT THE SKILL IN
THE RESOURCE TO THINK CRITICALLY
ABOUT YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
SPEND ALL YOUR TIME THERE CARE
THE THINGS TO LOOK OUT FOR I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT POINT
AROUND CRITICAL THINKING IT'S
STILL VERY IMPORTANT AND SO MUCH
OF THIS ISN'T NECESSARILY ABOUT
RESTRICTING OUR ACCESS OR
-- WRAPPING KIDS IN BUBBLE WRAP
IT REALLY IS AROUND ARE THEY
THINKING CRITICALLY TO THEY
REALIZE THERE'S AN ALGORITHM
THAT IS CAUSING ME TO SEE
THIS THING AT THIS TIME
-- IS THERE SOMETHING THAT
-- IT I AGREE WITH OR DISAGREE
WITH AND A LOT OF THAT IS ABOUT
WHAT OUR TEACHERS CAN PROVIDE
IN TERMS OF OKAY YOU'RE LOOKING
UP THESE RESOURCES FOR AN
ASSIGNMENT WHAT DO YOU THINK
THIS NEWSPAPER IS TRYING TO
TELL YOU VERSES THIS NEWSPAPER
-- THERE'S A WONDERFUL RESOURCE
FROM ARTIFACT DESIGN THE MOST
LIKELY MACHINE WHICH IS A GAME
THAT MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLERS
CAN PLAY TO TRY AND PREDICT
OUT WHICH FAMOUS FIGURES --
WOULD BE VOTED YOU KNOW BEST IN
CLASS -- OR -- YOU KNOW MOST
CREATIVE AND THEN CREATE AN
ALGORITHM TO SHOW THOSE THINGS
THOSE CHARACTERISTICS THAT
MAKE UP THOSE PERSON THOSE
CHARACTERISTICS AND IT IT'S
A REALLY GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR KIDS TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND SAY OH WHAT I ASSUME TO
VERSUS WHAT THIS ALGORITHM
DOES IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT
AND CRITICAL THINKING REALLY IS
THE FUNDAMENTAL BUILDING STAFF
AND AND THE TOOL THAT WE NEED TO
GIVE KIDS AREN'T MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I KNOW
THAT -- THE CHAIR HAD A I
THOUGHT YOU WANTED TO CHAIR
WELL I THINK THIS IS A VERY
INTERESTING DISCUSSION I GO
BACK TO A MILLION AS A SLIDE
WITH LIKE IT'S SOMETIMES
DEPENDING ON YOUR BUBBLE IT'S
EASY TO SAY WAS APPARENT I'VE
DECIDED I'VE LOOKED AT ALL THE
EVIDENCE I SAID THIS IS WHAT MY
KIDS CAN'T DO THIS MY MY KIDS
CAN'T DO MY DAUGHTER IS ON MY
OWN YOUTUBE CHANNEL SO I JUST
HAVE TO CHECK MY OWN YOUTUBE
HISTORY ON MY PHONE TO SEE WHAT
SHE'S BEEN DOING -- HENCE I
KNEW ABOUT THE QUESTIONING --
BUT YOU HAD A SIDE THAT SAID
ALL THE OTHER GROUPS THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT I
THINK IT'S CALIFORNIA WE LEAD
ON THAT EQUITY SIDE AND I
THINK WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW
WE ARE GOING TO APPROACH THIS
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THERE ARE
PARENTS WORKING THREE JOBS
THAT DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
SIT AND SAY THIS PLATFORM AS
OKAY THIS PLATFORM IS NOT I'M
GONNA CHECK MY KIDS YOU TO
HISTORY I'M NOT SO WE HAVE TO
I THINK THINK ABOUT IT MORE
-- LIKE POLITICALLY I THINK
THERE'S A PLACE FOR EDUCATION
I THINK THERE'S A PLACE WHERE
GOVERNMENT -- AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION ON THIS WITH BOTH OF
THE PARENTS AND THE STUDENTS
ARE HELPING CRITICAL TO CREATE
THOSE CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS
TO MAKE THAT EVALUATION BECAUSE
I COULD DO THAT AS A PARENT
BECAUSE I HAVE THE LUXURY AND
THE PRIVILEGE OF THAT TIME AND
EDUCATION DO SO BUT WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
OUR POLICIES I THINK EQUITY
LENDS A SUPER IMPORTANT AND
THAT WAS MY THOUGHT THAT CAN
AFFECT PANEL DISCUSSIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
GONNA GLASCOFF ANYONE FOR THE
COMMITTEE -- I THINK MAYBE
THAT WAS OUR SIGN THAT IT'S
-- TIME TO MOVE ON SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO OUR WITNESSES
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH RIGHT
NOW I WANT TO WELCOME OUR
THIRD AND FINAL PANEL WE'RE
GONNA DISCUSS -- SOME OTHER
PROACTIVE APPROACHES TO PRIVACY
AND SAFETY FOR CHILDREN ONLINE
FIRST TIME HONOR TO WELCOME
OUR GUEST WHO WINS THE AWARD
FOR TRAVELING THE FARTHEST --
THAT IS FAIRNESS BEAVAN KETRON
SHE IS THE FOUNDER AND CHAIR
OF THE FIVE RIGHTS FOUNDATION
IN INTERNATIONAL CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
BUILDING THE DIGITAL WORLD
YOUNG PEOPLE DESERVE SHE'S
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE OF
LORDS SO WE'RE DELIGHTED TO
WELCOME YOU TO THE GREEN CARPET
I KNOW YOU'RE USUALLY USED TO
THE RED CARPET AND -- HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT WITH
HER -- EVENTS OF THE HEARING
AND I WAS ASKING HER WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE HONORIFIC IS
BECAUSE SHE'S A AND BARONESS
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
OF LORDS AND SO I LEARNED THAT
I TECHNICALLY WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO REFER TO HER AS MILADY SO IF
YOU WANT TO BE A APPROPRIATE YOU
CAN ADDRESS ARE THAT WAY -- BUT
I'M GONNA SAY WELCOME BARONESS
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
M. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT CHAD
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INVITING ME TO ADDRESS YOU --
AND THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
-- HEARING ON WATCHES ON WHAT
IS A TIMELY AND CRITICAL ISSUES
SITE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND IT'S
A GREAT PRIVILEGE TO BE IN YOUR
HOUSE AM I AM AS AS AS
SAID BARONESS BE BANKING DRAWN
I WAS A MOVIE DIRECTED THIRTY
JENS AND FOR THE PAST DECADE
I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE OF LORDS WHERE I SIT AS
A CROSS BENCH PIA MEANING I'M
NOT ALIGNED WITH ANY POLITICAL
COUNTY I HAVE A WIDE RANGE
OF DIGITAL POLICY EXPERTISE
BUT BEST KNOWN IN REGULATE
TREE CIRCLES AS THE ARCHITECT
OF THE UK'S AGE APPROPRIATE
DESIGN CODE THE CODE WENT INTO
EFFECT IN SEPTEMBER LAST YEAR
AND IT HAS SHOWN THAT IF YOU
FOCUS THE PRODIGIOUS CREATIVITY
OF THE TECH SECTOR SQUARELY
ON THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN YOU CAN
PROTECT THEM I'M ALSO CHAIR
FIVE RIGHTS FOUNDATION WHICH
IS DRIVEN BIG IMPROVEMENTS
TO CHILD SAFETY ONLINE ACROSS
EUROPE AFRICA ASIA AND SOUTH
AMERICA AND OVER THE PAST
DECADE I'VE WORKED WITH MANY
CHILDREN AND YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS THE WHILE THEY ARE
UNITED AND THAT LOVE OF DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGY AND THEY ARE EQUALLY
UNITED IN THEIR DESIRE THAT IT
SHOULD BE KINDA FARAH AND
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
AND I AM HERE TODAY ON THAT
BEHALF IF YOU REWIND
A LITTLE BIT TO THE INTERNET'S
EARLY DAYS AND SPEND TIME
AS I HAVE DONE WITH SOME OF
ITS ORIGINAL ARCHITECTS YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AIMS
WHEN NOBLE THEY IMAGINED
A DEMOCRATIZING TECHNOLOGY
NO GATEKEEPERS WHAT WILL USES
WOULD BE EQUAL THIS EQUALITY
WAS PART OF A GRAND VISION BUT
THERE IS A CATCH IF YOU
TREAT EVERYONE EQUALLY YOU
TREAT A CHILD AS IF THEY WERE
AN ACT OF IT IS ONE OF THE
MOST PROFOUND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN THE HISTORY
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT THE DIGITAL
WORLD HAS SIMPLY NOT BEEN
DESIGNED WITH CHILDREN IN MIND
CHILDREN HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO SPEND A LARGE SHARE OF
THAT TIME IN THE DIGITAL
REALM IT IS WHERE THEY BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS STUDY PLAY FIND
INFORMATION AND HOPEFULLY AS
THEY MATURE THEY PARTICIPATE
IN CIVIC LIFE AND AND
DEMOCRACY BUT A CHILD IS
A CHILD UNTIL THEY MATURE
NOT UNTIL THE MOMENT
THEY PICK UP A SMALL FUND
IN TWENTY TWELVE I MADE A
FILM ABOUT TEENAGERS LIFE
ONLINE I SPEND HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS IN KIDS
BEDROOMS IF THEY WERE GOING
TO MEETUPS I WENT TO MEET UPS
IF THEY WERE WATCHING PORN
I WAS WATCHING PORN IF THEY
WERE GAMING THROUGH THE NIGHT
SO WAS I I HAVE SEEN
UP CLOSE SOME OF THE HOMES
THAT RESULT FROM A SYSTEM
THAT ENCOURAGES BEHAVIORS AND
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE SIMPLY TOO
MUCH FOR A CHILD'S EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IN LIFE EXPERIENCE
WE CAN OVER REAL LAW FOR
CANON OF HOMES DEPRESSION
BODY DYSMORPHIA SELF HARM AND
SUICIDE HATE SPEECH EXTORTION
VIOLENCE SEXUAL CONTENT
GAMBLING OR BEING A VICTIM OF
CRIMINAL SEXUAL ABUSE AND
IN THE COURSE OF MY WORK I
ROUTINELY DEAL WITH CHILDREN
WITH THREE PARENTS AND WITH
TEACHERS WHO FEEL POWERLESS
IN THE FACE OF THOSE HOMES
THE HARM IS NOT THE INTENTION
OF THE TECHNOLOGY SECTOR
BUT EQUALLY THE FEATURES
THE EXACERBATE AND AMPLIFY
ON I'M NOT ELECTIONS
THEY ALL FEATURES OF DIGITAL
SERVICE AND IT DOES
NOT HAVE TO BE THIS WAY
THE TECHNOLOGY CHILDREN USING IS
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT ENGINEERED
AND CAN BE OPTIMIZED FOR ANY
PURPOSE INCLUDING CHILDREN'S
SAFETY AND WELL BEING A SENIOR
LEADER OF A LARGE TECHNOLOGY
FOUND RECENTLY TOLD ME THAT
HIS PRODUCT ENGINEERS FOUND
THE CONCEPT OF DESIGNING TO
PUT CHILDREN'S BEST INTERESTS
FLESTE A VERY REWARDING TASK
HE ALSO ADDED THEY SIMPLY
HADN'T BEEN ASKED TO DO IT
FOR WHICH IS WHY ULTIMATELY
I'M A TECHNOLOGY OPTIMIST AND
A PRACTICE TEST THE JOURNEY
TO THE DIGITAL WORLD CHILDREN
DESERVE STARTS WITH THIS
QUESTION IF YOU KNEW FOR CERTAIN
THAT YOUR PRODUCT END USER
WAS A CHILD WHAT WOULD YOU DO
DIFFERENTLY FASTER
AFTER KNOWLEDGE THAT CHILD TO
DOES NOT AND TWELVE THIRTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS IS STILL
IN THE MAELSTROM OF COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT ON THE WAY TO ACT
OUT THAT TRYING TO MAKE SENSE
OF THAT IMPULSE IS TRYING TO
MAKE RATIONAL INFORMED DECISIONS
THEY STRUGGLE AND THE DIGITAL
WELL DESIGNED TO NUDGE THEM INTO
BEHAVING AS THE ENEMY THAT AGE
APPROPRIATE NORTH SAY SECOND
WE MUST AS UP AS OF SENATE
ADULT CHILD CENTERED DESIGN OR
SAFETY BY DESIGN AS MANY CORNET
NO ENVIRONMENT IS A HUNDRED
PERCENT SAFE BUT TOO MANY
DIGITAL PRODUCTS ALIKE BECAUSE
WITHOUT SEAT BELTS -- BREAKS
I'M AS A CHILD AT THE WHEEL
IT'S TIME FOR SAFETY OPERATE
FIVE RIGHTS HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE INSTITUTE OF ELECTRICAL
AND ELECTRONICS ENGINEERS THE
IEEE ON SAFETY BY DESIGN FRAME
WHAT THAT NUDGES INNOVATORS
TO ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS AT
EVERY STAGE IN THE LIFE CYCLE
OF A PRODUCT OR SERVICE FROM
ITS CREATION DEVELOPMENT BE TO
TESTING DISTRIBUTION EVEN ITS
RETIREMENT FROM ME WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH ENGINEERS WAS
REGULATORY THEY ARE NATURAL
PROBLEM SOLVERS AND THEY MADE
KIA OPTIMIZING FOR CHILDREN
DEPENDS CHIEFLY ON THE
WILLINGNESS OF COMPANIES TOP
LEADERSHIP TO SAY YES THE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES EMINENTLY
FEASIBLE THANK AND FINALLY
WE MUST PROTECT CHILDREN'S
PRIVACY WHEN HARVESTING
PROCESSING AND MONETIZING
UPDATED DEFINES THE FEATURES
OF PRODUCTS AND CULTURE OF AN
INDUSTRY IT FOLLOWS THAT
DATA PROTECTION IS A POWERFUL
TOOL TO CHANGE A CHILD'S
LIVED EXPERIENCE WHICH BRINGS
ME NEATLY TO THE UK'S AGE
APPROPRIATE DESIGN CODE IT'S
THREE OVERARCHING PRINCIPLES ON
THE ANY PERSON UNDER EIGHTEEN
MUST BE ACCORDED SPECIFIC
DATA PROTECTION THAT THOSE
PROTECTIONS BE APPLIED TO ALL
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES LIKELY
TO BE ACCESSED BY CHILDREN
WHICH RECOGNIZES THAT CHILDREN
SPEND MOST OF THAT TIME IN
PLACE IS NOT UNIQUELY DIRECTED
AT THEM FOR EXAMPLE INSTAGRAM
YOU CHOOSE PICKED UP GAMING
AND THAT THOSE PROTECTIONS
WILL BE OFFERED BY DESIGN AND
DEFAULT THAT IS TO SAY NOT
BY COMPLICATED OR HIDDEN TOOLS
BUT STRAIGHTFORWARD BAKED IN
DEFAULTS IN ADDITION THERE
ARE FIFTEEN STANDARDS THE
ALMOST IDENTICAL TO THOSE IN
THE CALIFORNIA AGE APPROPRIATE
DESIGN A BILL INTRODUCED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BUFFY
WICKS AND JORDAN CUNNINGHAM
AND I'M NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH THEM HERE BUT I CAN
TRACE EACH ONE OF THEM TO AN
INDIVIDUAL STORY OF A CHILD
HIS NAME'S FOR THE REASONS
YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND OF CHANGE
IT WAS PATEL WHO TOLD ME THAT A
STRANGER USED A MAP SHOWING
HAVE REAL TIME LOCATION TO FIND
HER IN REAL LIFE THAT LED TO
STANDARD TO TEN WHICH REQUIRES
JUNE LOCATION FEATURES TO BE
OFF BY DEFAULT IT WAS
MARK HE SAID HE WAS INCAPABLE
OF HAVING A RELATIONSHIP WITH
A REAL GIRL BECAUSE HE'D BEEN
WATCHING PORN SINCE THE AGE OF
EIGHT BUT LIKE TO STAND TO
TWELVE WHICH PREVENTS PROFILING
TO DELIVER DETRIMENTAL MATERIAL
IT WAS GRACE HIS FAVORITE
GAME TOOK THREE HOURS TO
COMPLETE BUT HAD NO SAVE BUTTON
SO WHEN CORD FOR DINNER BEDTIME
OF SCHOOL THE POWERFUL POINT
OF THE GAME AND THE INABILITY
TO POLLS MADE HAVE REFUSED
TO PUT IT DOWN WHICH IN TURN
CAUSED EXTREME MARITAL DISCORD
FOR WHICH SHE STILL BLAMES
HERSELF THIS CAN THIS IS
CAPTURED IN STANDARD THIRTEEN
THAT PREVENTS DUNGEONS INCLUDING
DELIBERATELY EXTENDING USE
AND REPETITIVE WHO WAS TOO
FRIGHTENED TO ACCESS THE ONLINE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OFFERED
BY HIS SCHOOL BECAUSE HE FEARED
THE INFORMATION WOULD BE SHAD
WHICH LED TO STANDARD NINE ABOUT
DATA SHARING AND SO ON
THE CODE BECAME LAW IN SEPTEMBER
LAST YEAR AND ALREADY WE'VE
SEEN SOME IMPORTANT CHANGES
GOOGLE HAS MADE SAFE SUCH
THE DEFAULT BROWSING MODE FOR
UNDER EIGHTEENS YOU TRIP TURNED
OFF AUTOPLAY BREAKING BEDTIME
REMINDERS THAT TURNED ON AS
DEFAULTS TICTOC ON INSTAGRAM
OF CHANGE THAT DEFAULT PRIVACY
SETTINGS FOR JOBS USES INCLUDING
IMPORTANTLY DISABLING OF DIRECT
MESSAGES BETWEEN CHILDREN AND
ADULTS THEY DON'T FOLLOW THE
GOOGLE PLAY STORE NOW PREVENTS
UNDER EIGHTEENS FROM VIEWING
AND DOWNLOADING APPS RATED
ACTIVE ADULTS ONLY AND CHILDREN
AGE THIRTEEN TO FIFTEEN ON
TICTOC DO NOT RECEIVE PUSH
NOTIFICATIONS AFTER NINE PM
AND THOSE SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
HAVE PUSH NOTIFICATIONS
DISABLED STARTING AT TEN
TO SUM UP THE CODES FIFTEEN
STANDARDS ARE INTERCONNECTED
AND INTERDEPENDENT BUT TOGETHER
THEY ESTABLISH THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN PRIVACY AND SAFETY
THEY SHOW THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY IS JUST AS CAPABLE
AS ANY OTHER SECTOR TO CHECK
THEIR PRODUCTS FOR SAFETY AND
THEY ESTABLISH BEYOND DOUBT
THAT LAWMAKERS HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY TO THOSE IN THE TECHNOLOGY
COMMUNITY MANY OF WHOM LIVE WORK
AND RAISE THEIR CHILDREN NOT
FROM FROM WHERE WE ARE TODAY I
ONLY ASK THAT DO YOU USE YOUR
GIFTS TO PROTECT AS WELL AS
TO ENTERTAIN AND EDUCATE OUR
KIDS TO SUPPORT INNOVATION
THAT KEEPS CHILDREN IN MIND
TACKLE THE PROBLEM BE THE
SOLUTION IN THE U. K.
THERE IS A STRONG BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS THAT WE NEED TO DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
IN A PROPORTIONATE AND SYSTEMIC
WAY BUT WE DO NEED THE STRENGTH
AND AUTHORITY OF THE UNITED
STATES TO SUPPORT WHAT HAS BEEN
THE BIGGEST DESIGN UPGRADE FOR
CHILDREN IN DECADES AND UPGRADE
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS TO
ACCEPT BUT THAT IS CERTAINLY
NOT STOPPED IT FROM THRIVING
THE CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVE ALL THE PROTECTIONS
NOW FORGET THOSE IN THE U. K.
AND AS CALIFORNIA IS THE BEACON
AT THAT AS THE TOWN CALIFORNIA
IS THE BEACON FOR THE WHOLE
WORLD IN TERMS OF TACK THE
ADOPTION OF THIS COAT WOULD BE
CRUCIAL TO SET A GLOBAL STANDARD
THE CHILDREN OF THE WORLD AND
LOOKING ON AND THEY NEED YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FAIRNESS
WE ARE NOW GOING TO TURN TO OUR
SECOND WITNESS DILLON HOFFMAN
HE IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR TECHNET FOR CALIFORNIA AND
THE SOUTHWEST PRIOR TO JOINING
TECHNET HE WAS THE DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION WORD ON
THE STREET IS ALSO GREAT LEAD
STAFFER WELL DONE IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR INVITING ME TO BE HERE --
AS MENTIONED MY NAME IS DON
HOFFMAN I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA THE
SOUTHWEST OF TECHNET AND TECHNET
IS THE NATIONAL BIPARTISAN
NETWORK OF TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
THAT PROMOTES THE GROWTH OF
THE INNOVATION ECONOMY OUR
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES
DYNAMIC AMERICAN BUSINESSES
RANGING FROM START UPS TO THE
MOST ICONIC COMPANIES ON THE
PLANET AND REPRESENTS OVER
FOUR MILLION EMPLOYEES AND
COUNTLESS CUSTOMERS IN THE
FIELDS OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
E-COMMERCE THE SHARING ECONOMY
ADVANCED ENERGY CYBERSECURITY
AND FINANCE TO NAME ONLY A FEW
FIRST CHILDREN'S PRIVACY AND
SECURITY IS A PRIORITY FOR OUR
COMPANIES WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
CHILDREN DESERVE A HEIGHTENED
LEVEL OF SECURITY AND PRIVACY
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS WITHIN THE INDUSTRY TO
INCORPORATE PROTECTIVE DESIGN
FEATURES AND OTHER WEBSITES AND
PLATFORMS OUR COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF RAISING
THE STANDARD FOR TEEN SAFETY AND
PRIVACY ACROSS OUR INDUSTRY BY
CREATING NEW FEATURES SETTINGS
AND PROTECTIONS THAT ARE AGE
APPROPRIATE AND TAILORED TO THE
DIFFERENT DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE SOME COMPANIES
HAVE CREATED FEATURES TO EMPOWER
TEAMS TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
ARE MEANINGFUL FOR THEM SUCH
AS REMINDERS TO TAKE BREAKS
REASON SETTINGS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM POTENTIAL
THREATS OR UNWANTED CONTACT
ADDITIONALLY OUR COMPANY'S
OF ROLLED OUT NEW FEATURES TO
INCLUDE PARENTS AND GUARDIANS
IN THEIR TEENS EXPERIENCES
BY BUILDING PARENTAL STRICT
SUPERVISION TOOLS TO GIVE THEM
MORE INSIGHT AND EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS TO ENCOURAGE DIALOGUE
BETWEEN PARENTS AND THEIR
TEAMS ON HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA
WHILE PROVIDING A SAFE
EXPERIENCE FOR USERS PROTECTING
THE PRIVACY ONLINE AND COMPLY
WITH ALL APPLICABLE LAWS IS
THE GOAL IS NOT WITHOUT ITS
CHALLENGES IN FACT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN THE VALUES OF PRIVACY
AND SECURITY CAN BE INTENTION
AGE VERIFICATION IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE UNDERSTANDING PEOPLE'S
AGE ON THE INTERNET IS A COMPLEX
CHALLENGE ACROSS OUR INDUSTRY
MANY OF ARE COPPA COMPLIANT
PLATFORMS ALREADY HAVE VARIOUS
METHODS OF IDENTIFYING REMOVING
ACCOUNTS USED BY PEOPLE WHO
MISREPRESENT THEIR AGE BUT
THEY'RE NOT FOOLPROOF -- FINE
EACH USER'S AGE COULD PROVIDE
A SAFER MORE SECURE EXPERIENCE
ONLINE BY DEFINITIVELY
IDENTIFYING WHICH USERS ARE
UNDER AGE AND BLOCKING THEM
FROM ACCESSING INAPPROPRIATE
SITES AND CONTENT HOWEVER THIS
WOULD REQUIRE COLLECTING MORE
SENSE OF INFORMATION WHICH RUNS
COUNTER TO DATA MINIMISATION
PRINCIPLES BEYOND MINIMIZING
DATA SELF FOR VERIFICATION
OR COLLECTING IDENTIFICATION
HAS LIMITATIONS FIRST SELF
VERIFICATIONS TO EASY TO
GET AROUND AS ANYONE WHO HAS
ACCESS TO AN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
SITE CAN ATTEST THERE ARE
ALSO SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH
IDENTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T HAVE AN
ID ID COLLECTION ISN'T A FAIR
OR EQUITABLE SOLUTION EITHER
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT ID'S VARIES
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE AS
IS THE INFORMATION CONTAINED
IN A NINETY SUCH AS A BIRTHDAY
CONVERSATIONS ARE ONGOING AS
TO HOW WE AS AN INDUSTRY CAN
IMPROVE THE PROCESS AND WORK
TOGETHER TO SHARE INFORMATION
AND PRIVACY PRESERVING WAYS THE
HELP SITES ESTABLISH WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE OVER A SPECIFIC
AGE ONE AREA WE BELIEVE HAS
REAL PROMISE IS WORKING WITH
OPERATING SYSTEM PROVIDERS
INTERNET BROWSERS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS SO THEY CAN SHARE
INFORMATION TO HELP WEBSITES AND
APPS ESTABLISHED WHETHER SOMEONE
IS OF AN APPROPRIATION THIS
HAS THE DUAL BENEFIT OF HELPING
DEVELOPERS KEEP UNDERAGE PEOPLE
OFF THEIR PLATFORMS OR MOVING IN
THE NEED TO GO THROUGH DIFFERENT
AND POTENTIALLY CUMBERSOME AGE
VERIFICATION PROCESSES ACROSS
MULTIPLE SITES AND SERVICES
WELL IT'S ULTIMATELY UP TO
INDIVIDUAL WEBSITES TO ENFORCE
THEIR AGE POLICIES AND COMPLY
WITH THEIR LEGAL OBLIGATIONS
COLLABORATION WITH OPERATING
SYSTEM PROVIDERS INTERNET
BROWSERS AND OTHERS WOULD BE
A HELPFUL ADDITION TO THOSE
EFFORTS LIKE TO CLOSE QUICKLY
WITH SOME CONSIDERATIONS FOR
POLICYMAKERS WHEN CONSIDERING
NEW LAWS AND REGULATIONS ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
THE BEST RULES AND LAWS THE
ONES THAT WILL PROTECT CHILDREN
THE MOST ARE ONES THAT CAN BE
CONSISTENTLY EASILY AND RELIABLY
COMPLIED WITH CLEAR BRIGHT
LINE RULES ARE PREFERABLE TO
VAGUE SUBJECTIVE ONES RULES IN
TERMS THAT ARE CLEARLY DEFINED
WILL ENSURE MORE CONSISTENT
COMPLIANCE AND ADHERENCE
TO THOSE RULES WITHOUT SUCH
DEFINITIONS COMPANIES MAY REACH
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONS OF
STANDARDS WHICH WILL RESULT IN
UNEVEN APPLICATION ONLINE ACROSS
SITES AND PLATFORMS ADDITIONALLY
FAIR AND CONSISTENT ENFORCEMENT
OF THE RULES WITH THE ABILITY
TO RECEIVE REGULATORY GUIDANCE
OR FIX VIOLATIONS WILL BE
NECESSARY MANY PROPOSED LAWS
PARTICULARLY PERTAINING TO
CHILDREN REQUIRED DIFFICULT
VALUE JUDGMENTS ON THE PART
OF COMPANIES THESE DECISIONS
DON'T FALL NEATLY INTO GOOD OR
BAD RIGHT OR WRONG REGULATORS
WILL DISAGREE WITH COMPANIES
ABOUT THEIR DECISIONS AND
COMPANIES WILL MAKE MISTAKES I'M
TRYING TO COMPLY IN GOOD FAITH
WITH THESE LOTS HER JUMPING
IMMEDIATELY TO FINES OR CIVIL
LIABILITY WILL CREATE UNEVEN
ENFORCEMENT OF SUBJECT RULES
AND SERVE ONLY TO HARM BUSINESS
AND IT BENEFIT ATTORNEYS FINES
IN LITIGATION WILL ALSO LEAD
TO OVER CORRECTIONS WHICH WILL
INEVITABLY LIMIT ACCESS TO KIDS
PROVIDING ROBUST GUIDANCE AND
FEEDBACK FROM REGULATORS AS
WELL AS THE ABILITY FIX GOOD
FAITH MISTAKES WILL HELP ENSURE
COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
AND IMPLEMENT THESE RULES
FINALLY AND DESIGNING ROLES WE
SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT TYPE OF
EXPERIENCE WE WANT KIDS TO HAVE
ONLINE IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
WE WANT A SAFE AGE APPROPRIATE
EXPERIENCE THE MODERN INTERNET
FOR ALL THE HARMS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY IS STILL AMERICAL
IS A MARVEL OF HUMAN ACHIEVEMENT
KNOWLEDGE AND SOMETHING WE
DON'T WANT TO COMPLETELY SHUT
CHILDREN OUT FROM PARTICULARLY
OUR TEENS YOU CAN ONLY LEGISLATE
SO FAR BEFORE THE END RESULTS
ARE SWIMMING KIDS AND TEENS
ACCESS THE OPEN FREE INTERNET
AS NOTED BY EARLIER PANELISTS
KIDS AND TEENS INTERACT SOCIALLY
ONLINE THEY LEARN AND SUBMIT
THEIR HOMEWORK ONLINE THEY
CREATE ART MUSIC AND LITERATURE
ONLINE AND THEY CONNECT WITH
THE WIDER WORLD ACROSS BORDERS
CULTURES AND LANGUAGES ALL
ONLINE IN OUR PURSUIT TO PROTECT
KIDS WHICH WE ALL AGREE WE
NEED TO PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL OF
SECURITY FOR THEM WE SHOULDN'T
LOSE SIGHT OF THE TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS OF THE INTERNET THAT
THE INTERNET STILL HOLDS AND
ITS IMMENSE POWER TO TEACH
PROVIDE COMMUNITY AND INSPIRE
CHILDREN AND TEENS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OFTEN
I WANT TO I APPRECIATE YOU FOR
MAKING THE TIME TO TESTIFY TODAY
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE INDUSTRY AT THE
TABLE WHEN WE ARE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND TO HEAR THE
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE INNOVATIVE
COMPANIES THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE CREATING SO MUCH OF THIS
CONTENT THAT'S WHY AND AND THESE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THAT'S
WHY I BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A SPECIAL OBLIGATION IN
A SPECIAL OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO --
TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY AND HELP
DRIVE THIS CONVERSATION IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION RIGHT NOW MY
PLEASURE TO WELCOME OUR FINAL
WITNESS DR HANY FARID HE IS A
PROFESSOR AT THE BEST UNIVERSITY
IN THE WORLD UC BERKELEY AT THE
SCHOOL THERE SEEMS TO BE
CONSENSUS ON THAT AT THE SCHOOL
OF -- ELECTORAL ENGINEERING
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND THE
SCHOOL OF INFORMATION -- AND
-- MISS WICKS HAS TO AGREE THAT
IT'S THE BEST UNIVERSITY IN THE
WORLD SINCE SHE REPRESENTS THAT
-- HE IS A WORLD RENOWNED FOR
HIS EXPERTISE ON DIGITAL IMAGE
FORENSICS -- AND OFTEN CONSULTED
TO WEIGH IN ON A AYE SYNTHESIZE
CONTENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR FASTER WE APPRECIATE YOUR
BEING HERE WITH US THANKS
I I MAY NOT BE APPARENT
ESPECIALLY SUMMIT BERKELEY
SO I HAVE THAT GOING FOR ME
MISTER CHAIRMAN JERRY THANK YOU
-- TO THE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
ARE WE CAN'T PRETEND THAT THE
INTERNET AND MORE GENERALLY
TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT HAD A
PHENOMENALLY POSITIVE IMPACT ON
SOME ASPECTS OF OUR LIVES OUR
SOCIETIES AND OUR ECONOMIES WE
ALSO CAN'T PRETEND AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THE INTERNET HAS NOT
HAD LEAD TO REAL HARM IN THE
FORM OF CHILD EXPLOITATION
TERRORISM THE SALE OF ILLEGAL
AND DEADLY DRUGS SMALL TO
LARGE SCALE FRAUD INVASIONS OF
OUR PRIVACY IN THE SPREADING
OF DEADLY AND DANGEROUS
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS
DESIGNED TO SOW CIVIL UNREST AND
DISRUPT THE DEMOCRATIC ELECTIONS
IN PARTS AND YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
THIS BEFORE I'M AND I'M I'M
GONNA REEMPHASIZE IT THIS IS
BECAUSE SOME OF THE LARGEST
TITANS OF THE TECH SECTOR THE
FACEBOOKS TWITTERS THE YOU
TUBES IN THE TECH TALKS ARE
BASED ON AN AD DRIVEN BUSINESS
IT IS SAID THAT IF THE PRODUCT
IS FREE THEN YOU ARE NOT THE
CUSTOMER YOU'RE THE PRODUCT
REVENUE SOCIAL MEDIA'S AD DRIVEN
MODEL IS MAXIMIZED BY MAXIMIZING
USER ENGAGEMENT WHICH MEANS
THAT MORE OFTEN THAN NOT PRIVACY
AND SECURITY TAKE A BACKSEAT
IN THE NAME OF ENGAGEMENT BASED
METRICS IN SOME CASES WE BEEN
BENEFICIARIES OF THIS BUSINESS
MODEL IN TERMS OF ENTERTAINING
INSPIRING AND ENGAGING CONTENT
OUR FINGER TO FINGER TIPS
CROCHETING FOR EXAMPLE OPERATE
OTHER CASES WE'VE BEEN THE
VICTIMS OF THIS BUSINESS MODEL
IN TERMS OF INVASIONS OF OUR
PRIVACY AND REAL MEASURABLE
WORLD HARMS THE BILL BESIDE NO
BY THE WAY I'VE BEEN MENTIONING
ONLINE AND OFFLINE IN REAL WORLD
AND I JUST WANT EMPHASIZES THAT
IT'S BEEN THIS TENDENCY TO TALK
ABOUT THE INTERNET LIKE IT'S
LAS VEGAS WHAT HAPPENS ON THE
INTERNET STAYS ON THE INTERNET
AND IT'S IT'S NOT TRUE I'M
WITH THE BLUE LIBERATED THE
LINE BETWEEN THE ONLINE AND THE
OFFLINE WORLD AND WHAT HAPPENS
ON THE INTERNET HAS REAL WORLD
IMPLICATIONS AND WE HAVE TO STOP
MAKING THIS DISTINCTION SOMEHOW
THAT IT'S JUST THE INTERNET
WE HAVE TO THEREFORE THINK
ABOUT TODAY'S ONLINE SAFETY THE
SAME WAY WE HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
YESTERDAY'S OFFLINE SAFETY IN
THE FIRST PANEL YOU ASKED ABOUT
THE RIGHT AND ALLERGY AND I
THINK THE CAR INDUSTRY'S EXACTLY
THE RIGHT ANALOGY HERE WHILE
REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN AGREE ON
WHAT IF ANY SAFEGUARDS SHOULD
BE PUT IN PLACE TO PROTECT
CONSENTING ADULTS MY MIND HARMS
MOST REASONABLE PEOPLE ALSO
AGREED THAT SPECIAL CARE SHOULD
BE GIVEN TO CHILDREN FROM THE
GLOBAL YEARLY DISTRIBUTION OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PIECES OF
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE MATERIAL
WHERE THE AVERAGE AGE OF A
CHILD IS EIGHT YEARS OLD DOWN
TO NOW A NEW CATEGORY CALLED
PREVERBAL TO CHILD GROOMING
SEXTORTION SCREEN TIME ADDICTION
AGE INAPPROPRIATE ADVERTISING
UNHEALTHY BODY IMAGES WE MUST WE
MUST THINK MORE CAREFULLY ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THESE POWERFUL
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE PLACED
IN THE HANDS OF CHILDREN IN
EVERY WAKING MOMENT OF THEIR
YOUNG LIVES THERE ARE PRACTICAL
MEASURED IN REASONABLE
SAFEGUARDS THAT WE CAN PUT
IN PLACE TO PROTECT CHILDREN
ONLINE WE SHOULD FOR EXAMPLE
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND DEPLOY
NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO DISRUPT THE
GLOBAL DISTRIBUTION OF CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE MATERIAL I WAS FOR
EXAMPLE PART OF THE TEAM THAT
DEVELOPED AND DEPLOYED PHOTO
DNA IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
I TECHNOLOGY THAT IS NOW USED
WORLDWIDE TO FIND AND REMOVE
PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED IMAGES
OF CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE DESPITE
THE WIDE ADOPTION SUCCESS OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY FOR OVER A
DECADE AND DESPITE CLAIMS FROM
THE PRIVACY SECTOR THAT WE ARE
GOING TO DESTROY THE INTERNET
-- AND DESPITE YEARS OF CAJOLING
DESPITE THE FACT THAT VIDEOS
TODAY NOT IMAGES ARE NOW THE
DOMINANT FORM OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE IMAGERY THE TECH INDUSTRY
HAS STILL IS STILL IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO NOT ADOPTED
UNIVERSAL VIDEO STANDARD TO
REMOVE KNOWN CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
MATERIAL WE SHOULD ALSO ENSURE
THAT PREDATORS ARE NOT ABLE TO
ENGAGE WITH CHILDREN -- ONLINE
ONLINE GAMING PLATFORMS FOR
EXAMPLE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
A SERIOUS PRODUCT OR PROBLEM
IN WHICH YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
BEING GROOMED AND SUCH STARTED
AN ONLINE GAMES WHERE THE
PREDATORS GO THEY GO WITH THE
CHILDREN ARE IN THE CHILDREN
AROUND THE GAMING PLATFORM
IT'S NOT DIFFICULT TO DRAW THAT
CONNECTION IT WASN'T UNTIL JUST
A FEW YEARS AGO HOWEVER THAT
A MICROSOFT LED TEAM THAT I
WAS PART OF BUILT A PROTOTYPE
SYSTEM TO DETECT GROOMING
PATTERNS ON ONLINE GAMING THIS
TECHNOLOGY HOWEVER IS STILL NOT
BEING FULLY SUPPORTED DEVELOPED
OR DEPLOYED BY THE INDUSTRY
WE SHOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN DON'T ACCESS AGE
INAPPROPRIATE ONLINE SERVICES
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THAT AND LET'S TALK SOME MORE
ABOUT AGE APPROPRIATENESS THE
BASIC APPROACH TODAY TO AGE
VERIFICATION WHAT IS CONSIDERED
THE INDUSTRY STANDARD IS
TO SIMPLY ASK THE USER TO
VERIFY THEIR AGE BY CLICKING
THE BOX OR ENTERING THEIR
BIRTH DATE LET'S PLEASE NOT
PRETEND THAT THIS IS IN ANY
WAY EFFECTIVE DESPITE THIS
ABSURDLY LOW INDUSTRY STANDARD
THERE ARE OTHER APPROACHES TO
AGE VERIFICATION INCLUDING A
USER'S NAME ADDRESS AND DATE OF
BIRTH CAN BE COMPARED AGAINST
ELECTORAL ROLLS GOVERNMENT
DATABASES OR PRIVATE SECTOR
DATABASES AS IS COMPLETELY
CALM IN THE FINANCIAL SECTOR
GOVERNMENT ISSUED DOCUMENTS
CAN BE PHOTOGRAPHED ALONG WITH
THE DOCUMENT HOLDER TO VERIFY
IDENTITY AND AGE I JUST DID
THIS THE OTHER DAY FOR GOOGLE
I I TO MAKE A CHANGE ON THAT
THE PANELISTS ASSOCIATE WITH MY
NAME IN A GOOGLE SEARCH AND I TO
PROVE MY IDENTITY TOOK A SELFIE
WITH THE US LICENSE SIGNED UP
TO GOOGLE THAT'S HOW THEY KNEW
WHO I WAS WE NOT DO THIS IT'S
NOT THERE'S NOTHING YOU HEAR
ON A AYE BASED FACIAL ANALYSIS
CAN DETERMINE WITH REASONABLE
ACCURACY IF A USER IS UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN I AM A USER'S
AGE CAN BE VERIFIED AT THE TIME
A MOBILE DEVICES PURCHASED AT
WHICH POINT THE PHONE ITSELF
CAN ARE SECURELY VERIFIED
ANY APPS OR SERVICES ARE AGE
APPROPRIATE I LIKE BY THE WAY
WHEN THE INDUSTRY TELLS US
THAT THEY DON'T LIKE TO DO AGE
APPROPRIATE AT AGE VERIFICATION
BECAUSE THE CONCERNS OF PRIVACY
ON THEY SEEM TO FORGET THAT
THE ENTIRE BUSINESS MODEL IS
B. AS PROMISED I'M VACUUM UP
EVERY MORSEL OF PERSONAL DATA
AND TELLING ADVERTISERS THAT
THEY HAVE THESE PHENOMENALLY
PRECISE -- PROFILES ABADEH SO
THAT THEY CAN TARGET ADVERTISE
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS YOU
CAN'T BECOME A TRILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY BY BOBBING OUR PRIVACY
AND THEN WHEN WE ASK YOU TO DO
SOMETHING TO PROTECT CHILDREN
I MIGHT SAY WELL WE DON'T WANT
TO VIOLATE PEOPLE'S PRIVACY
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS
BEYOND THE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES --
THAT I'VE ENUMERATED AND MORE
GENERALLY WE CAN AND WE SHOULD
ENSURE THAT ONLINE PRODUCTS LIKE
OFFLINE PRODUCTS ARE BY DESIGN
SAFE FOR CHILDREN IN TERMS
OF THEIR MENTAL EMOTIONAL AND
PHYSICAL SAFETY THE FUNDAMENTAL
IMITATION HERE IS NOT TECHNICAL
IN NATURE THIS IS NOT TO SAY
THE SOLUTIONS WILL BE EASY OR
THAT THEY WILL COME WITHOUT SOME
COMPROMISES WE SHOULD HOWEVER
HAVE AN HONEST CONVERSATION OF
THE RISK TO CHILDREN POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS IN THE COST OF THE
SOLUTIONS AND FIND A PROPER
COMPROMISE TO KEEP CHILDREN
SAFE WHILE ENSURING A VIBRANT
INTERNET THE BENEFITS ENVISIONED
SOCIETY I ALSO LIKE BY THE WAY
WHEN COMPANIES TELL US THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE REGULATION
-- THESE COMPANIES SEEM TO
FORGET THAT THE REASON WE
HAVE GOOGLE IS BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STEPPED IN
AND SLACK MICROSOFT AROUND FOR
USING THEIR MARKET DOMINANCE
TO STIFLE INNOVATION REGULATION
CAN HELP CREATE A MORE HEALTHY
ARMIDE ECOSYSTEM SO COMPETITORS
CAN MAKE BETTER PRODUCTS
I LOOK FOR TO TALKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT THESE
IMPORTANT AND PRESSING
ISSUES THANK YOU GO BEARS
WHERE IS THANK YOU AT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT DOCTOR
FREED AT THIS POINT I WANT TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WAKES THANK YOU
CHECK THE REAL GOOD TO SEE
YOU AS WELL BOERNER HORVATH
AND THANK YOU BOTH FOR --
PULLING THIS TOGETHER AND I'M
EXCITED TO BE HERE -- I'VE RUN
SOME BILLS IN THE SPACE AND
DOING A BILL -- WITH MILADY
-- THIS YEAR'S WELL ALONG
WITH THEM SOON WE'RE CUNNINGHAM
-- AND I WANTED TO ACTUALLY
ASK ALL OF YOU AND I'M CURIOUS
IF WE GET THE SAME RESPONSE
OR NOT -- YOU KNOW BARONESS
YOU'D SAID THAT OPTIMIZING FOR
CHILDREN DEPENDS CHIEFLY ON THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE COMPANY'S TOP
LEADERSHIP TO SAY YES TO THAT
AND YOU'VE ACTUALLY PUT FORTH
REGULATIONS IN THE U. K. THAT
ARE REQUIRING THOSE CHANGES AND
I KNOW YOU SAID SOME EFFECTIVE
THAT YOU KNOW WORKING WITH
ENGINEERS ARE NATURAL PROBLEM
SOLVERS WHICH I DON'T DOUBT
BUT THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN I
THINK THAT LEADERSHIP SAYING
YES RIGHT THERE HAS TO BE A
WILLINGNESS AND LEADERSHIP WITH
THESE COMPANIES AND I THINK
THERE'S AN INHERENT TENSION
HERE OF THE COMPANIES MAKE MONEY
WHEN THEY HAVE MORE EYEBALLS
ON THEIR PRODUCT MORE EYEBALLS
ON THE PRODUCT ARE THINGS THAT
ENCOURAGE MORE TIME ONLINE
RIGHT WHICH IS THIS TENSION THAT
THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
TRIED TO DISCUSS HERE RIGHT --
ARE THE THAT YOU OUTLINED SO
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE ARE THESE
COMPANIES WILLING TO SAY YES
AND WERE THERE ANY CHALLENGES
WITH THAT AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ASK THE SAME QUESTION TO
THE OTHER TWO AS WELL -- WHO
HAVE REPRESENT COMPANIES AND
I'VE WORKED WITH COMPANIES IS
THERE A LEADERSHIP TO TACKLE
THIS AND CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME
TANGIBLE EXAMPLES OF IF YES OR
NO I'M WELL IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND I THINK THAT THE
AND MAYBE I CAN POINT TO SOME
RESEARCH THAT WE DID LAST YEAR
AND WE LOOKED AT COMPANIES
OWN DECLARATIONS OF WHAT
THEY WERE DOING IN THAT TERMS
AND CONDITIONS WHAT WHAT THEY
DOING AND WHEN WE LINE THEM
UP THEY WERE DOING PRIVACY TO
A GREAT DEGREE BECAUSE BASS
LAW AND THEY WERE DOING HUMAN
SLAVERY GLASS AND THEY'RE DOING
IT GOES EVEN LESS AND THAT
YOU'RE NOT AND IT WENT DOWN
AND DOWN AND SO THE ANSWER IS
WHEN THEY ARE ASKED BY SOCIETY
BY LAWMAKERS TO PUT IT AT THE
TOP OF THE IN TRAY THAN THEY DO
YEAH WHEN THE REQUIRED WHEN IT'S
REQUIRED SO I DON'T
DOUBT THAT ANYBODY INSIDE THOSE
COMPANIES WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
BACKUP THAT SERVICES BUT OF THE
CHILDREN BUT IN THE COMPETING TO
MONTHS OF A BUSINESS WHAT
GETS TO THE TOP OF THE AND TRY
IS WATCHES WITH QUIET YEAH
SHAREHOLDER VALUE LAW
THOSE OF THE TWO THINGS
SO I WOULD LIKE SOME LOSS
OF EIGHT CAN SAY YES IN
THE WAY THAT THEY WISH TO
I THINK IT'S A MIXED BAG -- SO
I THINK THERE ARE SOME ENGINEERS
WHO ARE NATURAL PROBLEM SOLVERS
AND THEY WILL SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
OF THEIR TOLD SOLVE I THINK
THERE ARE OTHER A FAIR NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN SILICON VALLEY THOUGH
THAT ARE SORT OF FUNDAMENTALLY
BELIEVE THAT THE INTERNET IS
THE INTERNET -- THE GOOD THE
BAD THE UGLY AND IT'S NOT OUR
FAULT -- I DISAGREE WITH THAT
-- I THINK THAT'S A PARTICULARLY
CRAVING WAY OF LOOKING AT
THE WORLD -- I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THERE IS
INTENSE PRESSURE BECAUSE OF THE
UNDERLYING BUSINESS MODEL THAT
BUSINESS MODEL IS AN ATTENTION
GRABBING AD DELIVERY BUSINESS
MODEL AND THE REASON FOR THAT
BY THE WAY IS BECAUSE TWENTY
YEARS AGO NOBODY THOUGHT WE
CAN MAKE MONEY ON THE INTERNET
NOBODY ENVISIONED THAT WE BE
PUTTING OUR CREDIT CARD IN
BUYING SUBSCRIPTIONS IN BUYING
ABSENT THAT COMFORT THAT WE NOW
HAVE AND SO THE ONLY BUSINESS
MODEL WE COULD CONCEIVE BOB WAS
THE ATTENTION GRABBING EIGHT
ENGAGEMENT METRIC OF DELIVERING
ADS I WOULD ARGUE TODAY THAT
LANDSCAPE LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT
AND THAT MAYBE WE NEED BETTER
BUSINESS MODELS BUT WE CAN'T
BECAUSE WE HAVE FIVE TRILLION
DOLLAR COMPANIES THEIR STARTLING
INNOVATION IN THE SPACE
ARM NOW ON THIS AND THE C.
SUITE I THINK IT DEPENDS
ON WHICH COMPANY TO I THINK
SOME COMPANIES ARE BETTER
THAN OTHERS -- I THINK SOME
COMPANIES CAN YOU NAME NAMES
PLEASE SIGN IN YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT
BEING A TENURED PROFESSOR --
TRYING TO FIRE ME --
BOB I THINK SNAP AS WELL SO FOR
ME TO SAY I DON'T THINK ANY OF
THE COMPANIES ARE DOING A GREAT
JOB -- WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THIS -- OVER LUNCH I THINK
SNAP IS IS ONE OF THE BETTER
COMPANIES I'M I THINK THEY ARE
TRYING AT THE C. SUITE LEVEL TO
REALLY DO BETTER BOB I THINK
THAT TWITTER AND YOUTUBE HAVE
SORT OF TURNED THE CORNER I'M
SO TWITTER HAS TURNED THE CORNER
FROM WE ARE THE FREE SPEECH
WING OF THE FREE SPEECH PARTY
AN ANYTHING GOES I THINK THEY'VE
TURNED THE CORNER I THINK YOU
TO PLEASE TURN THE CORNER I
WOULD I WOULD I WISH I COULD SAY
THAT'S TRUE OF FACEBOOK MATTER
BUT I DON'T THINK IT IS -- I
THINK THEY ARE STILL HAVE THEIR
HEAD PRETTY DEEP IN THE SAND
YEAH AND I CERTAINLY THINK THAT
THERE IS AN OBVIOUS EVIDENCE
THERE IS INTENSE PRESSURE ON THE
INDUSTRY TO ADAPT TO -- I THINK
THE CHANGING LANDSCAPE I DO
THINK THAT YOU ARE STARTING TO
SEE THE MARKET CORRECTING FOR
-- SOME THE LACK OF PROTECTIONS
FOR KIDS THAT HAVE EXISTED IN
THE PAST AND YOU ARE SEEING
THOSE PRODUCTS ARE BEING ROLLED
OUT WITH THE FULL FEATURES AND
YOU ARE SEEING THIS CHANGES SO
YEAH I DO SEE A -- A LEADERSHIP
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY TO TO
START TO ADDRESS THIS THANK YOU
SEMINAR COMING UP THANK YOU
SO I WANT TO FOCUS FOR
SECOND ON THE AGE VERIFICATION
PIECE BECAUSE IT STRIKES ME
AS FUNDAMENTAL TO THE SOUL
PUBLIC POLICY PROBLEM HAVING
HAD SOME EXPERIENCE I THINK I
MADE THREE ATTEMPTS TO GET AN
AGE VERIFICATION BILL SIGNED
INTO LAW HERE THE FIRST ONE DIED
ON THE FLOOR IN THE ASSEMBLY
THE SECOND ONE WHICH WAS
VETOED -- THE THIRD WHICH IS
VERY GLAD TO TO SAY IS
NOW THE LAW WHICH IS THIS IS
THIS IS AS MUCH AS I COULD
GET IN THREE YEARS OF TRY
IT'S NOW IN SECTION FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT POINT FIVE THE CIVIL
CODE NOW READS A REPRESENTATION
BY A MINOR THAT THE MINOR'S
PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN
HAS CONSENTED SHALL NOT BE
CONSIDERED TO BE CONSENT FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS CHAPTER SO
THAT SOLVES I GUESS
THE SORT OF NARROW PROBLEM
OF KID GOES TO DOWNLOAD AN
APP APPS SAYS HEY YOUR PARENT
AGREES THAT YOU ARE ON THIS
RIGHT IT'S OKAY AND THEY GO
ABSOLUTELY DONE RIGHT WHICH WAS
WHICH WAS SORT OF THE PRACTICE
BUT IN THE EXPERIENCE OF
LEGISLATIVE TRYING TO LEGISLATE
IN THIS AREA I HAVE ENCOUNTERED
A NUMBER OF ARGUMENTS THE
INDUSTRY KEPT SORT OF RECYCLING
AND ONE WHICH I FOUND SORT
OF FUNNY AND I'D LIKE TO GET
YOUR GUYS THOUGHTS BOTH INDUSTRY
PROFESSOR OF BARONESS IF YOU'D
LIKE IS THIS IT WE WE CAN'T
TECHNOLOGICALLY DO IT WHICH I
JUST I JUST THINK ANY MAYBE FIVE
YEARS AGO RIGHT BUT EVERY TO
THE PROFESSOR'S POINT THE ENTIRE
BUSINESS MODEL IS MAKING TENS
OF BILLIONS OF THE KILLING OF
THE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS A YEAR
DATA MINING THE LIVING CRAP
OUT OF THE USE OF EVERY USER
AND SELLING IT TO MARKETERS AND
THAT'S TREMENDOUSLY PROFITABLE
FOR THEM AND SO THEY THEY THEY
CAN PREDICT WHAT SHOW YOUR KIDS
LIKELY TO LIKE BECAUSE THEY
WATCHED SEVENTEEN OTHER SHOWS
ME TO ADMIT THAT THEY CAN THEY
KNOW IN SOME CASES WHETHER YOUR
TEENAGE DAUGHTER IS HAVING BODY
IMAGE ISSUES BECAUSE WHAT SHE'S
SEEING ON TICK TOCK OR INSTAGRAM
AND THEN SELL THAT DATA TO
PEOPLE THAT ARE MARKETING
PRODUCTS RELATED TO WEIGHT LOSS
OKAY AT THIS GOING ON RIGHT
SO AND IF YOU CAN'T GET THE
AGE VERIFICATION PIECE RIGHT
AT THE FRONT AND THEN HOW DO
WE KNOW THESE ARE THE KIDS
THAT WE WANT TO PROTECT ON THE
BACKEND RIGHT SO THAT SEEMS
LIKE A CRITICAL THING AND I
DON'T THINK WE'VE GONE FAR
ENOUGH AND IN THE LAW I SIGNED
UP FOR AN ACCOUNT FOR CRYPTO
THING THE OTHER DAY AND LIKE
THE PROFESSOR MENTIONED I TOOK
A PICTURE OF MY DRIVER'S LICENSE
IT TOOK ABOUT TWO MINUTES AND
THEY SAID YEP YOU'RE VERIFIED
YOU CAN START THIS ACCOUNT
BUT KIDS CAN DOWNLOAD ANY SORT
OF APP ON THEIR PHONE BY
THE WAY ALL OF THIS THAT OUR
PARENTS ARE NOW IT IS NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE TO KEEP TRACK OF WHAT
YOUR KIDS UP ON THE PHONES VERY
DIFFICULT AND YOU DON'T REALLY
WANT TO HAVE A PLEASE STATE
YOUR HOUSE AND YOU PROBABLY
LOSE EVEN IF YOU TRY TO DO IT
I MEAN LET'S BE REALISTIC ABOUT
I MEAN YOU COULD DO THAT
PROCESS TWICE THEY WANT TO
DOWNLOAD A PARTICULAR APP MAYBE
IT THAT APP EXPOSES THEM TO
POTENTIAL CONTENT THAT MIGHT
BE INAPPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
AGE -- AS DEEMED BY EVERYBODY
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW I'M TALKING STUFF THAT
WE'RE HERE TO ADDRESS THE
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ABUSE THINGS
THAT HERE YOU HAVE TO GET YOUR
PARENTS TO SAY IT'S OKAY TO GO
INTO THE RATED R. MOVIE LIKE
THAT STUFF RIGHT AND WORSE --
YOU COULD OKAY YOU WANT ON
THIS THE SAP YOU NEED A PARENT
PICTURE DRIVER'S LICENSE PARENTS
AND SAYS OKAY NOW YOU CAN
DOLLAR I MEAN THAT SEEMS LIKE
A SIMPLE TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTION
TO VERIFYING THAT THE KID HAS
PARENTAL CONSENT AND IS OF THE
APPROPRIATE AGE I MEAN THIS
IN MY HOUSEHOLD -- WE'VE HAD
IN THE LAST PRICE SIX MONTHS --
THIS MY INTEREST IN THIS THING
STARTED YEARS AGO WHEN MY
DAUGHTER WHO IS LIKE TEN OR
ELEVEN AT THE TIME WAS PLAYING
ANIMAL JAM WHICH YOU THINK ABOUT
AN INNOCUOUS SOUNDING FREAKING
ONLINE GAME ANIMAL JANET MY
WIFE AND I DISCOVERED THAT
SOME CHILD PREDATOR WAS MAKING
SEXUALLY INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS
TO HER WHILE SHE'S PLAN ANIMAL
JAM ANIMAL JAM WAS GONE FROM
OUR HOUSEHOLD TEN MILLISECOND
SAY SURE YOU UP WE'VE
HAD TWO HUNDRED BUCKS OF THE
XBOX VIDEO GAME CHARGES ON MY
WIFE'S CREDIT CARD FOR MY SON'S
BUYING FIFA PLAYER CARD PACKS
RIGHT WE'VE HAD A BODY IMAGE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE HAD DISCUSSED
AT LENGTH WITH ONE OF OUR TEEN
TEEN DAUGHTERS -- YOU KNOW
I COULD GO ON AND ON BUT THAT'S
JUST IN OUR ONE HOUSEHOLD OKAY
SO BACK TO AGE VERIFICATION
I FIND IT BORDERING ON
DISINGENUOUS THAT THESE TECH
COMPANIES SAY THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY OR THE
CAPABILITY TO VERIFY THAT THE
USERS ON OUR PLATFORM ARE
EITHER OF THE APPROPRIATE AGE OF
CONSENT IN EVERYWHERE ACROSS LAW
WHICH IS EIGHTEEN IN CALIFORNIA
OR BE THEIR PARENTS DID IN
FACT CONSENT TO THE USE OF THE
PRODUCT SO I'D LIKE TO GET THE
LOTS ON THAT AND MAYBE THERE'S
WAYS THAT I WAS UNABLE TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS -- I'D LIKE
INPUT FROM INDUSTRY AS WELL AND
YOU'RE JUST THAT FEEL FREE TO
CONTACT SURE AND I CAN TAKE A
FIRST AND LET ME JUST MAKE
SURE I WAS CLEAR IN MY IN
MY TALKING POINTS I'M NOT
SAYING THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT WE
CAN'T DO BETTER WHAT I'M SAYING
THE RIGHT NOW IS THAT THERE
ARE TRADE OFFS AND THERE ARE
CHALLENGES WITH DIFFERENT
CHOICES TO ERROR AGE VERIFY
-- THERE ARE YOU KNOW NEW
LAWS IN THE STATE CPRE WE ARE
EXPECTING YOU REGULATIONS OUT
THIS YEAR THAT MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR TO COMPANIES THAT WE ARE
TO COLLECT IF WE ARE COLLECTING
PERSONAL INFORMATION WHERE
TO USE IT FOR THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH IT WAS COLLECTED AND
VERY LITTLE ELSE AND WE'VE
GOT TO DISCLOSE THAT AND THAT
THERE ARE VERY -- STRINGENT
-- BREACH LAWS AND PENALTIES
FOR -- INFORMATION THAT IS
ACCESSED -- IN CASE OF A BREACH
INCLUDING SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION SUCH AS A DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR OTHER GOVERNMENT ID
-- I THINK WHEN YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CURRENT TECHNOLOGY
I THINK THAT'S THE TRADE OFF
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
DO WE WANT TO USE SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION FOR THE PURPOSES
OF OF AGE VERIFYING ANY AGE
GATING THAT'S A CHOICE I THINK
FOR THIS BODY BUT THERE ARE
STRONG INCENTIVES FOR COMPANIES
TO MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF DATA
THAT WE HAVE AND MINIMIZE THE
USES FOR WHICH AND I THINK
I MENTIONED IN MY MY TALKING
POINTS I THINK THERE ARE WAYS
THAT WE COLLECTIVELY AS AN
INDUSTRY UNITING SOME OF THE
OPERATING SYSTEM PROVIDERS
THE INTERNET BROWSERS THE
END USER AND USER'S WEBSITES
APPLICATIONS -- TO REACH OF A
BETTER MORE PRIVACY PROTECTIVE
SOLUTION -- BUT RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE THOSE THOSE TRADE
OFFS AND AND I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE AND I'M SIMPLY
SAYING THERE ARE CHALLENGES
WITH THAT I I I HEAR THAT THE
THE THE THE THING I FIND FUNNY
IS I MEAN MAYBE WE JUST SEVEN
CREATED THE INCENTIVE STRUCTURE
TO DO IT YET BECAUSE I JUST
CAN'T BELIEVE I MEAN IT TWO
GENERATIONS AGO ENGINEERS
THAT WORKED AT THESE COMPANIES
WOULD HAVE BEEN DESIGNING
ROCKETS TO PUT MAN ON THE MOON
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE
DOING AND NOW THESE ARE SOME
OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE ON THE
PLANET I MEAN AND AND SO IS
IT IS IT THE LACK OF INCENTIVE
BECAUSE I DON'T I DON'T SEE
WHERE THE INCENTIVE IS I MEAN
IF IF THERE'S A LOT OF SAYS YOU
HAVE TO DO IT YOU GOTTEN SENT
TO DO IT IF THERE'S NO LAW IT
SEEMS LIKE THE INCENTIVES WHICH
IS HOW WE SEE IN THIS INDUSTRY
GROW WHICH IT WHICH IS IN
THE DATA HARVESTING AND DATA
MINING FOR ADVERTISING PURPOSES
AND THAT'S BEEN AN IMMENSELY
PROFITABLE HISTORICALLY
UNPRECEDENTED WE PROP PROFITABLE
RIGHT SO THERE IT'S CERTAINLY
I WOULD SEE SEEM TO THINK
THERE'S A THERE'S AN INCENTIVE
IN BALANCE RIGHT AND THAT'S
AND THAT'S CAPITALISM TO AGREE
AND I GOT NO PROBLEM PEOPLE
MAKE A BUCK BUT YOU KNOW MAYBE
HAVE WE NOT NUDGED YOU ENOUGH
IN ONE DIRECTION OR THE OTHER
HAVE WE NOT INSISTED ON THE
COLLABORATION OF WE NOT ME WHAT
WHERE WE WERE WE LACKING HERE
OKAY SO COUPLE OF THINGS I DON'T
THINK IT'S DISINGENUOUS FOR THE
COMPANIES TO SAY THEY CAN'T DO
IT I THINK IT'S JUST A LIE --
I KNOW I KNOW I'M NOT POLITE
-- SO A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE
IS THERE IS A LACK OF AND IT'S
WORSE THAN THAT THERE'S NOT A
LACK OF AN INCENTIVE IT NOT ONLY
IS THERE NO LAW SAYING YOU HAVE
TO DO IT THERE'S NO LIABILITY
THESE COMPANIES HAVE SECTION
TWO THIRTY THE COMMUNICATIONS
DECENCY ACT WHICH IS BASICALLY
EVERYTHING GETS KICKED BEFORE
THE JUDGE EVEN SEES ANYTHING
SO THERE THERE ISN'T EVEN A
LIABILITY THE BACK AND I'M LIKE
AUTOMOBILES RIGHT YOU BUILD A
CRAPPY CAR AND IT CRASHES AND
I DIE IN IT YOU'RE GONNA GET
SUED RIGHT YOU CAN'T SAY THAT
ABOUT THE PRODUCTS OF THERE'S NO
LIABILITY AT ONE AND THERE'S NO
LAWS AT THE OTHER END I'M TO THE
POINT ABOUT THAT WHAT WE DON'T
WANT TO COLLECT THIS INFORMATION
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO GET
STOLEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO RETAIN
THIS INFORMATION YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HOLD ONTO IT THAT THAT THAT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
THIS ARGUMENT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE RIGHT VERIFIED MENTALLY
THE THE THE DATA OR AT LEAST
HARD ENCRYPTED AT THE BACK AND
WE KNOW HOW TO DO ENCRYPTION
AREN'T SO AT THAT ARGUMENT
DOESN'T REALLY WORK I THINK
IT'S I THINK IT'S A COMPLETE
RED HERRING TO SAY WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IT BECAUSE THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE AND BECAUSE IT'S
BAD FOR BUSINESS AND WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS BAD FOR
BUSINESS RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
CREATE FRICTION THE REASON WHY
SOCIAL MEDIA WORKS SO WELL IS
BECAUSE IT'S FRICTIONLESS BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT FRICTION IS GOOD
FRICTION IN THE CRYPTO WORLD IS
GOOD BECAUSE IT HELPS PREVENT
FRAUD NOT ENOUGH THIS TO A LOT
OF FRAUD IN IT BUT THE REASON
WE PUT FRICTION IN SYSTEMS IS TO
SLOW DOWN THE BAD ACTORS RIGHT
WE DON'T HAVE THAT THE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES BECAUSE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO SIGN OUT
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THAT'S AN EYEBALL AND THAT'S
AN AD AND THAT'S MONEY THAT
WE PUT FRICTION IN THAT SYSTEM
TO OKAY I GOT MY LICENSE AND
TAKE A PICTURE OF A BLIND I'M
WILLING TO DO THAT TO GET MY
CREDIT CARD IF YOU GET A CRYPTO
ACCOUNT BUT MAYBE I'M GONNA LOSE
TWENTY PERCENT OF PEOPLE WHO
SIGNED UP FOR AN ACCOUNT THAT'S
ANNOYING RIGHT SO I THINK THAT
THE COLLABORATION HERE HAS TO BE
NOT WE CAN'T DO IT WE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT YOUR PRIVACY AND
THEN THE GOVERNMENT STEPPING IN
AND BEATING EVERYBODY OVER THE
HEAD WITH THE CLUB ALTHOUGH I
WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT I'M IS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE REALIGN THE
INCENTIVES AND HOW DO WE MAKE
THIS IS SEAMLESS AS POSSIBLE SO
FOR EXAMPLE YOU BEEN MENTIONING
SEVERAL TIMES OPERATING SYSTEMS
BROWSERS THE MOBILE DEVICES
CAN BE CENTRALIZED AT NIGHT IS
BASICALLY TO PHONE MAKERS IN THE
WORLD ANDROID AND APPLE RIGHT
SO WHAT WE CENTRALIZED WITH
THAT MAKE IT TO EVERY APP COULD
ACCESS WITH MY AGES SO THAT
WE CAN VERIFY ON THE PROJECT
CAN ACCESS THIS DOESN'T SOLVE
ALL THE PROBLEMS BY THE WAY
WE STOP LAPTOPS AND DESKTOPS
AND WE HAVE DIFFERENT DEVICES
WITH THE THINK ABOUT PEOPLE TO
SWITCH ACCOUNTS BUT SO I THINK
WE HAVE TO THINK MORE CREATIVELY
AND WE HAVE TO STOP PRETENDING
THAT THERE ISN'T A WAY TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM OR THAT IT SOMEHOW
IS GOING TO PUT EVERYBODY AT
RISK I THINK IT'S SIMPLY UNTRUE
I THINK I'M GONNA GO BACK
TO THE WORD DISINGENUOUS
-- FOR DECORUM SAKE BUT
I I I THINK THAT -- I THINK
THERE'S TWO ISSUES HERE ONE IS
WHETHER YOU CAN AND ACTUALLY
THAT'S A GREAT MANY WAYS OF
DOING IT AND IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE CENTRALIZED IT CAN BE
IT'S AN OPERATING SYSTEM IT
CAN BE A TOKEN AND IT CAN
BE A NUMBER YOU KNOW OF
VOICE IT CAN BE A FACE AND
THAT THERE ARE MANY WAYS AND
IN LOOKING AT ONE OF THOSE WAYS
THE BIT THAT IS MISSING IS THE
GOVERNMENT SPIT THE BIT THAT
WOULD ENSURE USE OF PRIVACY
ENSURE THAT SECURITY AND ENSURE
THAT EFFICACY BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S THE BILL THAT IS A A
LINE IF YOU LIKE IS TO SAY IT'S
NOT HAPPENING YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT GETS SHED WHEN
YOU USE YOUR LOG IN FROM ONE
COMPANY TO THE NEXT IT'S YOUR
AGE RANGE YEAH IT IS CONSTANTLY
SHED YOUR AGE ALL OF OUR AGE
INCLUDING KIDS SO I THINK I
THINK THE THAT'S ONE BIT BUT
I THINK WE HAVE TO ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION ABOUT WHY IS THIS SUCH
A LOT OF RESISTANCE BECAUSE THE
PURPOSE LIMITATION ALSO DOES
-- ACCRUE TO A DIFFERENCE
IT'S NOT THAT YOU'RE GONNA
PUT THIS LIMITATION AND IN
YOUR LOCAL AND THEN SAID THAT
IT DOESN'T IT BUT IT DOESN'T
ACCRUE TO AGE INSURANCE IT DOES
RIGHT SO WHY IS THERE SO MUCH
RESISTANCE IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT HAPPENS
ONCE YOU'VE IDENTIFIED AS A
CHILD RIGHT SO THE
CHILDREN ARE BEING TARGETED
FOR ADVERTISING AND IN FACT
I WOULD SAY THAT COMPANIES HAVE
DONE QUITE A GOOD JOB OF MAKING
AT AGE AT ADVERTISING AGE
APPROPRIATE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS IT'S A GREAT DEAL BETTER
THAN IT WAS WHEN I STARTED THIS
CONVERSATION HOWEVER THOSE
SAME CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS RECEIVING
AGE APPROPRIATE ADVERTISING
ARE BEING SENT CENTCOM
PURSUE SITE MESSAGES AND SO ON
BECAUSE THE COMPANIES ARE NOT
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
AGE OUTSIDE OF THE ADVERTISING
SO I THINK THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IT WE HAVE TO REALLY
SEPARATE AT THESE TWO ISSUES
WHAT IS THE FEASIBILITY TOTALLY
TECHNICAL FEASIBILITY YOU
KNOW WHY DON'T I WANT TO DO IT
BECAUSE OF THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT IS THE JOB OF LAWMAKERS
THAT IS THE INCENTIVE PICKS
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- GERMAN
YES THANK YOU I'M
I LIKE TO ASK MR HOFFMAN I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WITH CCPA MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IF YOU COLLECT
DATA FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSE
ECONOMY ONLY USE FOR THAT
PURPOSE IF YOU COLLECT DATA FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AGE VERIFICATION
THAT I CAN ONLY BE USED FOR THAT
PURPOSE SO THEN YOU HAVE THE
AGE VERIFICATION AND I THINK
I WOULD ENCOURAGE TECHNICAL
AND ALL THE TECH COMPANIES TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION FOR
THIS IT IS NOT OKAY THE SUMMIT
IS AND IS THEIR AGE THAT'S LIKE
GIVING SOMEBODY A FREE PASS OF
THE FAKE ID IN THE EIGHTIES LIKE
THAT'S INSANE WE ARE FAR BEYOND
THAT AND THE TECHNOLOGIES WE ON
THAT SIDE REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO INSTEAD OF SAYING WHY THIS
DOESN'T WORK TO COME BACK TO US
AND SAY THIS DOES WORK BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO AGE VERIFY AND I'M
NOT EVEN SURE THIRTEEN IS THE
RIGHT AGE I HAVE A FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD SON I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
THE RIGHT AGE AT ALL I DON'T
KNOW WHERE THIRTEEN CAME FROM
JORDAN PROBABLY KNOWS THAT I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM SORRY
YEAH THAT'S RIDICULOUS I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE DID WHAT WE
WELL THAT'S WHY ANYWAYS I'M
YEAH I THINK WE NEED TO ALSO
LOOK AT THE AGE LIMIT I'M I'M
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT I'M FULLY
FORMED BRAINS -- PROCESSING
THE AMOUNT OF STUFF THAT HAD
TO PROCESS THE LAST TWO YEARS
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT ON OUR YOUTH
AND AS I SAID EARLIER IN
SOME WAYS SOCIAL MEDIA ONLINE
PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN A GODSEND
IN SOME WAYS THEY HAVE CONNED
CAUSED IRREPARABLE HARM AND THE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES HAVE TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
AND I DON'T BELIEVE IT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN TRUST BUT VERIFY BUT I
DO BELIEVE VERY VERY STRONGLY
THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS FOR OUR LEGAL
A LEGAL FRAMEWORK FOR ENSURING
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING OUR
KIDS WE WANT PROTECT THEM THAT
WE'VE EXPANDED THE ANTI HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REGULATIONS TO GET
AT HUMAN TRAFFICKERS IN REAL
LIFE AND IT'S THE SAME ONLINE
WHEN I DID THAT WEAPON ARE
WITH MY D. A. AT HOME WHAT I
LEARNED PREVENTED ME FROM EVER
LETTING MY CHILDREN GO ON SOME
OF THESE PLATFORMS I HAD TO HAVE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS WITH
MY THEN THIRTEEN YEAR OLD AND
MY TEN YEAR OLD ABOUT HOW DO
YOU VERIFY SOMEBODY'S REALLY A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD FROM OAKLAND
AND NOT A FORTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD MAN FROM KENTUCKY SORRY
MAN THANK YOU BUT YOU KNOW
HOW HOW DO YOU KNOW ALL HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS MARKETS
BUT NOT EVERY PARENT HAS THE
TIME AND WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
IDENTIFICATION VERIFICATION
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER CALIFORNIA
WE DO HAVE UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS
SO HOW ARE YOU GETTING AT THE
UNDOCUMENTED AS WELL SO WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THAT SO I CHALLENGE
THE TECH COMPANIES TO COME
BACK TO US WITH SOME SORT OF
SOLUTION THAT'S GONNA DRESS THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP BECAUSE THAT ISSUES BROUGHT
UP BY THE BEARS VANNESS SORRY
AND DR FRED ARE OF VERY CLEARLY
I THINK IN THE INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND YOU
HAVE A BUNCH OF PARENTS ON
THIS PANEL YOU'RE A BUNCH OF
PARENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
WE ARE GOING TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN FOR WHATEVER IT TAKES
SO THAT'S WHY I GUESS IT'S
NOT A QUESTION I GUESS THAT'S
MY STATEMENT ON THE SPELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK THE
VERY NICE YOU WANTED TO COMMENT
ON THAT I JUST WANTED TO PICK
UP ON SOMETHING THE CHAIRWOMAN
SAID ABOUT AT THAT AGE RANGE I
THINK THAT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
IN THIS CONVERSATION NOT
TO SEE AGE VERIFICATION AS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KICK KIDS OFF THE
INTERNET IT'S THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TREAT THEM ACCORDING TO THAT
AGE AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS ABOUT
STUFF IT'S A LAW AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOOD THINGS THAT THE COMPANIES
HAVE DONE IN RELATION TO THE
CODE'S SO IF ACTUALLY YOU WORK
OUT IT'S A SEVEN YEAR OLD MAYBE
YOU NEED TO GET THE PREVIOUS C.
NOTICE IN THE VIDEO OR CONTENT
MAYBE YOU CAN ACTUALLY OFFER A
LITTLE BIT MORE HELP AS THEY TRY
AND A DOWNGRADE THAT PRIVACY
SETTING AND SO ON THE THE THE
IDENTIFYING OF AGE ISN'T REALLY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE SAFETY
WITH THE CHILD AS THEY GROW
BECAUSE A FIFTY A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD OUR SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD DOESN'T NEED THE SAME
PROTECTION THEY NEED DIFFERENT
PROTECTIONS ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY
M. ON H. AND AND IT SHOULD
NOT BE TESTING MUST NOT BE
TESTING BECAUSE THE MAJORITY
OF CHILDREN WHO COME TO
HARM OF FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN RIGHT AND THEY HAVE
NO PROTECTIONS THEY ARE TREATED
AS IF THEY'RE ADULTS SO THIS HAS
TO BE A SOPHISTICATED LOOK OF
RESPONSIBILITY FROM THE TECH
COMPANY I BELIEVE THEY CAN
DO IT WE JUST HAVE TO SET THE
SET THE BOX READ ONE MORE THING
HERE UP I AGREE WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THE H. CAREFULLY AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THAT I'M NOT
A CHILD ABOUT MENTAL YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THAT EARLY ON BUT ME
REMIND YOU THAT THE PREFRONTAL
CORTEX FULLY DEVELOPED IN THE
EARLY TO MID TWENTIES RIGHT
SO THE KIDS I'M TEACHING AT
UC BERKELEY ARE YOU ARE NOT
FULLY DEVELOPED IN THERE THE
PREFRONTAL CORTEX ON THAT MEANS
EXECUTIVE FUNCTION DECISION
MAKING UNDERSTANDING RISK NOT
FULLY DEVELOPED UNTIL YOUR MID
TWENTIES SO THAT THINK ABOUT
THAT IN RELATION TO A THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD AND WE SHOULD VERY HAVE VERY
SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
THAT AGES -- I GREW THE BARONESS
THIRTEEN IS WAY TOO YOUNG
MISTER BUMP I'M GLAD THAT
YOU JUST BROUGHT THAT UP --
BECAUSE I THINK -- -- THAT
THE OPPOSED EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
TO USE -- YOUNG ADULTS
-- ARE VERY MUCH TARGETED
TO -- -- BY -- ONLINE
PRODUCTS AND BEHAVIOR --
WHEN IT COMES TO -- EIGHT
-- THAT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE
TERRORISM A HAN A BODY
IMAGE I THINK -- YOU KNOW
FOR MANY YOUNG ADULTS OF THAT
AGE AND -- OF SUICIDE
-- -- AT THAT A SOLICITOR I
THINK -- THIS IS A OF
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION TODAY BUT -- A
BROADER ONE THAN WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO -- -- -- TO GET TO
IF THERE'S AN ENTIRE CONTINUUM
-- AND IT PROBABLY IF WE THINK
ABOUT IT PROBABLY GOES ON BEYOND
EVEN USE BUT WE JUST KNOW THAT
WE KNOW WHAT THE IMPRESSIONABLE
YEARS ARE AHEAD WE KNOW
THAT TO A TERRORIST FOR EXAMPLE
ARE FREQUENTLY GROOMED AT
A YOUNG AGE AND WE SEE THE
RESULTS -- AND AND HEADLINES
SO I JUST I WANNA -- AND
WE'RE COMING TO A CLOSE TO THE
CONCLUSION OF -- OF OF THE
HEARING I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU'VE PROVIDED IT'S BEEN
FASCINATING AND HELPFUL AND
USEFUL AND -- IN MANY
WAYS THAT I THINK GO BEYOND
JUST THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE HAD HERE TODAY YOU CAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM I'M AND I
DO WANT TO MOVE US IN A LITTLE
BIT TO -- PUBLIC COMMENT YEAH
JUST TO HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO WIN I GUESS
THE ONE THING I WANTED TO SORT
OF REFLECT ON AS I LISTEN ALL
THIS AND MAYBE IF ANY OF THE
PANELISTS ONE RESPOND -- YES
YOU KNOW IT TO ME IT'S SORT
OF THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE IS
A FUNDAMENTAL TENSION BETWEEN
PROFIT MOTIVATION AND WHAT IS
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND MENTAL
WELL BEING OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND AND THAT'S OKAY RIGHT I MEAN
THE COMPANIES HAVE A MANDATE IN
THEIR MANDATE IS TO TO MAXIMIZE
PROFITS FOR SHAREHOLDERS BUT WE
HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT MANDATE
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
THAT IS TO PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE
TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT -- IN THE
BROADER INTERESTS OF SOCIETY
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF GROUPS THAT
ARE VULNERABLE AND THERE'S AN
ESPECIALLY STRONG PUBLIC POLICY
CASE TO PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
-- WHAT'S IT WAS OBVIOUS TO
ME IS THAT SOME OF THESE CHOICES
ARE CLEAR TRADE OFFS BETWEEN
THE PROFIT MOTIVATION FOR THE
COMPANIES AND SAFETY AND HEALTH
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE BUT ALSO
LISTENING SOME OF THIS IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT SOME OF THOSE
THINGS REQUIRE THE COMPANIES
TO SACRIFICE PROFITS I WAS
LISTENING TO THE BARONESS YOU
KNOW TURNING OFF THE FEATURE
WHERE IN ADULTS CAN'T CONTACT A
CHILD THAT THEY'RE NOT FRIENDS
WITH ON INSTAGRAM I HAVE A
HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING HOW
THAT WOULD REALLY DRAMATICALLY
IMPACT THE PROFIT OF THAT
COMPANY BUT IT SEEMS LIKE A
REALLY LONG WAY FROM CREEPING
CREEPY PEOPLE AWAY FROM MY KIDS
RIGHT I MEAN THAT THAT THAT
SEEMS TO BE A TRADE OFF IT'S
A PRETTY EASY ONE TO MAKE AND
I ALSO WONDER AT THE SAME TIME
WHETHER SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THE COMPANIES ARE RESISTANT TO
OR AND INDEED ACTUALLY GOING
TO IMPACT THEIR PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES IN THE WAY THAT THEY
DO THAT I'M THINKING OF --
A BIRD THAT THE LEGENDARY HENRY
WAXMAN WHO CERTAINLY UNITED
STATES HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES AND
ALSO IN THIS BODY TALKING ABOUT
WHEN THEY WERE WORK WORKING
TO OUTLAW SMOKING IN BARS
THERE'S INCREDIBLE RESISTANCE
AND THEY SAID NO NO EVER COME
TO A BAR IF YOU CAN'T SMOKE
THERE IT TURNED OUT THAT THE
OPPOSITE WAS TRUE RIGHT THAT IT
WAS ACTUALLY BENEFITTED THEIR
BUSINESSES TO DO THAT I WONDER
THAT IF PARENTS YOU KNOW WITH
WITH MINIMAL EFFORT FROM SOME OF
THESE COMPANIES WORKING TO MAKE
THEIR PRODUCTS SAFER -- IT WOULD
REALLY BENEFIT THOSE COMPANIES
AND AND PEOPLE WOULD BE MORE
INCLINED TO WANT TO HAVE THEIR
CHILDREN ACCESS THEM AND USE
THEM FOR EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES
AND ALL OF THE WONDERFUL -- I
THINK YOU DESCRIBED IT AS AT
PHENOMENALLY POSITIVE BENEFITS
THAT THEY PROVIDE RIGHT AND I
THINK ABOUT GOING BACK TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE AUTOMOBILE
REQUIRING A COMPANY TO HAVE
A CAR SEAT FOR AN INFANT THAT
DOESN'T IMPACT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU CAN SELL CARS THAT DOESN'T
IMPACT THE PROFITABILITY OF
THOSE COMPANIES SO I JUST WAS
WONDERING IF YOU WERE YOU KNOW
COULD COMMENT ON THAT CERTAINLY
THERE ARE GONNA BE CASES WHERE
THAT PROFIT MOTIVATION IS
INTENTION WITH DOING WHAT'S
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
A LOT OF LOW HANGING FRUIT HERE
WHERE WE COULD MAKE SOME REALLY
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO PROTECT
YOUNG PEOPLE AND STILL ALLOW
FOR INNOVATION CREATIVITY AND
ALL OF THE WONDERFUL BENEFITS
OF THESE THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES IT'S A REALLY GREAT
QUESTION I THINK THE FIRST THING
WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES IS
ARE WE PAYING A PRICE FOR THEM
NOT DOING IT AND I THINK IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR HEALTH SYSTEM IN
SONG WITHOUT PAYING A PRICE YOU
KNOW WHAT PAYING A SOCIAL PRICE
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY PAYING OUT
A COST PRICE AT BAKER BECAUSE
HOMES COSTS I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE ALSO INTERESTING
WHICH IS IF YOU CANNOT MAKE THE
PRODUCTS SAFE YEAH BUT YOU'VE
GOT A CLUTCH ON THE MARKET
THAT'S MARKET FABIA BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF INNOVATORS
OUT THERE YOU KNOW AND START
UPS WOULD LIKE TO COME INTO THIS
SPACE BUT THEY CALMED BECAUSE
ACTUALLY IF YOU COME TO TREAT
PEOPLE WELL AND MAKE A PROFIT
THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR A SOUL AND
THEN FINALLY I THINK THERE IS
A QUESTION OF SUSTAINABILITY
AND I'M NOT AND IT WAS QUITE
PUBLIC YOU KNOW RECENTLY --
THAT YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE FOUND TO BE UNSAFE
ON AND GRAHAM AND WE'RE MOVING
OVER TO TAKE TALK AND THAT
HAD A HIT ON THE SHARE PRICE
AND SOMEONE'S ON THAT THAT
IS A COMPLEX PICTURE AND I'M
NOT GONNA SAY BECAUSE A FACT
BUT I DO THINK IT IS WORTH
LOOKING AT THE SUSTAINABILITY
PIECE I THINK THAT IS A COST
BUT THEN MAY ACTUALLY BE A
BENEFIT AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS
SHORT TERM LONG TERM YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT ALWAYS IN
THE SHORT TERM I THINK IN THE
LONG TERM AS A TRUST DEFICIT
AND YOU'RE NOT INDUSTRY WOULD
REALLY BENEFIT FROM MAKING
THESE CHANGES AT SOME COST
THIS IS ALWAYS BAFFLED ME ABOUT
THE INDUSTRY IS THAT NOT ONLY
IS JUST THE RIGHT THING TO DO
I'M ATTACHING THE SMART THING
TO DO -- AND I THINK IT IS SMART
IN TERMS OF LONG TERM PROFITS
INCIDENTALLY LOOK DOES ANYBODY
ACTUALLY LIKE FACEBOOK I MEAN
WERE YOU SAID I MEAN I DON'T USE
ABOUT THE PEOPLE USE THAT BUT
NOBODY REALLY THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF LOVE FOR FACEBOOK FACEBOOK
HAS TO PAY HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
SALARIES THE COMPANY BECAUSE
OF WHAT IS NOW BEING CALLED
THE REPUTATION TAX PEOPLE ARE
EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT THEY
WORK AT FACEBOOK WHEN I WAS A
A YOUNG PROFESSOR JUST STUDENTS
WHO GOT A JOB AT FACEBOOK WITH
TATTOO FACEBOOK ON THEIR FACE
THEY WERE SO PROUD OF IT NOW
THEY'RE EMBARRASSED THEY'RE
EMBARRASSED TO SAY THEY WORK AT
FACEBOOK THAT'S HUGE PRICE THAT
THEY ARE PAYING REPUTATIONAL E.
SO I THINK IT IS BEEN THIS IS
SORT OF WHAT WE KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ELSE RIGHT MORE
SCARED BECAUSE WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THE NEXT QUARTER IN
THE SHAREHOLDER MEETING WITH
PROFITS GOING TO LOOK LIKE A
JOKE WE NEED INCENTIVES RIGHT
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE NEED BUT
I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
INDIA AND THIS WILL BE GOOD FOR
EVERYBODY TO BE GOOD FOR KIDS
TO BE GOOD FOR SOCIETY BECAUSE
FOR CALIFORNIA AND WILL BE GOOD
FOR THE COMPANY'S BOTTOM LINE
BUT WE JUST HAVE TO GET THEM
OVER THAT FEAR -- THAT THEY
HAVE BADLY ONE OTHER GROUP WE
SHOULD TALK WITH OUR VENTURE
CAPITALISTS BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE REALLY DECIDING
WHICH COMPANIES MAKE AND WHICH
ONES DON'T AND THEY ARE ALSO
SPECTACULARLY RISK AVERSE TO
NEW BUSINESS MODELS AND SO
THEY KEEP FINDING THE SAME
THING OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN RIGHT THE SAME BUSINESS
MODELS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND I'D LOVE TO SEE
MORE DIVERSITY AT THE VENTURE
SIDE AS WELL THE FUNDING SIDE
TO CREATE A BETTER ECOSYSTEM
MR TO YOUR POINT I DO THINK
THERE ARE SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS CHANGES THAT DO A LINE
COMPLETELY -- AND I THINK THERE
ARE TIMES WHERE -- NEW FEATURES
THAT OUR PRIVACY PROTECTIVE
THAT OUR SECURITY PROTECTIVE
FOR KIDS DO ALIGN WITH PROFIT
MOTIVES -- AND CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT AS AN ORGANIZATION WE TRY
TO PROACTIVELY WORK WITH THIS
BODY AND AND THIS LEGISLATORS
AND PLAN TO WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND MANAGERS COMMITTEE -- THIS
YEAR ON ON BILLS TO TRY TO FIND
WHERE THOSE AREAS ARE ON THAT
WE CAN BE COMPLETELY ALIGNED AND
AND PUSHED TOGETHER IN THE SAME
DIRECTION YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THAT I THINK I WELL I NORMALLY
WOULD SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUES
BUT I I I CAN VENTURE TO GUESS
THAT YOU -- IN THE INDUSTRY
WILL EARN A LOT OF GOOD WELL --
FROM PROACTIVELY TAKING STEPS
TO PRIORITIZE PROTECTING YOUNG
PEOPLE I THINK THAT'S GOING
TO RENEW A LOT OF GOOD WELL --
AROUND THE LEGISLATURE AND AND
CERTAINLY -- AMONG THE BROADER
PUBLIC AS AS THE PROFESSOR
MENTIONED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PANEL -- WE APPRECIATE
ALL VERY MUCH WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUTTING HIM BECOMES A
CRYPTO BILLIONAIRE TO VENTURE
CAPITALISTS HE WILL -- HE WILL
INVEST IN THOSE IN THOSE IN
THOSE OTHER PRODUCTS AT THIS
POINT I WANT TO TURN TO YOU --
PUBLIC COMMENT -- AND IF THERE
IS ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT WOULD
INVITE THEM FOR IT THIS TIME
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE
AND JUST REALLY WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR A SUPERB HEARING THOROUGH
AND THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS WE
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF AN UNPRECEDENTED YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT IS IMPERILING
OUR ENTIRE GENERATION OF OF
CHILDREN -- OUR CAT AND LOVES
WHAT THE BARONESS SAID THAT
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
DESERVE BETTER AND THAT WE CAN
AND SHOULD ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
OF ADDICTION AND HARMS TO
OUR YOUTH ARE OFFERING THAT
SUPPORTS AND ASSISTANCE OF THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL TO FIND SOLUTIONS
TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND MAKE
INTERNET PRODUCTS SAFE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MARVIN BEYOND A WITH COMMON
SENSE MEDIA AND -- I'LL JUST
ECHO IT CAN JUST IT FROM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SEEING AND NO ONE ELSE --
IN THE HEARING ROOM WISHING
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
TO WE HAVE ONE MORE PLACE
THANK YOU SO MUCH DAVID J. WITH
A SET OF HUMAN TECHNOLOGY --
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
SOMETHING THAT WAS TO TELL
TIMES AT THIS HEARING I ENGAGE
EVERY DAY WITH TECHNOLOGISTS
INSIDE A MAJOR PLATFORM TO
TECHNOLOGISTS WHO ARE INNOVATING
AND THERE IS A THERE IS A
UPS WELL OF BRILLIANCE
ENGINEERS AND DESIGNERS WHO
WANT TO BE INNOVATING IN A
WORLD WHERE THEY INCENTIVIZE
PROTECTING CHILDREN THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THIS
THAT WOULDN'T SING OUR
FINAL CALL WE ARE CLOSED I
I'M GONNA TURN OVER TO THE
OPERATOR I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANYBODY ONLINE BUT --
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
ONLINE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND HAVE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANY OTHER MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE CLOSING REMARKS
ALL RIGHT I THINK EVERYBODY
IS A WE'VE WE'VE HAD A LONG
HEARING SO I WOULD JUST SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS WE WOULD REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE TIME TO BE WITH US SHARING
YOUR EXPERTISE EXPERTISE AND
YOUR VOICE IS ONE I THINK AGAIN
THE STAFF WHO HELPED ORGANIZE
THIS -- I GUESS WHAT I WOULD
OFFER IS THAT I BELIEVE THIS IS
REALLY JUST THE BEGINNING OF A
CONVERSATION -- I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS COME TO THE
ATTENTION OF A LOT OF MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE WE ARE HEARING
ABOUT IT FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IT AS
PARENTS WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
IT AS POLICY MAKERS AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE UPDATING OUR LAWS AND OUR
REGULATIONS AND OUR STANDARDS
TO PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE AND
ONE THING THAT IS GOING TO
STICK WITH ME FROM THIS HEARING
IS THIS SORT OF ARTIFICIAL
DISTINCTION THAT WE'VE CREATED
BETWEEN THE REAL WORLD IN THE
ONLINE WORLD IT IS CLEAR FROM
ALL THE DATA WE'RE SEEING THAT
OUR CHILDREN ARE SPENDING JUST
AS MUCH TIME IF NOT MORE TIME --
IN THE DIGITAL WORLD AS THEY ARE
AND SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW
DO WE PROTECT THEM WHEN THEY'RE
IN SCHOOL HOW DO WE PROTECT
THEM IN PUBLIC PLACES HOW DO
WE PROTECT THEM WHEN THEY'RE
RIDING IN THE CAR WE ALSO HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE SAFE AND THAT
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING IS CARED FOR WHEN THEY'RE
ONLINE SO WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
LEARNING THAT WE'VE DONE TODAY
AND WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU EVERYBODY